WELL GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TODAY. AND I
ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK YOU SEE
RIVERSIDE.
FOR FOR THE UNIVERSITY'S
HOSPITALITY AND HOSTING THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AND FOR WORKING
SO CLOSELY IN SO WELL WITH MY
TEAM. A TO MAKE TODAY'S HEARING
A SUCCESS WHICH I KNOW IT'S
GOING TO BE.
THIS IS THE FOURTH HEARING OF
THE AND I GUESS I SHOULD FOR
SUCH AS A MEANS MARC BERMAN.
AND ON THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
THE TWENTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WHICH IS A LITTLE
FURTHER UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SO I FLEW DOWN THIS MORNING.
AND THIS IS THE FOR HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THIS HEARINGS BEING RECORDED
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR VIEWING
ONLINE ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
WEBPAGE WHICH CAN BE FOUND ON MY
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN TAM.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY CALIFORNIA
DEVELOPED A VISIONARY PLAN FOR
THE FUTURE HIGHER EDUCATION
KNOWN AS THE MASTER PLAN.
HOWEVER MUCH HAS CHANGED SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY.
POPULATION GROWTH INCREASE
STUDENT DIVERSITY
CHANGE IN LEADING INDUSTRIES AND
THEIR NEED FOR TALENT.
AS WELL AS THE FIELD OF
EDUCATION ITSELF.
REPRESENTING SILICON VALLEY I
SEE HOW QUICKLY TECHNOLOGY IS
ADVANCING ALONG WITH THE RISE OF
NEW INDUSTRY.
BOTH HAVE ALTERED STUDENT NEEDS
AND BOOSTED DEMAND FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
WE NEED OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM TO RESPOND TO A HOST OF
ISSUES.
NEVER PREVIOUSLY ENVISIONED.
MY GOAL FOR THE SELECT COMMITTEE
IS TO HOLD HEARINGS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND WE HAVE ALL
HEARINGS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND CONDUCT A THOROUGH
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A MASTER
PLAN AND HIGHER JUST AND A
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR
TODAY AND FOR THE FUTURE.
WE NEED TO KEEP THE STATE'S
PROMISE TO OUR STUDENTS
PROVIDING ACCESSIBLE.
AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE IS THE
FIRST STEP IN A MULTI YEAR
ENDEAVOR TO UPDATE THE MASTER.
I'M COMING IN WITH AN OPEN MIND
AND DO NOT HAVE ANY PRECONCEIVED
NOTIONS OR SOLUTIONS AND I
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO DO
THE SAME.
I DO THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE IS BEING THE
INFORMATION GATHERING PHASE
WHERE WE HEAR FROM STAKEHOLDERS
AND COLLECT FEEDBACK WHICH IS
WHAT WILL BE DOING TODAY.
OF A SELECT COMMITTEE HELD ITS
FIRST HEARING LAST YEAR ON
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST IN
SACRAMENTO.
WHERE WE HEARD AN OVERVIEW AND
STATUS OF HIGHER EDUCATION FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AS WELL AS FROM THE LEADERS OF
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION?
INSTITUTIONS
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE CSU
SYSTEM THE UC SYSTEM AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS.
THE SECOND HEARING HELD ON
NOVEMBER FIRST OF LAST YEAR AT
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY.
FOCUSED ON CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
AT THIS HEARING WE HEARD FROM
ACADEMICS AS WELL AS THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ABOUT THE
WORKFORCE SKILLS GAP THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA AND THEY WILL
BE FACING. OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
THE THIRD HEARING HELD ON MARCH
FIRST OF THIS YEAR AT FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE FOCUSED ON THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
WE HEARD POWERFUL TESTIMONIES
FROM STUDENTS DISCUSS THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE.
BASIC NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
HOUSING. AS WELL AS EQUITY IN
STUDENT SUCCESS.
WE ALSO HEARD FROM THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HIGHER EDUCATION CONSORTIUM. AND
FROM REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE U.
CCS YOU AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING
THE NEEDS OF.
IN ADDITION TO TODAY'S HEARING
OUR FIFTH ARE HEARING IN LAST
HEARING WALL I BELIEVE LATER ON
THIS YEAR TO EXAMINE THE COSTS
AND FUNDING ISSUES.
IN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION IN A
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING FINANCIALLY.
AFTER THE CONCLUSION OF THE
HEARINGS THE SELECT COMMITTEE
WILL ISSUE A REPORT LIKELY AT
THE END OF THIS YEAR SUMMARIZING
THE HEARINGS AS WELL IS
RECOMMENDING THE NEXT STEPS.
SUCH AS WHAT ISSUES NEED TO BE
FOCUSED ON IN MORE DEPTH.
TODAY BUILDS OFF OF OUR PREVIOUS
STUDENT HERE.
WE HEARD FROM STUDENTS ABOUT
THEIR NEEDS AND NOW WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
FACULTY AND STAFF ABOUT WHAT
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL CONSIST OF
THE FOLLOWING FOUR PANELS.
THE FIRST PANEL WILL DISCUSS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
ACADEMIC INITIATIVES.
THE SECOND PANEL WILL DISCUSS
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY
AND LECTURERS PROVIDING A UNION
PERSPECTIVE.
THE THIRD PANEL WILL DISCUSS THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS SERVICES STAFF.
IN THE FOURTH PANEL WILL DISCUSS
THE NEEDS OF STAFF.
ALSO PROVIDING A UNION
PERSPECTIVE.
THERE WILL ALSO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THE HEARING WE'VE
A SIGN UP SHEET FOR FOLKS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN THE SIDE
OF SHEET IS.
UPSTAIRS AT THE REGISTRATION
TABLE AYE WITH ELIZABETH SMITH
FROM MY OFFICE.
THIS LIKE COMMITTEE HAS A
MEMBERSHIP APPOINTED ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS AND WE'RE
REALLY FORTUNATE TO BE JOINED BY
MY FRIEND.
YOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE
MEDINA ITS SHARE OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND AND LATER ON WE'LL BE JOINED
BY DOCTOR WEBER A PROFESSOR WHO
TAUGHT IT SEEN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
BOTH OF THEIR STRONG BACKGROUNDS
AND EXPERTISE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION WILL BE INVALUABLE
TODAY'S HEARINGS THEY'VE ALSO
BEEN INVALUABLE TO ME.
AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND I WILL BE INVALUABLE
OVER THE COMING YEAR.
HAVE THE THE THE MORE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER.
THAT MR MEDINA OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE ANY OPENING
REMARKS AND.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WELCOMING
US YOUR DISTRICT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
THIS MIGHT.
THERE WERE GO WELL GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH TWO.
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN.
IT TOOK. NOT TOO MUCH ARM
TWISTING TO TO GET HIM TO COME
HERE TO UC RIVERSIDE AND AND. BY
THE DAY AND THE WEATHER OUTSIDE
AYE I THINK IT WAS A GOOD CHOICE.
IT'S A GREAT PLACE.
GRAY PLACE TO RAISE A FAMILY AND
I'M PROUD TO BE A YOU SEE ARE
ALLOWED. AND I JUST WANNA I WANT
TO WELCOME ALL HERE THIS MORNING.
TO THE BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS OF UC
RIVERSIDE.
I WHERE I GRADUATED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WHEN WE WERE A
LITTLE BIT SMALLER CAMPUS.
BUT I SEE A LOT OF FRIENDS AYE
IN THE AUDIENCE A LOT OF FOLKS
THAT I GO BACK WITH A LONG TIME
AS A STUDENT HERE. AT UC ARE SO
WELCOME A TO THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE HERE THE STUDENTS WHO AYE I
SEE.
IN SACRAMENTO STUDENTS WHO
DROVE FROM RIVERSIDE TO OUR OUR
HEARING IT FRESNO CITY COLLEGE.
GLAD TO HAVE YOU BACK.
AS THE CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
I KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
WORK THAT ASSEMBLY BERMAN IS
DOING AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE MASTER PLAN.
I I'VE BEEN THE CHAIR FOR ABOUT
FOUR YEARS AND I SEE THAT THE
DOCUMENT THE MASTER PLAN THAT
WAS WRITTEN IN NINETEEN SIXTY.
AS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN SAID
NEEDS UPDATING BECAUSE AS HE
SAID MUCH AS JANE.
AND WITHOUT A VERY STRATEGIC A.
GOLD PLAN A WE FLOUNDER.
AND.
AND THE DIFFERENT.
.
SEGMENTS
OF PUSH AGAINST EACH OTHER.
AND OTHER MAY BE GOOD. THAT MAY
BE GOOD YOU KNOW INNOVATION IS
GOOD BUT I THINK IT'S FOR THE
STATE IS. IT IT WOULD BE BETTER
TO HAVE A CONSISTENT PLAN AND I
I I I ALSO WOULD NOTE THE LACK.
OF AN OVER ARCHING ENTITY THAT
WE USED TO HAVE YEARS AGO AS WE
HAD THE POST SECONDARY
COMMISSION.
IT'S WE NO LONGER HAVE.
I WILL ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
ON MAY SEVENTH.
THE S. STAFF OF YOU SEE WILL BE
GOING ON STRIKE.
ASKED ME AND SUPPORT STAFF WILL
BE ON STRIKE AND I WILL BE AT UC
DAVIS.
MEDICAL SCHOOL JOINING THEM ON
THAT DAY.
I WILL HAVE STAFF HERE AT UC
RIVERSIDE
TO BE JOINING THEM AS WELL.
SO AT THE OUTSET I I WILL AND I
KNOW WE'RE BEING TAPED I WILL I
WILL ASK PRESIDENT APOLLO TIME
TO ACT QUICKLY.
WHEN SHE WHEN I FIRST MET WITH
HER.
I THINK ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO
SHE CAME ON AS PRESIDENT OF UC
SHE ASKED ME WHAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WHAT IS THE
THING THAT I COULD DO. TO HELP
YOUR JOB IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I WILL REPEAT WHAT I TOLD
HER FIVE YEARS AGO AND THAT IS
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
STUDENTS. TO HAVE US STAFF
I AT ALL LEVELS THAT ARE.
YOU KNOW NOT HAVING TO WORRY
ABOUT THEIR JOBS NOT WORK HAVING
TO WORRY ABOUT THEIR PAY.
THEY ARE THE FIRST PEOPLE THAT
STUDENTS MEET. AND LOT OF TIMES
THE LAST PEOPLE THAT THEY MEET
DURING THE DAY SO. ARE WE HOPE
FOR A QUICK RESOLUTION OF THAT.
I I I KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT THE NEEDS OF STAFF
AND.
PROFESSORS HERE IN THIS PANEL
AS THIS CAMPUS HAS GROWN SO
QUICKLY I KNOW THAT.
SPACE HAS BEEN AN ISSUE.
AND THAT STUDENTS WE HEAR FROM
THE STUDENT SAYS STUDENTS WHO
CAME TO SACRAMENTO.
THIS WEEK SAID THAT THERE SIT
IN THE SAME CHAIR THAT I'M SAT
IN IN NINETEEN SEVENTIES OR
WORSE THAN THAT THAT THERE ARE
NO CHAIRS.
AND THAT THEIR FORCES SIT ON THE
FLOOR
SO I I I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
MORE ABOUT THE FACILITY NEEDS.
AND WITH THAT SAID I I WOULD
MAKE ANOTHER PLUG ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF FULLY FUNDING. I
UC AND CSU THIS YEAR.
I WHEN RECOGNIZE YOU ELECTED
OFFICIALS THAT ARE HERE THIS
MORNING.
FRANK REYES THAT COLLEGE
TRUSTEE IT'S AMBER TO DO YOU
KNOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND HAS BEEN TO OUR COLLEAGUE A
ELOISE REYES ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM
SAMBAR MEDINA.
ALSO WITH US IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE RIVERSIDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
BOARD OF PATRICIA LOCK BOX.
WELL NEWMAN I LOOK FORWARD TO A
GOOD DISCUSSION THIS MORE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR MEDINA.
AND WITHOUT LET'S THAT'S.
KICK OFF OUR FIRST PANEL THIS
BILL GOING TO BE A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND ACADEMIC
INITIATIVES.
AND IF OUR PANELISTS WILL COME
UP WE HAVE PROFESSOR JULIE BRUNO
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
I DO THINK MORNING.
WE HAVE PROFESSOR KRISTINE
MILLER CHAIR OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
MORNING.
WE HAVE PROFESSOR SHE IN WHITE
CHAIR OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ACADEMICS AND.
FOR JOINING US AND WE HAVE
DOCTOR SARAH CLOTS.
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR FOR
LEADERSHIP IN INSTITUTIONAL
TRANSFORMATION OF THE CENTER FOR
URBAN EDUCATION ROSSIER SCHOOL
OF EDUCATION UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AS A
GRADUATE OF THE WHAT LAW SCHOOL
S. C. FIND ON.
AND.
GUY LET'S LONG START OFF WITH.
JULIE.
AND THE.
.
FOLKS IF THE A LIGHT ON THE TOP
THE MIKE IS RED IT'S NOT ON.
PERFECT.
I GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MEDINA THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY.
I SERVICE THE PRESIDENT THE
ACADEMICS AND FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUTE COLLEGES. THE
ORGANIZATION TRUSTED BY
CALIFORNIA LAW TO BE THE VOICE
OF FACULTY
AN ACADEMIC AND PROFESSIONAL
POLICY MATTERS WE REPRESENT A
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND FULL AND
PART TIME FACULTY IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIVE SYSTEM.
I WILL FOCUS MY COMMENTS TODAY
ON THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
STUDENTS AS THEY REACH FOR THEIR
ACADEMIC AND CAREER GOALS.
FACULTY NEED ACCESS TO
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
THREE VERY SPECIFIC REASONS
TO MAINTAIN CURRENCY IN THEIR
DISCIPLINES TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES FOR
EFFECTIVE TEACHING AND LEARNING
AND TO FULFILL THEIR ROLES
RESPONSIBILITIES IN COLLEGE
GOVERNANCE AND SERVICE.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE SIGNED INTO
LAW THE REFORM BILL FOR
COMMUNICABLE EDGES AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FIVE IT MOVED OUR SYSTEM
AWAY FROM ESCAPE THROUGH TWELVE
ROUTES TO A GREATER CONSISTENCY
WITH OTHER SEGMENTS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION LIKE CSU AND YOU SEE.
ONE EFFECT OF THOSE CHANGES WAS
THE ELIMINATION OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CREDENTIAL WHICH WAS
SOMETHING LIKE WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE.
ESSENTIALLY AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
FIVE FOLKS ARE HIRING ON
COMPETENCY IN A DISCIPLINE.
ADDITIONAL TRAINING IN PEDAGOGY
WOULD BE LEFT TO PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
AT THE TIME THE LEGISLATURE
DISCUSS REQUIRED A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF COMMITTEE COLLEGE
FUNDING TO BE SAID SPENT ON
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL
STAFF
SIMILAR TO WHAT CORPORATION
SPENT ON TRAINING FOR THEIR
WORKERS ABOUT FIVE PERCENT.
THAT APPROACH WAS REJECTED IN
FAVOUR OF A DISTINCT CATEGORICAL
LINE ITEM FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WHICH UNFORTUNATELY
WAS ELIMINATED IN THE FIRST
THOUSANDS.
MUCH OF THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT CURRENTLY PROVIDED
BY THE STATE IS DESIGNED TO
TRAIN FACULTY ON IMPLEMENTING
STATE DIRECTED FITNESS
INITIATIVE SUCH AS THE STUDENT
SUCCESS IN SUPPORT PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO
CONSISTENT SUPPORT FOR FACULTY
TO MAINTAIN CURRENCY IN THEIR
AREA OF EXPERTISE OR TO IMPROVE
AND PEDAGOGY.
OF COURSE ALL COLLEGES SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TEAM
CONCEPT A FEW PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR ALL
FACULTY TO ATTEND EVENTS.
AS A RESULT FACULTY IN
PARTICULARLY PART TIME FACULTY
ARE FREQUENTLY LEFT TO BEAR THE
COST PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
ACTIVITIES WITHIN THEIR
DISCIPLINES.
TEACHING IS A FULL TIME JOB.
BUT WHEN WE OUT ON THE
REQUIREMENT FOR COLLEGE SERVICE
RESPONSIBILITIES OFFICE HOURS
AND OTHER JOB.
SERVICES FITTING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT INTO ALREADY TIGHT
SCHEDULES BECOMES DIFFICULT
ADVANCED.
COMPOUNDED WITH THE ADDITIONAL
COST IN A LACK OF SUFFICIENT
COLLEGE SUPPORT SUCH AS
PROVIDING SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS IS
QUITE CHALLENGING FOR FULL TIME
FACULTY TO ATTEND AN ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PART TIME.
TO PURCHASE.
WE PRIDE OURSELVES ON PROVIDING
HIGH QUALITY. AT INSTRUCTION LOW
COST ACCESS TO OVER TWO MILLION
STUDENTS ANNUALLY AND IN THE
PROCESS CREATE MIRACLES FOR OUR
STUDENTS
HOWEVER WE FAILED TO PRIORITIZE
THE MOST BASIC ASPECT OF
TEACHING AND LEARNING. WHICH IS
KNOWLEDGE CURRENCY FOR TEACHERS
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS PROFESSIONAL
DEPARTMENT.
OTHER PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SPECIFIC INITIATIVES MAY BE
VALUABLE FOR INSTITUTIONS IT IS
INSUFFICIENT FOR WHAT OUR
FACULTY NEED AND BY EXTENSION
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
THE STATE CAN ENSURE THE HEALTH
AND VITALITY OF HIGHER EDUCATION
BY INVESTING OUR MOST IMPORTANT
RECENT SOURCE. THE INDIVIDUALS
WORKING AT OUR COLLEGES
ONE ACTION THAT WOULD NOT
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD
BE TO DESIGNATE A PERCENTAGE OF
OUR BASE FUNDING BE ALLOCATED TO
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
ANOTHER ACTION THAT DOES REQUIRE
FUNDING NEW FUNDING WOULD BE TO
FIND THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT CATEGORICAL.
PROVIDING RESOURCES FOR THE
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT A FACULTY
WILL IMPROVE EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
COLLEGES AND SURE THAT WE ARE
READY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS.
I'D LIKE TO TURN OUR ATTENTION
NOW TO THE ISSUE OF FACULTY
DIVERSE.
THE ACADEMIC SENATE HAS LONG
BEEN IN SUPPORT OF INCREASING
THE DIVERSITY OF FACULTY TO
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STUDENT POPULATION. DOING SO IS
CRITICAL TO IMPROVING THE
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE OF ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE SCHOOL OF THE
STATEWIDE EONE DIVERSITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE DEVELOPED A
HANDBOOK ON BEST PRACTICES FOR
PROMOTING DIVERSITY IN THE
HIRING PROCESS.
SUBSEQUENTLY THE ACADEMICS AND
IN THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
WORKSHOPS ON IMPLEMENTING THOSE
BEST
SINCE
WORKSHOPS WERE WELL ATTENDED AND
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
MOST OF OUR COLLEGES.
THESE CHANGES WERE PUT INTO
PRACTICE WHEN COLLEGES HIRED
FULL TIME FACULTY USING A ONE
TIME ALLOCATION OF SIXTY TWO
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. WHICH
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITIES
IN FIRST TIME FULL TIME HIRES.
HOWEVER WE WILL NEVER ACHIEVE
THE RESULTS WE DESIRE FREE
CONTINUE RELY ON AN INTERMITTENT
APPROACH WHEN WE HIRE A GOOD
NUMBER FACULTY ONE YEAR BUT IN
OTHER YEARS EVEN WHEN THE STATE
BUDGET IS STRONG WE RELY ON OUR
PART TIME FACULTY. AND PERHAPS
REPLACE THE RETIREMENTS THAT WE
HAVE.
WE NEED A SUSTAINED EFFORT THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO MAKE REAL
PROGRESS.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE SET A
GOAL OF SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
CREDIT INSTRUCTION TAUGHT BY
FULL TIME FACULTY.
CURRENTLY OUR SYSTEM HOVERS
AROUND THE AN AVERAGE OF FIFTY
FIVE PERCENT.
THIS LOW PERCENTAGE OF FULL TIME
FACULTY HAS SOME VERY REAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND OUR COLLEGES.
HIRING FULL FULL TIME FACULTY
EVERY YEAR WOULD ALLOW US TO
MAKE PROGRESS ON THE SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT GOAL. IMPROVE THE
DIVERSITY OF THE ACADEMY AND
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS NEED FROM FACULTY OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS TO ACHIEVE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
AND WHEN WE DO HIRE PART TIME
FACULTY WE NEED TO HONOR THEM AS
PROFESSIONALS BY ENSURING THAT
THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT NECESSARY
TO TEACH OUR DIVERSE BODY OF
STUDENTS.
SUPPORT FOR ANY ANY FACULTY
MEMBER SHOULD INCLUDE OFFICE
SPACE TO MEET WITH STUDENTS
ADEQUATE COMPENSATION TO TEACH
AND SUPPORT STUDENTS SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THIS IDEA FREEWAY
FLYERS.
ACCESS TO HEALTH BENEFITS AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES.
IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO RECRUIT
OUR OWN STUDENTS TO COME BACK
AND TEACH AT OUR COLLEGES.
THIS MEANS THAT THERE MUST BE A
CLEAR PATH FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO SEE ES UN YOU SEE AS
WELL AS MENTORING AND PAID
INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
A CRITICAL COMPONENT IN THAT
PATHWAY IS SOME ASSURANCE THAT A
TEACHING POSITION OR SYSTEMS IN
OBTAINING A POSITION IS AND AS
AVAILABLE AT THE END OF THE PATH.
TAKEN TOGETHER THESE THREE
EFFORTS DEDICATED FUNDING TO
HIRE FULL TIME FACULTY
PARITY FOR PART TIME FACULTY AND
A PATH WE TO TEACHING IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WILL
ULTIMATELY PROVIDE A SUSTAINABLE
STRATEGY FOR IMPROVING THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR FACULTY TO THE
BENEFIT OF OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
COLLEGES.
TEACHING AS AN INTERPERSONAL
ENDEAVOR.
FUNDAMENTAL TO ITS SUCCESS IS
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN FACULTY
AND STUDENTS
FACULTY REMINDED DAILY OF THE
POWER OF THIS CONNECTION IN OUR
LEARNING SPACES BOTH FORMAL AND
INFORMAL. AND WE ARE DEEPLY
COGNIZANT OF THE NECESSITY OF
SUSTAINED INTERACTION BETWEEN
FACULTY AND STUDENTS AS THE MOST
MEANINGFUL FACTOR THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO STUDENT SUCCESS.
SUPPORTING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL FACULTY
WHILE IMPROVING THE DIVERSITY
AND NUMBER OF FULL TIME FACULTY
ARE COLLEGES WILL ENSURE A
VIBRANT AND ENGAGING COLLEGE
COMMUNITY WHERE STUDENTS WILL
ENJOY A RICH ACADEMIC LIFE ARE
PURSUING THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE AND I
WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PROFESSOR
BRUNO.
AND A PROFESSOR MILLER.
THINK YOU IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOUR DAY TALKING ABOUT THE
ROLE OF FACULTY DEVELOPMENT IN
THE MASTER PLAN.
YOU'VE ALL SEEN THE SIGN FROM
THE LONDON METRO MIND THE GAP
WHEN IT ADVANCES YOU'LL SEE IT.
UP MY CLICKER PERSON STEPPED
AWAY.
THERE WERE BY YOU SEE NOTHING
BEFORE ME IT'S ALSO A WAY FOR ME
TO DEVELOP DEMON REMARKS.
GONNA TALK ABOUT THE GAPS TO
MIND IN CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION GAPS IN SKILLS
ACHIEVEMENT COMPLETION FUNDING
UNFORTUNATELY I HAD TO EDIT THIS
TESTIMONY TO OMIT DISCUSSIONS OF
WORKFORCE AND TENURE DENSITY BUT
MAYBE WE CAN DISCUSS THEM DURING
Q. IN A.
THE FIRST HAPPENED GONNA DISCUSS
RELATES TO STUDENT BASIC SKILLS
AND HOW FACULTY DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS ADDRESS THESE GAPS.
SKILLS GAPS HAVE TO DO WITH THE
PREPARATION STUDENTS BRING WITH
THEM TO COLLEGE OR WHETHER
THEY'RE COLLEGE READY.
WITH THE CSU IS ADDRESSING
SKILLS GAPS BY PURSUING
DEVELOPMENTAL EDUCATION
INITIATIVES AS PART OF
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE.
COURSE IS FORMALLY KNOWN AS
REMEDIAL ARE BEING TRANSITIONED
INTO CREDIT BEARING EXPERIENCES
CONVERTING THESE COURSES IS
REQUIRED A GREAT DEAL OF FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT IN THE FORM OF
COURSE REDESIGN USING APPROACHES
LIKE SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION
AND STRETCH MODELS.
WEBINARS HAVE HOPE FACULTY TO
MAKE THESE CHANGES
IF YOU GO TO THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WEBSITE YOU'LL SEE
THIS SCREEN AND YOU CAN SEE THE
TOPICS COVERED IN THE WEBINARS
IN THE DROP DOWN MENU.
NOTICE THAT ARE IN THE KNOW EVEN
FACULTY PEPPER PATE REAL TIME IN
THE WEAPON.
IF THEY CAN WATCH OR REWATCH
LATER.
AND IF YOU EXPLORE THOSE
CATEGORIES YOU CAN FIND THE
NUMBER OF MEETINGS ON THE NUMBER
OF HOURS
JUST THIS YEAR THIRTY CHIU
WEBINARS HAVE BEEN OFFERED WITH
A HUNDRED AND FIVE HOURS OF
FACULTY DEVELOPMENT KATA.
IN SOME THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
FACULTY DEVELOP RELATED CLOSING
SKILLS GAPS AND HELPING STUDENTS
TO SUCCEED. CSU FACULTY ARE
MINDING THE GAP HERE.
THE NEXT GAP HAS TO DO WITH
GRADUATION RATES FOR
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS SUCH AS STUDENTS OF
COLOR SO I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
HOW FACULTY DEVELOPMENT IS HELP.
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AS IN A PROFOUND DEVELOPER CALL
VOLUME PRACTICES WERE HIPS.
HIPS THINGS LIKE STUDY ABROAD
SERVICE LEARNING INTERNSHIPS
LEARNING COMMUNITIES AND THE
LINK BETWEEN HIPS AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS CAN BE SEEN IN
EXAMPLES LIKE CSU NORTHRIDGE WHO
REPORT THAT LATINO STUDENTS ARE
TEN PERCENT MORE LIKELY THAN
THEIR PEERS. TO EARN A BACHELORS
DEGREE IF THEY DO JUST ONE HIP
AND IF THEY DO MORE THAN ONE THE
EFFECT IS CUMULATIVE.
BUT THERE'S A BIG HOBBY I HEAR
QUALITY MATTERS AND FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT MATTERS BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW YOU GET THE QUALITY.
THERE WAS A STUDY PUBLISHED IN
THE JOURNAL OF HIGHER EDUCATION
WHICH SAID OFFERING JUST
OFFERING AND LABELING AND
ACTIVITY AS A HIP. DOESN'T
GUARANTEE STUDENTS WILL BENEFIT
FROM IT WHAT IS EFFECTIVE IS
SUPPORTING FACULTY DEVELOPMENT
TO MAKE THEM HIGH QUALITY
EXPERIENCES AND THEN THEY CAN
REALLY MOVE THE NEEDLE ON THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
SO AGAIN REMINDING THE GAP ON
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT BY DEVOTING
RESOURCES TO HELPING FACULTY
DEVELOP HIGH QUALITY HIPS.
WE'RE ALSO PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION TO COMPLETION GAPS
WHAT WE WANNA SEE IS THAT WHEN A
STUDENT ENTERS THE INNER CITY
THAT PERSON.
WHATEVER PAYS FOR THAT.
WE'D RATHER NOT SEE THEM STOP
AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T PERCEIVE
ROB.
SO WE LOOK FOR.
YOU CAN PERSISTENCE RATES
WHICH ULTIMATELY CLOSES
COMPLETION GAPS.
ONE KEY REASON WHY STUDENTS
MIGHT NOT STICK WITH THEIR
EDUCATION IS COST INCLUDING THE
COST OF TEXTBOOKS.
SO THERE FACULTY DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES OFFERED THROUGH
ACADEMIC TECHNOLOGY INITIATIVES
AND I'LL RUN THROUGH SOME OF
THEM VERY QUICKLY.
THE ACADEMIC TECHNOLOGY STE A
SERVICES DIVISION IS DEVOTED
AMONG OTHER THINGS TO SUPPORTING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AS YOU
CAN SEE IN THE BLOCK BOXER Y..
TS FIRST INNING IN CONSULTING
DISS THE LINE TOOLS CONFERENCES
AND SO ON.
YOU CAN SEE HERE A WHOLE SUITE
OF RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
AND DESCRIPTIONS FOR EACH ONE.
ONE OF THE SIGNATURE RESOURCE
FOR FACULTY OFFERED BY THE
ANSWERS DOES IS THE CSU SUPPORT
LEARNING SOLUTIONS A. L. OTHER
SIGN PROGRAM.
IT OFFERS FREE OR LOW COST
DIGITAL TV RE PURSES TIGHTER
CURATOR AT THE BEST LEVELS OF
QUALITY OR MAINTAIN.
JUST LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THE PROGRAM A SAFE STUDENTS
SINCE IT STARTED IN TWENTY TEN
THE CSU ESTIMATES THAT THE TOTAL
STUDENT SAVINGS ON TEXTBOOKS
THROUGHOUT THE CSU HAS BEEN OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY. MILLION
DOLLARS.
KEY VENUE FOR A BIT AND HE'S OF
ABILITY PRINCES PORTAL CALLED
COOL FOR AN.
NOTICE THE TOP THIS IMAGE IT HAS
THE LOGO FOR ALL THREE SAID IT'S
A PUBLIC HIGHER PATIENT.
COOL FOR ED IS TRULY YOURS
MENTAL EFFORT THE ACADEMIC
SENATE'S OF COORDINATED FOR
SEVERAL YEARS ON THIS PROJECT.
IT'S PART OF AB SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT WHICH ALLOCATED THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
ADOPTION OF OPEN EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES OR OR A ARE. THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED IS ALMOST THERE ARE
THOUSAND. STOOD IN COURT ACTIONS
OF IT DID.
ARE CLOSE TO FOUR HAVE MILLION
DOLLAR WAS SAVED.
IN ONE SEMESTER.
SO I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT ALL
THREE SUSPECTS SEGMENT SENATE'S
ARE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
REDUCING TEXT BECAUSE FOR
STUDENTS BY INVOLVING OUR
FACULTY. IN WAYS TO KEEP COLLEGE
AFFORDABLE SO STUDENTS CAN
PERSIST AND COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE.
AT THIS POINT I HAVE TO EDIT MY
REMARKS SO I'D ASK YOU TO SKIP
SLIDE SIXTEEN THROUGH TWENTY TWO.
ON THE WORK FORCE IN TENURE
DENSITY GAPS AND A PICKUP WITH
SLIDE TWENTY THREE WHICH IS TO
FROM THE AND.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE EVERYTHING
I'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY COSTS
MONEY BUT LEAVE THE LAST COUNT
GONNA TALK ABOUT. THAT THE GAP
BETWEEN THE AMOUNT OF STATE
FUNDING WE. AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WE NEED TO OPERATE.
ALL OF THE INITIATIVES I'VE
TALKED ABOUT ART FREE AND YOU
GET WHAT YOU PAY FOR.
AS YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET BARELY COVERS A
THIRD OF OUR NEED AND DOESN'T
EVEN COVER OUR BASIC OUR MOST
BASIC MANDATORY COSTS.
IT ALSO DOESN'T FUND THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE WHICH IS
THE LYNCH PIN OF SO MUCH OF WHAT
I'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY.
WE BUILT UP A LOT OF MOMENTUM
WITH THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
WITHOUT FULL FUNDING THAT
MOMENTUM WILL BE STOPPED IN ITS
TRACKS AND WILL GO BACKWARD
COURTESY OF SIGNIFICANT CUTS FOR
EVERY CAMPUS.
THIS WOULD BE A TIME WHEN STATE
RESERVES ARE HUGE IN THE RAINY
DAY FUND THIS FALL IT
A FIVE LOGIC.
IT'S ALSO NOT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S WHERE THE
MASTER PLAN COMES IN.
THE MASTER PLAN IS A PERFECT
FLEXIBLE BLUEPRINT FOR PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION.
IT'S PROMISED ON A MORAL
IMPERATIVE THAT THE STATE SHOULD
EDUCATE ITS CITIZENRY.
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF EACH
SEGMENT WITHIN THE MASTER PLAN
IS TO FULFILL THE PUBLIC TRUST
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR MISSION.
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE
IN TURN IS TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES THAT THE SEGMENTS NEED
TO OPERATE WITHIN THE MASTER
PLAN.
SO FOR OUR PART WE'RE MINDING
THE GAPS IN SKILLS ACHIEVEMENT
COMPLETION WORKFORCE NEEDS AND
YOUR DEAD BODY. BUT ALL WE DO IS
ADVOCATE WHEN IT IS TO THE LINK
OUT.
WE NEED FUNDING TO CLOSE ALL
THESE GAPS WE NEED FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT TO CLOSE ALL THESE
GAPS
AND WE NEED ALL OF YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO MIND THE GAPS
WITH US.
BUT YOU THINK YOU PROFESSOR
MILLER AND AND MEN TO PRACTICE
TODAY'S ENTIRE HEARING BY SAYING.
EVERYONE OF THESE PANELS COULD
BE A TWO HOUR CONVERSATION.
AND I WISH THEY WERE.
ENFORCING WERE TRYING TO HIT
FOUR PANELS INTO ONE HEARING.
BUT IS REALLY VALUABLE FOR US
TO START THE DIALOGUE AYE AND
DEVELOP THOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
ALL THE PANELISTS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JAMMING. A
LOT OF VERY IMPORTANT
INFORMATION INTO INTO A SHORT
PRESENTATION.
BUT KNOW THAT THIS IS REALLY
JUST THE THE START BUT WE HAVE
REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOU KNOW ALL IN ALL YOU'RE
DOING TO PARTICIPATE TODAY AND I
WAS NOT THE MOST IDEAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
PROFESSOR WHITE PLEASE THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE FACULTY.
.
OF THE SIX STATES DIFFERENTIATED
RESEARCH UNIVERSITY THAT REWARDS.
IRAQI CHEMICAL PROFESSIONAL
DEGREES AND ALSO IN THE GROUND
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE OTHER
SEGMENTS.
AND IT DOES SO TO SERVE THE MOST
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY IN ITS
HISTORY.
AT THE UC FACULTY DEVELOPMENT
PRACTICES RELATED TO DIVERSITY
TRANSFER STUDENT SUPPORT ATAGO
GEE THAT MISSION ON NOT THINGS
MANDATED EXTREMELY TO THE
FACULTY. THERE ARE THINGS BETTER
THAT A BIRTH STE ORGANICALLY
FROM THE FACULTY TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF THE STUDENTS.
WHAT WE NEED?
WHEN WE ARE COMMITTED THE
UC'S PUBLIC MISSION WHERE HAVE
IT.
WE DO HAVE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
THEN SUMMARIZE SOME OF THEM.
I THINK WE COULD DO BETTER AND
TO DEVELOP.
.
SYSTEM.
WIDE.
TRANSPARENT CLEARINGHOUSE THAT
WOULD HELP TO BETTER.
SHARE THE RESOURCES TO HELP
AN INCREASE IN DIVERSIFY
REPRESENTATION.
WE HAVE ACCESS TO PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES BUT A
FAR BIGGER CHALLENGE IS ONE MORE
BASIC ONE. BOUT OF INSTITUTIONAL
RESOURCES.
I'M GOING TO SUMMARIZE A FEW
REPRESENTATIVE EXAMPLES OF.
INITIATIVES THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND FACULTY OF VARIOUS
FLAVORS.
UNLIKE APPEARS WE HAVE A HIGHER
PROPORTION.
TENURE TRACK FACULTY NOT A RANK
FACULTY AND A MUCH HIGHER
PROPORTION OF OUR COURSES ARE
TAUGHT. OUR BY LATERITE TENURE
TRACK FACULTY.
WE ARE GUIDED BY SINGLE ACADEMIC
PERSONNEL MANUAL THIS DEFINES
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
FACULTY MEMBER AND THE
UNIVERSITY. IT DOES NOT AS A
CAREER MANAGEMENT TOOL FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL LINKING THEIR LONG
TERM CAREER LONG DEVELOPMENT.
CONTRIBUTION DIRECTLY TO THE
UNIVERSITY'S MISSION.
YOU SEE UNIQUELY EMPLOYS
RIGOROUS CAREER LONG POST TENURE.
FACULTY REVIEW. YOU SEE FACULTY
ARE HELD TO HIGH STANDARDS IN
TEACHING AND RESEARCH.
THE ACADEMIC SENATE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DETERMINES ACADEMIC POLICY.
ADMISSION ENROLLMENT RETENTION
AND GRADUATION RATES FROM FIRST
JAN UNDERREPRESENTED. ENTRANCE
FOR STUDENTS ARE EXTREMELY HIGH
AND EIGHTEEN YOU TO STEM THE
RISE.
SPITE PROP TO A NINE.
THESE EFFORTS A FOUNDATIONAL TO
IMPROVING THE PIPELINE TO
DIVERSIFY THE.
THE STORY OF.
UC'S HIGH GRADUATION RATES MEANS.
HIGHER RETURNS ON ROMAN
INVESTMENTS.
NINE STUDENTS OUT OF EVERY TEN
WILL AND DEGREE.
THEY ARE PROUD OF OUR
UNPARALLELED SUCCESS ADVANCING
SOCIAL MOBILITY.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX THE
ACADEMIC SENATE RECOMMENDED
DIVERSITY STATEMENT THE BOARD OF
REGENTS WHO SUBSEQUENTLY ADOPTED
IT.
MORE RECENTLY THE ACADEMIC
SENATE INITIATED REVISION OF THE
ACADEMIC PERSONNEL MANUAL TO
READ. CONTRIBUTIONS IN ALL
LEVELS OF FACULTY ACHIEVEMENT
THE PROMOTE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
ADVERSITY SHOULD BE GIVEN DUE
RECOGNITION.
IN THE ACADEMIC PERSONNEL
PROCESS IN THE MERIT REVIEW
PROCESS IN THE PROMOTION PROCESS.
THAT SHOULD BE EVALUATED AND
CREDIT IS IN THE SAME WAY AS
OTHER FACULTY ACHIEVEMENTS.
DIVERSITY STATEMENTS ARE NOW
SORT. OF ALL APPLICANTS TO
FACULTY POSITIONS.
PRESIDENT'S POSTDOCTORAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM IS KEY TO
SPORTING DIVERSIFICATION OF THE
UC FACULTY.
IT HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IT'S
BEEN EMULATED ELSEWHERE
NATIONWIDE AND WORLDWIDE.
IT'S WAY TOO SMALL LAST YEAR WHO
GREAT HUNDRED APPLICANTS
I JUST TWENTY FOUR SLOTS.
NORMAL ATTRITION END IN LIKE AND
RENEWAL IS INSUFFICIENT TO MOVE
THE.
NEEDLE ON DIVERSIFYING THE
FACULTY FAST ENOUGH WE NEED TO
DO MORE.
IN MY OPINION GREATLY IMAGINING.
THE PRESIDENT'S POSTDOCTORAL
FELLOW PROGRAM WOULD REALLY MAKE
A BIG DIFFERENCE WE GOTTA DO
THAT.
THE BOARD OF ADMISSIONS AND
RELATIONS WITH SCHOOLS WE CALL
IT POOREST.
I IS AN ACADEMIC SENATE
COMMITTEE.
IT REGULATES THE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES OF ADMISSION TO THE
YOU SEE. ONE CURRENT EXAMPLE OF
BOARDS ENGAGEMENT IS THE WORK TO
IMPLEMENT.
THE BRAND BICU TRANSFERRED
GUARANTEE OF ADMISSION TO THE UC
SYSTEM THAT'S BUILT UPON THE
TWENTY ONE TRANSFER PATHWAYS
INITIATED BY THE FACULTY. TO
INCENTIVIZE AND REWARD GOOD
ACADEMIC PREPARATION WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY DETERMINED TO FULFILL
A MASTER PLAN TRANSFER
OBLIGATIONS.
THE STATE PROGRAM.
A DAVIS STRENGTH TO EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY USES TRAIN FACULTY
MEMBERS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
AND ADVICE ABOUT ACHIEVING.
EXCELLENCE EQUITY AND RECIPIENT
FACULTY RECRUITMENT.
ALL CAMPUSES HAVE SIMILAR
PROGRAMS.
TRAINING BY ANY PARTICIPANT
IN A FACULTY RECRUITMENT
COMMITTEE OF FACULTY SEARCH
COMMITTEE.
A IS A REQUIREMENT TO SERVE AND.
THAT WAY.
IN PEDAGOGY WE HAVE THE
INNOVATIVE LEARNING TECHNOLOGY
INITIATIVE OR I'LL TI.
SYSTEM WIDE EFFORT SUPPORTING
FACULTY TO HARNESS EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES ONLINE AND HYBRID
MODELS TO ASSIST YOU SEE
STUDENTS.
I BY HELPING THEM ACCESS ITEM ON
COURSES SATISFIED REAL
REQUIREMENTS GRADUATE ON TIME
IT'S PROVIDED HARD AND SOFT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CAMPUSES.
PROVIDED A SYSTEM WIDE ACROSS
CAMPUS IN ROMAN SYSTEM.
I AT SEARCHABLE DATABASE OF
STUDENTS CAN FIND THE COURSES
THEY NEED.
AND IT'S FUNDED DEVELOPMENT OF
SEVERAL HUNDRED COURSES AROUND
THE SYSTEM
OF COURSE EVERY CAMPUS HAS ITS
OWN.
ONLY CAMPUS GROWN EFFORTS THAT
WORK IN SYNC WITH I'LL T. I.
REMEDIATION GENERALLY IF YOU SEE
WE DO NOT OFFER REMEDIAL COURSES
INSTEAD WE DO THINK TWO THINGS
MORE IMPORTANT I THINK IN BETTER
ONE IS WE TRY TO ENSURE. THAT
OUR STUDENTS HAVE EXCELLENT
PREPARATION COMING IN EXAMPLE
WOULD BE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO CREATE AND UPDATE
THE ATG CURRICULUM.
ANOTHER ONE WOULD BE THE ENTRY
LEVEL WRITING REQUIREMENT YELL
W. ARE.
SO WE TRY TO MAKE SURE THE
STUDENTS ARE WELL PREPARED TO
COMPETE SUCCESSFULLY WHEN THEY
ARISE.
IF THEY'RE NOT INSTEAD OF SAYING
STOP AND HOLDING THEM UP.
UP FOR REMEDIATION WE DO
SOMETHING ELSE.
WE DO.
HAVE A COLLEGE LEVEL INTENSIVE
COURSES.
IN THOSE RELATED AREAS THAT THEY
WILL TAKE FOR CREDIT AND
PROGRESS.
SO THAT IS.
ARE ALTERNATIVE APPROACH TO
REMEDIATION.
YOU SEE FACULTY DON'T JUST DRIVE
OUR OWN PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
BUT. WE.
GENERATE.
MORE THAN TWENTY PERCENT OF THE
FACULTY OF OUR OWN UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS.
I HAVE ANOTHER THIRTY OR SO
EXAMPLES IN THE LONGER WRITTEN
HANDOUT.
.
WHAT CAN WE DO?
ALL THE LOW HANGING FRUIT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN PICKED THERE'S NOT
MUCH THAT WE CAN DO THAT WON'T
REQUIRE MORE FUNDING.
OUR REAL PROBLEM IS.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FACULTY TO
STUDENT RATIO.
IT STEADILY WORSENED OVER THE
LAST DECADES.
WE USE THE WHERE APPEARS THERE
A DECADE AGO ONE NOT ANY MORE
WE'VE LEFT FAR BEHIND.
SLIDE DIRECTLY CONNECTS
THE WORSENING OUR FACULTIES
RATIO.
WITH A DIM.
I MEAN. IN STATE FUNDING.
THINGS ARE TO PLEASE RELATED
INESCAPABLE.
SLIDE SHOWS A DECREASE INC FUNDS
FROM THE STATE OR LAST THIRTY
YEARS.
THIS SLIDE SHOWS.
ONE PERCENT DECREASE IN FULL
BATTLE RISKY.
IN THIS PLENTY OF.
THIS IS ONLY IN SCHOOL BEING
WRONG.
WE HAVE FACULTY ENGAGEMENT IN
GOVERNANCE AND IN DEVELOPMENT
FACULTY ARE ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATES.
IT'S PART OF OUR EXPECTED
BUTTONS
IT'S NECESSARY FOR OUR SMALL.
THE SUPPORT YOU CAN SEE IN THE
WAY IS THAT WE DEVELOP OUR
FACULTY.
WE WORK TOGETHER WITH OUR
SEGMENT CSU IN THE CCC. MASTER
PLAN HAS BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE IN
LA EACH SEGMENT EFFECT THE AND
THE LEAST DISCUSSED.
MUCH TO A PARTNER.
CCC AND CO TWO SYSTEMS.
MASTER PLAN CAN USED TO SERVE
WELL THE STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
STATE FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HAS FALLEN SHORT
BY MANY METRICS.
NOTABLY FUNDING PER STUDENT AND
STUDENT FACULTY RATIO.
SPECIAL DEVELOPMENT AND STUDENTS
SUPPORTER CONSTRAINED BY
STEADILY WORSENING STUDENT
FACULTY RATIO METRIC FOR BROAD
ACADEMIC TEACHING RESEARCH AND
SERVICE QUALITY.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT MUSIC
STRANDS ALL OF THOSE THINGS
REVERSING THIS TREND MUST BE KEY
PRIORITY STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PROFESSOR Y.
IT. AND DOCTOR CLOTS.
THANK YOU.
I JUST WANNA INTRODUCE MYSELF
BRIEFLY SO NOT ONLY AM I A
RESEARCHER AND SOMEONE WHO WORKS
ON POLICY AT THE CENTER FOR
URBAN EDUCATION.
I BUT I WAS A TEACHER FOR TEN
YEARS AND SO I THOUGHT BOTH IN
THE UC SYSTEM AS A GRADUATE
INSTRUCTOR FOR SIX YEARS AT UC
DAVIS. UP AND THEN I MOVED TO
BUTTE COLLEGE WHICH IS IN THE
NORTH STATE IN BUTTE COUNTY. I'M
WHERE I TAUGHT BOTH TRANSFER
LEVEL IN BASIC SKILLS ENGLISH
COURSES FOR THREE YEARS.
SO ALL OF MY COMMENTS ABOUT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT I HOPE
WE'LL BE ABLE TO BRING THOSE
THREE PIECES TOGETHER WHAT WE
KNOW FROM RESEARCH WHAT WE SAY
ABOUT POLICY. AND ALSO WHAT THE
PRACTICE OF BEING A FACULTY
MEMBER IN CALIFORNIA IS REALLY
LIKE.
I'M SO IT'S A GREAT PLEASURE TO
BE SPEAKING WITH A SELECT
COMMITTEE TODAY.
I WHEN I WORK COLLEGE IN
CALIFORNIA OFTEN TELL THE STORY
WE OWE OUR HER. AYE WHO'S ONE OF
THE KEY ARCHITECTS OF THE MASTER
PLAN I'M GONNA BE ACTUALLY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT A KILLJOY ABOUT
THE THE MASTER PLAN RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE THAT'S KIND OF MY ROLE
AS A RESEARCHER AND A SCHOLAR.
SO HE WAS THINKING BACK ON
DEVELOPING THE MASTER PLAN HE
WROTE AN ARTICLE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN YEARS
AFTER THE MASTER PLAN WAS
WRITTEN THIS IS WHAT HE SAYS.
HE CONSIDERS IN RETROSPECT THE
VAST EXPANSION OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO BE THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AS AN INSTITUTION OF
INTERNATIONAL ACADEMIC RENOWNED
WHAT IF YOU MEAN BY THIS.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
PERSISTENT OPPORTUNITY GAPS IN
OUR STATE'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM I ALWAYS THINK ABOUT THAT
IDEA OF THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE.
IT MEANS THAT THE MASTER PLAN
WAS DESIGNED TO BLOCK THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS FROM
ENTRY INTO THE HIGHEST SOCIAL
GOODS PROVIDED BY HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IN THE WORDS OF EDWARDS DEMING
EVERY SYSTEM IS PERFECTLY
DESIGNED TO TO GET THE RESULTS
THAT IT GET.
AND TODAY THOSE RESULTS HAVE
RACIAL IMPLICATION.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LATIN NEXT NATIVE AMERICAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER STUDENTS
MATRICULATING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE STUDENTS ARE SUBJECT A
DISPROPORTIONATE REMEDIATION AND
THEY COMPLETE DEGREES
CERTIFICATES AND TRANSFER GOALS
AT LOWER RATES THAN THEIR WHITE
AND ASIAN PEERS.
AT THE CENTER FOR URBAN
EDUCATION OUR RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT THESE EQUITY GAP ARE BUBBLE
OF. ACCESS NOT A PROBLEM IF THE
ABILITIES OR THE POTENTIAL OF
THESE STUDENTS.
SO HOW DO WE IMPROVE PRACTICE
I AM HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT OUR CENTER IS DOING IN THE
AREA OF PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
TO ENSURE THAT OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS ARE SERVING
MINORITY HIGHS RACIAL STUDENT
GROUPS EQUITABLY.
FACULTY ARE SUBJECT AREA EXPERTS
ARE PROFESSIONAL IDENTITIES
DERIVED FOR MANY YEARS OF
ENCULTURATION INTO OUR ACADEMIC
DISCIPLINE.
DESPITE EXPERTS THAT WE GAIN AS
I MET SOCIOLOGISTS HIS REAR.
BUT RARELY TRAINED IN THE KEY
COMPETENCIES THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO SERVE STUDENTS AN EQUITABLE
WAYS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT TAKE AWAY
AREA EXPERTISE IS INSUFFICIENT
TO ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE FACE IN HIGHER EDUCATION
TODAY.
AS FACULTY WE NEED TO BECOME.
INSTITUTIONAL EMPOWER MENT AGES
FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THIS MEANS LEARNING TO TEACHING
CULTURALLY SUSTAINING REYES TO
BUILD HIGHER LEVELS OF EQUITY
MINDED DATA LITERACY TO
UNDERSTAND OUR OUTCOMES DATA.
AND TO INTERROGATE ARE TAKEN
FORGET GRANTED POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THE BLOCK AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATIN NEXT NATIVE
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
STUDENTS FROM EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY.
GIVEN THE SHORT TIME THAT WE
HAVE TODAY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
JUST ONE AREA WHERE CENTER IS
LEADING PROFESSIONAL LEARNING.
EQUITY IN FACULTY HIRING.
RATHER THAN PROVIDING BEST
PRACTICES WE FOCUS ON BEST
PRACTITIONERS.
WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE HIGH
LEVELS OF CONTEXT SPECIFIC
KNOWLEDGE THAT FACULTY POSSESS.
AND PRIDE BRIEF ARTICLE FOR
FACULTY TO LOOK INTO THAT OWN
BEST.
IF YOU CAN ONGOING LEARNING
PROCESS PROFESSION EXPAND.
IT IS WIDELY ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
FACULTY HIRING IN CALIFORNIA IS
OUT OF STEP WITH THE DEMOGRAPHIC
SHIFTS THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
STUDENT IDENTITIES IN OUR STATE.
I QS BUILDING CAPACITY FOR
FACULTY TO IDENTIFY HOW RACIAL
BIAS IS KEEPING FACULTY
REPRESENTATION STATIC.
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY RECENTLY RELEASED A
REPORT SHOWING THAT DISPARITIES
BETWEEN STUDENTS BACKGROUNDS AND
THE PROFESSIONALS TEACHERS AND
LEADERS THEY ENCOUNTER THEIR.
CAMP SAYS
SO IT SLIDE YOU CAN III AT THE
UNDERGRADUATE DEMOGRAPHIC
REPRESENTATION IN THE STATE.
IN THIS SLIDE YOU CAN SEE THE
DEMOGRAPHIC REPRESENTATION OF
THE PROFESSIONALS IN HIGHER
EDUCATION BETTER CURRENT WORKING
IN OUR FIELD. THE PAST SMUDGED
THREE OF WHOM ARE WE.
WHY DIVERSITY IN OUR CURRENT
FACT
AND CURB THE STEREOTYPE THREAT
EXPERIENCED BY STUDENTS OF COLOR?
FACULTY OF COLOR ENHANCE THE
SENSE OF BELONGING THAT STUDENTS
OF COLOR CAN FEEL ON CAMPUS.
THEY PROMOTE POSITIVE AND CURB
NEGATIVE SOCIAL OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND FACULTY OF COLOR ARE MORE
LIKELY TO ADVOCATE FOR AND BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH.
DO YOU HAVE NOW COULD IN OVER
FORTY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES TO LOOK INTO
THEIR FACULTY HIRING PROCESS YOU.
TEAMS OF TEN LOOK AT DATA ABOUT
HOW CANDIDATES PROCEED THROUGH
THE HIRING PROCESS AND THEY ARE
NOT BY THE PRECISE POINTS WHEN A
POOL BECOMES LESS DIVERSE.
THEY LOOK INTO THE LANGUAGE OF
THEIR JOB ANNOUNCEMENTS AND SEE
HOW THEIR COLLEGE IS PRESENTING
THEIR VALUES AROUND RACIAL
EQUITY TO POTENTIAL HIRES.
THE TEAMS WORK TOGETHER TO LEARN
ABOUT IMPLICIT BIAS AND TO BUILD
INTERPERSONAL STRATEGIES TO
DISRUPT EXPLICIT BIAS WHEN IT
EMERGES IN HIRING COMMITTEE
MEETING.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING WIDESPREAD
CHANGES AND JOB ANNOUNCEMENTS
USED ACROSS THE STATE AFTER ONE
YEAR OF ENGAGING IN THIS
IMPORTANT WORK.
THIS IS ONE EXAMPLE OF OUR
METHODOLOGY FOR FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
WE CONVENE FACULTY FROM ACROSS
CAMPUS AREAS TO ENGAGE DEEPLY
AND DISCUSSIONS OF RACIAL EQUITY.
THEY BECOME RESEARCHERS INTO
THEIR OWN PRACTICE AND CHANGE
AGENTS WILLING TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEIR RACIALLY MINORITY HIGH
STUDENTS.
TO CONCLUDE I WONDER RESTATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT OUTSIDE OF THEIR
SUBJECT AREAS.
THE STATE SHOULD BE FUNDING MORE
PROGRAMMING FOR FACULTY TO COME
TOGETHER AND LEARN HOW TO BRING
CRITICAL RACE CONSCIOUSNESS INTO
THEIR PRACTICE.
ONE ACTION THE STATE CAN TAKE
THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE FUNDING IS
TO SHIFT THE LANGUAGE THAT WE
USE AROUND ACHIEVEMENT VERSES
OPPORTUNITY GAPS.
WE CANNOT BEGIN TO TALK ABOUT IN
ACHIEVEMENT GAP UNTIL WE ENSURE
THAT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS DO HAVE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE STOP
TALKING ABOUT THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP AS A PROBLEM OF STUDENT
MOTIVATION OR STUDENT
PREPARATION. AND INSIST IN NO
UNCERTAIN TERMS THAT OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE THE SOURCE OF
THE INEQUITIES THAT WE ARE
SEEING.
THIS REFRAMING HAS CHIU BENEFITS
THE FIRST IS TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
ATTEMPT TO CORRECT.
MANY CENTURIES OF GOVERNMENT
SPONSORED EDUCATIONAL INJUSTICE
FROM JIM CROW SEGREGATION TO
NATIVE AMERICAN BOARDING SCHOOLS
FOR LANGUAGE ERADICATION.
THE SECOND BENEFIT IS TO RE
FRAME EDUCATIONAL INEQUITY AS A
PROBLEM OF PRACTICE WITHIN THE
SPHERE OF INFLUENCE OF OUR
FACULTY.
A PROBLEM WITH A SOLUTION.
THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE THROUGH
REFLECTION AND PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING.
WE WILL NOT ACHIEVE THE AIMS OF
A JUST AND EQUITABLE SYSTEM
WITHOUT DISMANTLING OUR
EUPHEMISTIC LANGUAGE AROUND
RACIAL INJUSTICE.
CHALLENGING OUR MYTHS OF
MERITOCRACY AND RETHINKING THE
TAKEN FOR GRANTED PRACTICES OF
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
THANK YOU.
BUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CLIENTS AND FOR
EVERYBODY HERE TODAY AND ANYBODY
WATCHING.
ONLINE LATER ON ALL THE
MATERIALS ALL THE SLIDES THAT.
FOLKS OF PRESENTED TODAY IS
GONNA BE AVAILABLE ON MY WEBSITE
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN
A JOB DOWN MENU FOR FOLKS IF
THEY WANT IN THE FUTURE. I WOULD
THAT I WANT TO WELCOME MY
COLLEAGUE DR WEBER.
WHO JOINED US?
AS SOON AFTER WE STARTED TODAY.
THEN YOU GIVE HER A CHANCE TO
SAY THE OPENING WORDS I SHOULD
LIKE OR WE CAN JUST GET RIGHT
DOWN TO THE Q. IN A BECAUSE I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
TAKEN LONG NOTES. AND OFFER THEM
SPEAK TO A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
BEFORE AND I KNOW THEY HAVE A
LOT OF FUNDS.
SO I'LL START OFF WITH ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO JUMP IN.
WELL THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PANELISTS DUH LOT OF THE
INFORMATION LOT OF THOUGHT
PROVOKING.
.
INFORMATION PRESENTED. AS THE
CHAIR SAID MANY OF THIS ISSUES
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND I.
.
WOOD JUMPS IN A LOT JUMPS OUT AT
ME OF THE LACK OF FUNDING OF THE
STATE.
AND THE CORRELATION BETWEEN THE
LACK OF FUNDING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OF FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND THE CHANGE IN THE
RATIO OF STUDENTS TO FACULTY.
A WHEN I WAS A STUDENT HERE BACK
IN THE SEVENTIES WE WERE A.
.
I CAMPUS OF SIX THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND THAT WE HAD A AYE
I'M SURE A GREAT RATIO OF. A
STUDENTS TO FACULTY WAS ABLE I
WAS ABLE AS A STUDENT TO REALLY
GET TO KNOW. ON MY FACULTY HERE
AND I THINK THEY WERE ABLE TO DO
THE SAME.
AND THE EXPERIENCE.
I'M SURE IT IS DIFFERENT OF
WHEN WHEN THE IT STUDENT RATIO
TO FACULTY IS A SO MUCH HIGHER.
I AND AND I WILL.
YOU KNOW TAKE RESPONSIBILITY. A
FOR THIS UNIT FOR THE STATE.
.
I CAN'T.
I'VE SAID BEFORE WE CAN'T TAKA
AT BOTH ENDS OF OUR OF OUR
MOUTHS AND YOU KNOW.
.
CRITICIZE CRITICIZE WHILE NOT
FUNDING SO THAT THAT IS A TAKEN.
AYE I AM VERY. TAKING NOTES.
PROFESSOR.
CLOCKS
NO IT'S NOT CORRECTLY UP WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT THAT WE GET THE
SYSTEMS THAT.
WE.
HELP ME HERE THAT WE THAT WE
DECIDE THAT WE DESIGN.
A WE HAD A HEARING ON.
.
OF FACULTY DIVERSITY AT SAN JOSE
STATE AND I'LL REPEAT THE.
STATEMENT MADE BY UC FACULTY
ASTRONOMER DISTINGUISHED FACULTY
WHO SAID THAT WE DON'T NOT HAVE
THE DIVERSITY ON AND HIGHER
EDUCATION. UP BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT TO.
WAS THE STATEMENT HE SAID.
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE ARE LAUDABLE.
MANY OF THEM.
HERE AT UC RIVERSIDE CLUSTER
HIRING.
.
THE STATEMENT.
A PROFESSOR THAT YOU MENTIONED
THE STATEMENT OF OUR DIVERSITY
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO TEACH.
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATION
REQUIRING THAT DIVERSITY
STATEMENT AS PART OF THE
APPLICATION. I MENTION IN
SACRAMENTO CLUSTER HIRING THAT
IS TAKING PLACE HERE AT UC
RIVERSIDE. I KNOW THAT.
CHANCELLOR WILCOX WAS ABLE TO
HIRE A BELIEVES SEVEN NATIVE
AMERICANS FACULTY IN THE LAST
YEAR SO LOTS OF VERY LAUDABLE
THINGS.
HOWEVER.
I WOULD POINT OUT.
GOING OUT TO A DOCUMENTARY THAT
I SAW RECENTLY THAT GOES BACK
FIFTY YEARS.
FIFTY YEARS TO BACK TO NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. WHEN STUDENTS
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE.
UNIVERSITY.
STUDENTS AT CORNELL UNIVERSITY
IN VERY UNCERTAIN TERMS.
A PROTESTER.
FOR THE SAME THINGS THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT FIFTY YEARS LATER.
LACK OF.
AMONG IN IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND SO I AS AS MUCH AS I APPLIED
ALL SEGMENTS FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING. AND CONTINUING
WORK AND THE GREAT PROGRAMS.
SOME OF WHICH ARE ARE GOING TO
BE UNDER FUNDED.
THIS YEAR.
PROGRAM OF THE POST DOCTORAL.
AS
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM IS IS GONNA
BE CUT IN HALF
THIS YEAR WHERE IT RECEIVED
MAYBE TWO MILLION IT WOULD
RECEIVE. ONE MILLION THIS YEAR
AND THESE PROGRAMS COST MONEY
WHY ARE WE. NOW GONNA UNDER FUND.
EVERY YEAR AND WE HAVE WITH US A
SUBPOENA CONTROLLER EVERY YEAR
WE FIGHT TO MAINTAIN THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WE KNOW ARE
WORKING PROGRAMS LIKE WEDNESDAY
AND MESS. WE FIGHT EVERY YEAR TO
KEEP FUNDING THEM.
SO I I I AM.
.
YOU KNOW I I'M NOT EVEN SURE
WHAT WORDS TO SAY DID THE THAT
THE FIGURES AS WELL IF WE LOOK
AT THE PROGRESSION OF A DIVERSE
FACULTY HIRING.
SPECIALLY WITH WITHIN UC. ARE
FLAT.
OUR FLAT.
IT WE LIVED FROM YEAR TO YEAR
GOING BACK FORTY FIFTY YEARS.
AYE. SHARED WITH A DOCTOR WEBER
THAT IN THE FALL I INTEND TO
HAVE A HEARING SPECIFICALLY. ON
THE LACK OF DIVERSITY IN UC
BECAUSE I I THINK WE COULD TALK
ABOUT IT FOR THREE FOUR HOURS.
AND THAT'S WHAT I INTEND TO DO
IN THE FALL COME BACK TO YOU SEE
ARE TO HAVE. A AYE HEARING ON
THE LACK OF DIVERSITY FACULTY IN
UC.
A BUT THANK YOU ALL TO.
TO ALL THE PANELISTS AND.
CERTAINLY THESE ARE THINGS THAT
WE CAN TAKE BACK WITH US TO
SACRAMENTO.
I WANNA.
ALL FOR.
I KNOW.
AND. WILL BE NOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF FIRST WON'T APOLOGIZE OF
STUCK IN A TRAFFIC ADDED NO THE
JUST THE BOTTLE NICK OF TIME.
RATE. YOU SO CLOSE YOU COULD SEE
IT BUT YOU CAN'T GET THERE ONE
OF THOSE KIND OF REALITIES.
BUT.
YOU I'M I APPRECIATE BEING HERE
THIS MORNING AND.
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT I I
SPENT FORTY YEARS AS A PROFESSOR
OF AFRICANA STUDIES IT'S ENABLE
STATE UNIVERSITY OF THE FOUNDER
OF AFRICAN STUDIES. AND A BOOK
WITH WILL PROFESSOR AT SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY. ARE AND.
CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY.
AFTER MY RETIREMENT IT'S AN
EAGLE STATE WHERE CONTINUE TO.
REALLY WORK IN AND DO
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAMS I'M OUT
OF WORK WITH THE SEVERAL OF YOU
OVER THE YEARS IN TERMS OF THE
ONGOING STRUGGLE. OF WHAT IS
PRESENT.
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO BRING A
CHANGE TO THE SYSTEM.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND
I'M PLEASED THAT THE.
THAT THE ACADEMIC THE CHEERS OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE ARE HERE ON
THIS PANEL BECAUSE.
YOU PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
DETERMINING OUR WHAT HAPPENS UP
OUR OWN ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES IN
THE SYSTEMS THAT I APPRECIATE.
DR KLOTZ'S OP COMMENTS BECAUSE
AS WE MADE OUR EFFORTS AT THE
UNIVERSE AT THE AT THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO BRING
CHANGE WERE OFTEN. CONFRONTED
WITH THE WITH THE IDEA OF THE
NOTION THAT THESE INSTITUTIONS
ARE RUN BY THE FACULTY.
THAT IS A FACULTIES WILL WITH
THE PUT TALKING DIVERSITY AND
FACULTY THE TALKING CHANGING
CURRICULUM. AT THE TALKING A
REQUIREMENTS OF ETHNIC STUDIES
OF ALL STUDENTS TO A COME TO THE
UNIVERSITY. OF WHERE I AND AND
AS A LEGISLATURE THOSE ARE
THINGS WE CAN WORK ON A TRIP AND
MANDATE WERE OFTEN. CONFRONTED
WITH THE NOTION OF WHAT WORLDS
OFTENTIMES MIS USE OF THE WORD
ACADEMIC FREEDOM WHICH IS NOT
WHAT THAT'S ABOUT. AND THAT'S
WHY IT TO CLARIFY THAT RECENTLY
BUT THE NOTION THAT THESE
INSTITUTIONS ARE COLEGIO
INSTITUTIONS AND THEY ARE. THAT
ARE RUN BY FACULTY. THAT THE
ISSUES OF CURRICULUM AND HIRING
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS GOAL
TO THE FACULTY.
I AND HAVING BEEN IN THAT SYSTEM
IN THOSE POSITIONS OF PERSONAL.
OWN PERSONAL COMMITTEES AND
WHAT HAVE BEEN HIRING THINGS
THAT IS TRUE. SO FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AS CHEERS OF THESE
ACADEMIC IS SENATE'S WHICH
EVERYBODY PAYS HOW MUCH DO. I
SERVE IN ACADEMICS AND SO I
DON'T PAY AS MUCH HOW MUCH AS
EVERYBODY ELSE.
IT SIX OR SEVEN YEARS I CAN
REMEMBER LAW PART OF MY.
SEEM LIKE ON ACADEMIC SENATE.
SO WHAT DO YOU. WHAT DO YOU SEE
AS OTHER THAN FUNDING BECAUSE AT
DEFINING WHAT THE KEY I'D
PROBABLY GO FIND THE MONEY FOR
YOU BUT?
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE KEY TO?
CHANGING THE DYNAMICS.
OF ALL OF THESE INSTITUTIONS
AROUND THE ISSUE OF HIRING AND
RESEARCH WAS EVEN THOUGH WE CAN
SAY.
THE ACTIVITIES YOU ENGAGE IN
FOR DIVERSITY OR WHATEVER SHOULD
COUNT LIKE THE OTHERS.
ANYBODY IN ITS INSTITUTION KNOWS
IS A VERY BEAUTIFUL WORDS.
BUT IN THOSE PERSONNEL
COMMITTEES WHAT I'VE SAID.
I PEOPLE SAY YES IT'S WONDERFUL
THAT THEY'VE GONE OUT AND AND
RESCUE ALL THESE KIDS OF THEIR
WORKING WITH THEM IN THERE
HELPING THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL
HOWEVER.
THEY SHOULD OF DONE ONE MORE
ARTICLE.
AND SO THEY DID TO THE GUY WHO
DID NOTHING THE A THREE.
AND THE THREE GETS PROMOTED INTO
A NEED AND A TWO PERSON GETS A A
A SAY YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO GET
ENOUGH ARTICLE AND BLAH BLAH
BLAH AND SO. IN SOME SMALL WAY.
AND WHICH IS REALLY LARGE OF
THE EMPHASIS IS IS SAID AND IN
MANY WAYS IT THIS IS UNIMPORTANT
IN THE REAL WORLD.
AND THE WORLD OF TENURE
PROMOTION AND RESOURCES WORKING
WITH THESE POPULATIONS IS NOT
THAT IMPORTANT.
IT'S IMPORTANT BUT IT'S NOT
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T COUNT IN IN
IN TERMS OF HOUSEHOLDS CAN.
FOLKS IN WHO THEY CELEBRATE WITH
A LOT WHEN THEY BECOME THE DEAN
WHO BECOMES WHATEVER ELSE THAT
USED TO BE WE KNOW WHO GETS THAT
SO HOW DO WE CHANGE THAT.
AS YOU FOLKS ARE.
SHARES OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE.
WHICH ACCORDING TO AND BEING
TOLD VALUE PRESIDENTS AND
CHANCELLORS THAT IF YOU FOLKS
SAID IT WOULD HAPPEN. THAT'S
WHAT THEY TELL US WHICH I KNOW
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS TRUE EITHER
BUT WHAT WOULD YOU WHAT WHAT DO
I MEAN WHAT CAN WE DO TO CHANGE
THAT DYNAMIC BECAUSE EVERYBODY
KIND OF SHIFTS THAT EVERYBODY
ELSE.
NO WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
FIGURING OUT HOW YOU GONNA MOVE
THESE INSTITUTIONS TO TO REALLY
OPEN UP TO THE POPULATION OF
STUDENTS WERE HERE. AND TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
WHAT WHAT WHAT. IF THERE WAS ONE
THING YOU COULD THINK ABOUT THAT
WOULD CHANGE IT WHAT WOULD IT BE
SINCE.
LIKE I SAID YOU GUYS AT YEARS OF
ACADEMIC SENATE.
WELL.
THANK YOU I WISH THAT WE DID
HAVE THE POWER THAT YOU THOUGHT
AND YOU HAVE.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR YEARS
OF SERVICE.
.
I I SEE A A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
ONE IS IT'S A CHICKEN AND EGG
SITUATION.
WE'VE GOT TO DO BETTER WITH THE
PIPELINE.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY.
FUNDAMENTAL.
WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE THE PERFECT
STORY AT MACADAM THE THAT
REPRESENTS AND IS REFLECTIVE OF
THE PEOPLE.
THE GETTING THERE.
IS THE HARD BIT.
WE HAVE SAID WHAT WE WANT
WE HAVE SAID WHAT OUR IDEALS ARE
WE HAVE ENCODED. IN OUR
PRACTICES THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIVERSITY IN CONTRIBUTIONS TO
DIVERSITY.
WE'VE GOT THAT IN THE APPLICANT
HAVING IT RISKY STATE.
WE'VE GOT ABOUT IN OUR.
APPRAISAL OF THE APPLICANT.
I THINK WHAT PROFESSOR CLARK
SAID IS.
WE GOT TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE
A PROBLEM AND THAT WE ARE THE
PROBLEM.
I BELIEVE WE DO BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN MAKING THOSE CHANGES.
TO OURSELVES.
SO IT'S A CHICKEN AND EGG.
WE GO TO BREAK THE CYCLE WE'VE
GOT TO HAVE A BETTER PIPELINE.
AND I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT.
THE FACULTY SENATE MAY GET TO
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S THE ADMINISTRATION.
WHO MAKE THE HIGHER?
WE MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND ADMINISTRATOR MAKES THE
HIGHER.
SO THE LEADERSHIP AT ALL LEVELS
WHETHER IT SENATORS OR
ADMINISTRATIVE.
DEAN OR CHANCELLOR HAS GOT TO
LIVE THAT.
TO.
SO I GUESS IN A WAY.
I'M NOT PASSING THE BUCK BUT I'M
SHARING IT.
A WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
I WOULD ALSO SAY WE GOT ANOTHER
EXAMPLE.
AT UC.
OUR STUDENT BODY AS LONG.
IN WAITED TOWARDS FEMALE GENDER.
BUT.
BUT THE NEXT STEP GRAD SCHOOL WE
LOSE SOME OF THAT AT THE NEXT
STEP POSTDOC WE LOSE SOME OF
THAT.
AT THE NEXT STEP FACULTY WE DO
SOME OF THAT.
NOW WE HAVE.
BABY FOR PRESIDENT LAST YEAR WE
HAD.
A LADY AS PROVOST.
WE HAVE.
TWO LADIES AS COUNSELORS.
WE'RE GETTING THROUGH THAT.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO.
RIGHT THIS THING AND IT'S A
CHICKEN AND EGG THING.
IT'S VERY VERY HARD TO DO BUT I
REALLY SEE THE PIPELINE. WE'VE
GOT TO PUT OUR RESOURCES INTO
THAT PIPELINE.
I HOPE I'M HELPING. YOU CONTEXT
AND ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION.
YOU ARE.
GOOD COULD I FOLLOW UP ON AYE
AYE REFERENCE THE YEAR NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT.
SINCE THEN.
NO DOCTOR WEBER.
I HAVE GOT THROUGH.
GOT HER DOCTORATE AT UCLA.
THERE ARE MANY MORE LIKER.
WHO GRADUATED AND GOT THEIR
DOCTORATES FROM OUR INSTITUTIONS
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA?
SO IS IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
NUMBER OF.
QUALIFY.
.
FOLKS WITH WITH P. H. D.'S HAVE
VASTLY INCREASED.
OVER THE LAST FIFTY YEARS.
BUT STILL THE NUMBER OF FACULTY
REMAIN. THE SAME SO I I I I I
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WANTING TO
TO.
INCREASE THE PIPELINE BUT I WAS
A STUDENT HERE. AND I I GOT MY
MASTERS HERE. I I ACTUALLY.
BEGAN THE SKI HD PROGRAM HERE
IN HISTORY AND I HAVE.
AND HAD A LOTS OF FRIENDS.
WHO LOOK LIKE ME?
YOU KNOW SOME OF WHOM WENT ON TO
FINISH THEIR P. H. D.'S.
SOME OF WHOM ARE TENURED.
IN IN DEPARTMENTS OF HISTORY
HAD AT IRVINE. OF BUT NOT ENOUGH.
SO I I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT JUST
BE KNOW.
FIFTY YEARS AGO WE WERE SAYING
THE SAME THING. WE WERE ST FIFTY
YEARS AGO THAT THERE WERE NOT
ENOUGH.
BUT BUT THERE HAVE BEEN THE
NUMBER HAS HAD TO HAVE INCREASED.
AND IN THE IN THE POOL AS THEY
SAY.
I'M CAN I SPEAK BRIEFLY TO THAT
THE PIPELINE QUESTION BECAUSE
IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT WORKING WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO I KNOW THAT THAT THE
UC IS OF COURSE A VERY DIFFERENT
CONTACTS.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU WE HEAR THE
SAME EXACT ARGUMENTS EVERY TIME
WE SPEAK TO FACULTY FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ABOUT WHY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I'M HAVE A SUCH A VAST MAJORITY
OF WHITE FACULTY THAT HAS NOT
BUDGED IN ANY SUBSTANTIAL WAY IN
THESE YEARS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. ON AND WHAT SO WHAT WE
DID OUR CENTER IS WE WENT AND WE
FOUND IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO MEETS
THE MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS WHO
IS AFRICAN AMERICAN AND NATIVE
AMERICAN LATIN NEXT PACIFIC
ISLANDER. AN ASIAN AMERICAN IN
THE STATE FROM THE CS YOU AND
THAT YOU SEE SYSTEM. SO WE
ACTUALLY CREATED A POCKET FOR
ALL OF OUR FACULTY TO SHOW THIS
IS YOUR POOL AND IT'S ACTUALLY A
MASSIVE POOL SO THEY HEARD
SOMETHING ELSE THAT IS GOING ON.
ARE YOU IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM WHERE THE REQUIREMENT TO
TEACH IS A MASTER'S DEGREE.
ARE YOU GOING FOR THAT WHITE
CANDIDATE WITH THE PHD AND IF
YOU ARE DEAD Y..
WHAT ARE THE WAYS YOU NEED TO
REPHRASE? YOUR NOTION OF MERIT
SO THAT YOU CAN BE SURE THAT YOU
ARE ACTUALLY FULFILLING THE
NEEDS OF YOUR STUDENTS.
I'D LIKE TO JUST CHIME IN I
FIGURED YOUR SPOT ON AND AND I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS AT LEAST
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE. WHEN YOU LOST ME
ON THE ARTICLES FOR TENURE AND
ALL THAT RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT FOR US. ARM AND IS
ABOUT THE TEACHER RIGHT AND WE
ARE COLLEGES OF OF TEACHING.
SO I THINK REALLY THE
CONVERSATION IT HAS TO BE A
MORAL IMPERATIVE.
IT HAS TO BE THE IDEA THAT THIS
IS A MORAL IMPERATIVE AND SO WE
HAVE GOT TO START EXAMINING OUR
PROCESS SEIZE WE'VE GOT TO
REDUCE THOSE BARRIERS WE HAVE
GOT TO THAT POOL IS OUT THERE.
AND WE HAVE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
WHY WERE NOT RECRUITING APPLE
HOWEVER NOT RECRUITING THAT PULL
TO GET IN SO THAT WE WIDEN. THAT
PULL THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND
ENSURING THAT WE ARE HIRING
THOSE THAT ARE READY TO MEET OUR
STUDENTS AND AND AND THAT'S
REALLY.
WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT I DO I DO
THINK ALSO THERE HAS TO BE THIS
CHANGE IN THE WAY THAT WE TALK
ABOUT TEACHING AND LEARNING AND
PEDAGOGY?
AND WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO
CRITICAL PEDAGOGY AND AND AND
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
AMONGST OURSELVES AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY RELEASED WHEN WE LOOK
AT WHAT'S HAPPENING.
FOR FACULTY IN THE
COMMUNICATIVE JUST.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE COURAGE TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS TO
CONFRONT.
OUR COLLEAGUES AND OUR PRACTICES
AND WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET RID OF.
THE STUFF THAT IS NOT SERVING
OUR STUDENTS AND REALLY FOCUS ON
WHERE WE NEED TO SERVE THEM. AND
SO THAT.
THAT TAKES
TIME AND IT TAKES ON SPACE
TO DO AND SO I THINK REALLY IF
WE CAN FIGURE OUT.
AND AND AND JUST CREATE THAT
SPACE AND I THINK WE'RE REALLY
STARTING TO I THINK THE WORK.
THAT AND Q. IS DOING I THINK THE
WORK THAT OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE IN THE ACADEMIC SENATE SO
I THINK THE WORK THEY WERE DOING
AROUND THE GUIDED PATHWAYS AWARD
PROGRAM. IS ACTUALLY PART OF
THAT IS BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER
TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT ARE WE
CREATING AS BARRIERS.
BUT. IT IT IT'S IT HAS TO BE AN
INSTITUTION WIDE AND BECAUSE OUR
COLLEGES OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
BASED INSTITUTIONS THAT WORK IS
FOR THEM TO REALLY DIGGIN INTO.
BUT I TAKE MISTER MEDINA'S POINT
IT'S BEEN FIFTY YEARS WE'VE HAD
THAT MORAL IMPERATIVE EVEN BACK
THEN IS WHAT'S NOT THE MERE
MORAL IMPERATIVE THAT'S CHANGED.
I WOULD SAY WHAT'S THE BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN FIFTY YEARS
AGO AND NOW IS WHETHER WE CAN BE
MORE INTENTIONAL ABOUT IT.
AND INTENTIONALITY A LOT OF THE
RIVER THE THINGS THAT DRIVE
FACULTY IS DATA. WE HAVE DATA
DASHBOARDS NOW THAT WE NEVER HAD
BACK FIFTY YEARS AGO WE HAVE THE
DATA LIKE THE THE THE.
THAT SLIDES THAT HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TODAY THAT SHOW THE FOR
THE THE SITUATION AND WE CAN
POINT TO THAT RATHER THAN
ANECDOTES.
WE KNOW FOR INSTANCE THAT THAT
STUDENTS TELL US I SUCCEED
BETTER WHEN I SEE SOMEONE LIKE
ME UP IN FRONT OF THE CLASSROOM
AND THAT'S IT ANECDOTES. WHEN WE
CAN WHEN WE CAN TAKE DATA AND
PUT IT TO THOSE ANECDOTES IT
GIVES US MORE AMMUNITION TO BE
INTENTIONAL. AND ONCE WE CAN GET
INTENTIONAL ABOUT IT WE CAN
REWARD.
SO WE CAN REMOVE THEM FROM A
REWARDING FOR INSTANCE
PUBLICATIONS TO RIP TO REWARDING
HOW MANY STUDENTS OF COLOR HAVE
YOU HELPED THIS YEAR.
THAT KIND OF THING WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY NOW BEGIN TO TRACK IT
AND AND HOPEFULLY BEGIN TO
REWARDED SO THE MORAL IMPERATIVE
IS STILL THERE AND I THINK IT'S
IT'S STRONG. IT JUST NEEDS TO
HAVE SOME BACKING TO IT NOW WITH
THE REWARD STRUCTURE IN MORE
INTENTIONALITY.
I'D I'D I THINK YOU YOU YOU.
.
I THINK CLEARLY INTENTIONALITY
IS CRITICAL BECAUSE.
IF YOU DON'T MAKE THAT YOUR
GOAL. A TO DO YOU WON'T NEED IT
BECOMES NO MORE THAN OPEN
STATEMENTS.
AND I THINK ALSO WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES IN AND I'M SURE YOU DO.
WHY IS IT THAT THOSE WHO COME
DON'T STAY SOMETIMES?
IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH THE THE
FACT THAT THE ENVIRONMENT IS NOT
ALWAYS WELCOMING.
A YOU CAN'T EXPECT TO INFUSE
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR INTO
AN INSTITUTION AND EXPECT THEM
TO ACT LIKE MEN WERE WHITE. OF
THEY BRING A DIFFERENT KIND OF
FLAVOR AFFECTED THEM. ALL A
DIFFERENT ATMOSPHERE TO THE
CAMPUS AND THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT
STUDENTS ARE TRACKED A TO DO.
BOB AND SO IF YOU IF YOU IF YOU
ARE COSTLY LOOKING FOR THOSE
FACULTY OR YOUR COLLEAGUE WHO
LOOKS LIKE YOU WHO MAY NOT LOOK
LIKE YOU WOULD ACT LIKE YOU.
THEN YOU END UP.
BASICALLY BRINGING PEOPLE INTO
A INSTITUTION WHICH WE OFTEN DO
THAT HAVE LITTLE RELATIONSHIP TO
THE STUDENTS AT ALL. OKAY AND SO
I I DIDN'T ADMIT IT'S NOT ONLY
YOU IT'S ALSO K. TWELVE AND
EVERYBODY ELSE AND SO I THINK WE
HAVE TO MAKE REALIZE OF ONCE YOU.
DECIDE THAT THE INSTITUTION.
NEEDS TO BE INFUSED WITH THAT
WITH A DIVERSE FACULTY ARE
DIVERSE CURRICULUM WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT IVORY
TOWER WOULD NO LONGER BE IVORY
COLORED ANYMORE.
IT WILL BE YOU KNOW MAYBE
JAMAICAN COLORED OR WHATEVER BUT
IT WILL NOT BE THE SAME AND THAT
AND AND I FOUND AS A FACULTY
MEMBER. ON THE SENATE AND CHAIR
OF THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT THIRTY
YEARS AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
THAT WAS PROBABLY THE GREATEST
CHALLENGE THAT PEOPLE WANTED
FOLKS THERE BUT THEY WANTED THEM
TO ACT LIKE THEM. AND I'D REMIND
THAT THIS IS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALE HE DOESN'T ACT LIKE THE
OTHER ONES AND HE'S IT AND THE
STUDENTS ARE TRACKED IT TO HIM
BECAUSE HE HAS A SWAGGER TO HIM
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
EXCITING. UP HIS CURRICULUM YOU
KNOW HIS SUBJECT MATTERS IS
CLEAR HE TEACHES A CLASS HE
KNOWS MATERIAL WHAT HE MAY BE A
LITTLE LOUDER IN THE HALLWAY
THAN SOMEBODY ELSE OR WHATEVER
IT MAY BE. AND SO WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IF YOU'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF CHANGE IT IS
GOING TO CHANGE IT IS NOT GOING
TO LOOK LIKE WHAT YOU WANT TO
LOOK LIKE. AND I THINK THAT MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE IS THE
HARDEST PART A I'D YOU KNOW AND
AND AND AND. AND AND IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE WHEN I WAS
ON THE FACULTY. WE WOULD HAVE
FOLKS WHO WOULD DIE GO OUT WITH
EVERY INTENTION TO HIRE A PERSON.
AND BRING THEM TO CAMPUS AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
BRING THEM TO CAMP WAS
INTRODUCED INTO THE FACULTY
INTRODUCED INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THEN I WOULD
LEAD.
THEY WOULD GET HOME THEY WOULD
CALL ME BECAUSE SOMEBODY SAID
DID YOU MEET GOT THE WEBER GOOD
CHEER FOSCA SAID NO. AND SO THEY
WOULD CALL ME AND SAY I DIDN'T
MEET ANY BLACK PEOPLE WHAT I WAS
ON CAMPUS.
WHERE IS THAT BLACK LIFE THAT
I'M GOING TO BE A PART OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT I'M GOING TO BE A
PART OF TO? AND SOMETIME AND AND
I MENTION THAT TO COLLEAGUES ARE
SO WHAT WE DON'T THINK THAT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT. WHAT IS
IMPORTANT YOU HIRING AFRICAN
AMERICANS KNOW THAT THERE'S AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN
SAN DIEGO THERE'S ONE ON CAMPUS
FACULTY AND STAFF? AND THAT THEY
MAY WANT TO BE A PART OF IT
BECAUSE AND THEN THEY REALIZE I
COULD NOT ONLY TEACH HERE BUT I
CAN LIVE HERE AS WELL. AND SO I
THINK YOU KNOW THE RECOGNITION
AND AND AND REALLY TRYING TO
CHANGE THE DYNAMICS OF OF
INTERVIEW PANELS AND. WHO YOU
TAKE FOLKS TO SEE AND WHEN YOU
BRING AROUND THE CAMPUS THERE'S
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
HAVEN'T MAKE A TREMENDOUS CHANGE
IN THE PERSON SAYING YES I WILL
CALM?
I HATE TO CUT THIS UNLESS
THERE'S ENOUGH.
THAT'S THE BAD NEWS THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT EVERYTHING IS GOING
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
YEAH A COUPLE MONTHS RIGHT BACK
YOU'RE YOU SEE OUR.
AND.
WILL LET ME GET AS A TO GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WERE WERE
ONLY TWENTY THREE MINUTES BY
SCHEDULE.
OF WHICH HAS AS WAS BEING THE
FOURTH HEARING OF GOTTEN USED TO
BY NOW.
BUT LET'S BRING UP OUR SECOND.
PANEL OF OF FOLKS
WE'RE GONNA SPEAK TO THE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY AND
LECTURERS FROM A UNION
PERSPECTIVE. I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE DR JONATHAN MCCLOUD
PROFESSOR OF HISTORY IN VICE
PRESIDENT AT OF AFP GUILD LOCAL
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
INTRODUCE APPLICANT YOU DO SO I
DOCTOR SHARON ELISE
FOR PRESS OUR SOCIOLOGY AND
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT SOUTH
OF COUNSEL FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AT THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION. ARE DARK AND DOCTOR
MEDIA MCIVER WRITING PROGRAMS
LECTURE AND PRESIDENT OF
UNIVERSITY COUNCIL AMERICAN
FEDERAL AT THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION. OF TEACHERS THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH OF FOR JOINING
US HERE TODAY.
AND IF DOCTOR MACLEOD IF YOU'D
LIKE TO KICK US OFF.
JONATHAN.
IF YOU TAKE THE LITTLE BUTTON ON
TOP THERE THANK YOU I'M JONATHAN
CLUB I'M A PROFESSOR OF HISTORY
AT SAN DIEGO MESA COLLEGE MORE
I'VE BEEN ON THE FACULTY FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
AND I'M ALSO VICE PRESIDENT
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
FOR THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GROSSMONT CUYAMACA
COLLEGES.
SO THANK YOU.
TO THE COMMITTEE MARC BERMAN IS
CHAIR JOSE MEDINA AND MY FELLOW
SAN DIEGANS SHIRLEY WEBER FOR
INVITING ME.
IN FRAMING THE MASTER PLAN FOR
CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
NINETEEN SIXTY CLERK HER TO FIND
A FORMAL STRUCTURAL RELATIONSHIP
AMONG THE THREE YEARS OF JUNIOR
COLLEGES STATE COLLEGES IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
CURRENT VISION BOTH SOCIAL
INCLUSIVENESS INSTANCE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
THE CULTURAL ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE
IN RESEARCH AND NOT WAS A
MARRIAGE MERITOCRATIC SYSTEM.
AT THAT MOMENT.
IN MANY WAYS.
THIS VISION SEEMED TOO FEW
OPTIMISM THE STATE OPTIMISM
WHICH.
INFLUENCED.
PUBLIC ATTITUDES TOWARD THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA FOR.
SOMETIME.
FROM THE VANTAGE POINT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS APPARENT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEMS HAVE STRENGTHS
IN OFFERING STUDENTS LIFE
CHANGING OPPORTUNITIES AND
ACADEMIC AND CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. AND IN ADVANCING
SCHOLARLY RESEARCH.
YET THE GREAT PLAN WHICH CLARK
HER.
ARTICULATED HAS STALL
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS INCLUDED
HAS BEEN MENTIONED IN SOME WAYS.
BY PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
LIBERTARIAN INSURGENCY AND THE
ANTI TAXATION MOVEMENTS SINCE
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
THE DESTABILIZING RISE OF THE
SUPER RICH ENTREPRENEURS
CONCENTRATED IN THE SILICON
VALLEY.
AND THE CONCENTRATION OF WEALTH
AMONG THE NEW ELITE NOW SOME OF
THOSE NEWLY MONIED VENTURED
PHILANTHROPISTS.
CORD OPPORTUNITIES WITH
POLITICIANS AND EDUCATIONAL
LEADERS IN THE TOP RANKS OF THE
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS
TO PROMOTE THEIR BRANDS.
AND VARIOUS PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
EDUCATIONAL REFORM.
BUFFETED BY THESE FORCES COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY FACULTY.
FACE MARGINALISATION
FACULTY CONTENDER IN THE PUSH TO
BOOST ENROLLMENT INCREASE
STUDENT RETENTION AND SUCCESS
RATES LEADING TO DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES FOR TRANSFER AND
EMPLOYMENT.
THAT THEIR VOICES ARE NOT HEARD.
AND THEIR PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE
AND PRACTICAL KNOWLEDGE OF
STUDENT NEEDS IS DISREGARDED
WHOLESALE.
TODAY I FOCUS ON WHAT THIS MEANS
FOR THE FACULTY IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I START BY POINTING OUT. THAT
DESPITE SOME NEGATIVISM IN SOME
CORNERS THE SUCCESSES.
OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
VERY REAL IF YOU STATISTICS
ILLUSTRATE MY POINT.
IN ACADEMIC YEAR TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ROLLED THROUGH
POINT ONE FIVE MILLION STUDENTS
THAT WITH A LARGE THAT IS THE
LARGEST SYSTEM IN THE UNITED
STATES.
MAYBE IN THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
UC TRANSFERS.
INCREASED BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN TWO THOUSAND SIX
INCREASED BY SIXTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS FOR A TOTAL OF SIXTY
ONE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE STUDENTS.
SOME FIFTY ONE PERCENT OF CSU
GRADUATES IN TWENTY NINE PERCENT
OF YOU SEE GRADUATE STARTED IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE GRADUATES
ENTERED THE LABOR FORCE IN IN
EARNED WAGES WHICH ONLY AVERAGE
WERE HIGHER THAN THOSE PAID TO
EMPLOYEES.
LACKING ANY COLLEGE DEGREES.
EVERYDAY THE OAK COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANKS MICK AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY THINGS
MANY HURDLES.
IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
STUDY BY TEMPLE UNIVERSITY IN
THE WISCONSIN HOPEFULLY AB.
WHICH INCLUDED THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
SAMPLING INDICATES THAT FORTY
TWO PERCENT OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
CONTENT HOUSING INSECURITY FORTY
TWO PERCENT.
AND THAT FORTY SIX PERCENT
SUFFER FROM FOOD INSECURITY.
MEANWHILE CSU LEADERSHIP NOW
RECOGNIZES THE URGENT NEED FOR
ENHANCE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHICH STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
REQUESTED.
STATE LEGISLATURE REPORTEDLY IS
CONSIDERING MANDATING AN
IMPROVEMENT IN THE RACIAL MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS TO SEE US USED.
THE NEEDS IN THE MUCH LARGER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM ALMOST
CERTAINLY ARE EVEN GREATER.
THE SYSTEM IS GROSSLY
UNDERFUNDED TO MEET THE DEMAND.
ACROSS THE U. S. WE STRUGGLE
WITH ILLITERACY AND IN NUMERACY.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY SIX APRIL
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT THIRTY FIVE
MILLION ADULT AMERICANS ONE
SIXTH OF THE POPULATION CANNOT
READ AT THIRD GRADE LEVEL.
MOST ARE WHITE EUROPEAN
AMERICANS.
THE PORTIONS OF THESE AMERICANS
LACKING LITERACY SKILL OUR
GREATEST AMONG LATINOS FORTY ONE
PERCENT. IN AFRICAN AMERICANS
THIRTY TWO PERCENT.
DURING MY THREE DECADES OF
TEACHING IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
APPROXIMATELY TWO THIRDS OF OUR
INCOMING STUDENTS.
HAVE BEEN ASSASSINATING
DEVELOPMENTAL TRAINING IN
READING WRITING AND NUMERACY.
LET ME BE CLEAR THAT ALL OF THE
STATISTICS DESCRIBE REAL PEOPLE.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SO YES WE FACULTY FACE MAJOR
HURDLES BUT WE LACK THE FULL
SUPPORT NEEDED TO ADVANCE OUR
STUDENTS EDUCATION.
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE BEEN
THE ONE AND THEN THE
INSTITUTIONAL RESPONSES OVER
TIME.
INSTEAD OF A PREDICTABLE REVENUE
STREAM THE COLLEGES WERE FORCED
TO CHASE ENROLLMENT.
DEMONSTRATE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR.
THAT WE ARE BEING PRODUCTIVE AND
DESERVING OF OUR FULL PORTION.
GIVEN IS THE CONTINUOUS EBBING
AND FLOWING OF ENROLLMENT
SPECIAL NOW IN THE NUMBERS
GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
IS. TREATMENT.
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT DRIVEN
DECISIONS OFTEN LEAD TO
IMPROVEMENT POLICIES.
THE ADVERSELY AFFECT BOTH
STUDENTS AND FACULTY TRYING TO
SERVE THEM.
GOVERNOR BROWN'S PROPOSAL FOR
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING ONLY
ADDS INSULT TO INJURY.
SINCE THE MID NINETEEN SEVENTIES
THE GROWING RELIANCE OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES ON CONTINGENT
FACULTY TO TEACH STUDENTS WHILE
PER POLLING TENURE LINES IS BEEN
A DIRTY SECRET.
IS DATA FROM A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
STATEWIDE I INDICATE DURING FALL
OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
THE HEAD COUNT OF OF THE ADJUNCT
FACULTY EMPLOYED THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WAS FORTY TWO
THOUSAND FOURTY FOUR.
OR SIXTY NINE POINT THREE
PERCENT OF THE TOTAL YOU
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HEAD COUNT OF
SIXTY THOUSAND SIX THIRTY THREE.
LIMITED TO ASSIGNMENTS OF SIXTY
SEVEN PERCENT OF A FULL LOAD PER
ACADEMIC YEAR IN ANYONE DISTRICT
MANY OF THE AYE JACKSON URBAN
AND SUBURBAN AREAS HAVE
ASSIGNMENTS AT MULTIPLE
DISTRICTS SIMULTANEOUSLY.
EVEN WITH THOSE PAYCHECKS MOST
ADJUNCT FACULTY STRUGGLING MEET
THE COSTS OF LIVING.
IT'S APPALLING.
THE ADJUNCT FACULTIES.
STILL ACCOUNT FOR FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
FACULTY.
GENERALLY AS WELL.
THE ADJUNCT FACULTY ARE ABLE TO
TAKE ON THE LITTLE IF ANY
SERVICE WORK WHICH MEANS PROGRAM
REVIEW CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT.
AND REVISION INDUSTRY AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH
AND THE NEVER ENDING
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORTING.
FOR THEIR DEPARTMENTS.
CONSEQUENTLY THE TENURE LINE
FACULTY ARE LEFT WITH MORE THAN
THEIR FAIR SHARE OF THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES AS WELL AS A
TIME CONSUMING PROCESS IS A
FACULTY EVALUATION AND SERVICE
ON SHARED GOVERNANCE COMMITTEES.
THAT KEEP THE DEPARTMENTS AND
THE COLLEGE IS RUNNING.
FOR LEASE THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS
THE COLLEGES HAVE BEEN
CONFRONTED WITH.
THE NEW INITIATIVES.
IN A MID COURSE CORRECTIONS OF
ONGOING.
INITIATIVES ALWAYS TAUGHT DOWN.
MOST EMANATE FROM THE STATE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL WHO
ACTUALLY GATES THOSE REFORM AND
AGENDAS.
MOSTLY THEY'RE GRANT FROM THE
GATES LUMINA KEY GOAL JAMES
IRVINE COLLEGE FUTURES AND
WILLIAM AND FLORA HEWLETT
FOUNDATION.
ALL ARE LAUNCHED FROM THE TOP
RANKS
WITH MINIMAL INPUT FROM FACULTY
PROFESSIONS
HAVING PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE IN
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE.
MOST OF THESE AGENDAS ARE ONE
SIZE FITS ALL THEY FOCUS ON
INSTRUCTIONAL METHODOLOGY IN
OUTCOMES MEASUREMENT.
TYPICALLY THE PLANS ARE STEEPED
IN JARGON FROM SCHOOLS OF
EDUCATION.
CONCEPT THEY IGNORE THE SUBJECT
MATTER OF ACADEMIC DISCIPLINES
WHILE BEING ORIENTED TOWARDS
CAREER TECHNICAL TRAINING
PROGRAMS BUT ALL PROGRAMS. ALIKE
OUR TASK TO GET ON BOARD WITH
THE LATEST REGIMES. WHETHER
THESE MEASUREMENTS WHAT WHETHER
ALL THESE MEASURE STUDENT
LEARNING OUTCOMES OR DEVELOPING
GUIDED PATHWAYS.
SOME OF THESE INITIATIVES ARE
EVEN INHERENTLY CONTRADICTORY.
THAT'S FACULTY APPLAUDED
TRANSFORM CLASSES AND ONLINE
FORMAT SO THE COLLEGES WILL
PARTICIPATE NEW ONLINE
EDUCATIONAL INITIATIVE. OR EVEN
GOVERNOR BROWN'S.
OPPOSE A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE A FULLY
ONLINE INSTITUTION.
THE SAME TIME THOMAS BAILEY WHO
IS ONE OF THE INSPIRATIONS FOR
GUIDED PATHWAYS.
THOMAS BAILEY AS ASSOCIATES.
.
HAVE ARGUED.
DEFINITIVELY
THAT ONLINE COURSES ARE COUNTER
PRODUCTIVE IN IMPROVING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LATINOS AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR.
AND THAT'S BACKED UP BY THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE REPORT
OF CALIFORNIA TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN ON THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTE REPORT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTY.
AND THOSE ARE NATIONAL.
STE STUDIES INVOLVING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS.
SO WHAT AM I ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE.
ON THE MASTER PLAN.
WELL TO REPORT FIRST OFF TO
REPLACE THE INEFFICIENT
ENROLLMENT BASE FUNDING MODEL
WITH A SIMPLE FORMULA ALLOCATING
A PROPORTION OF THE ANNUAL
BUDGET RESOURCES TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TO MEET THE DYNAMIC ENVIRONMENT.
THIS WOULD PARALLEL THE
BUDGETING PROCESS FOR BASIC A
DISTRICTS.
TOOK.
FUN THE TRANSFORMATION OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
INVEST IN THE HIRING OF TENURE
LINE FACULTY TO MEET THAT
SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE RATIO.
THAT WAS FIRST PUT FORWARD IN AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE DATING
BACK TO NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FOR GOD SAKES IS LONG OVERDUE.
NUMBER THREE IN THE SHORT RUN.
BOOSTS FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO
ENHANCE ADJUNCT FACULTY SALARY
SCHEDULES
AND TO RAISE THE LEVEL OF
COMPENSATION FOR ADJUNCT FACULTY
HOLDING EVEN LIMITED OFFICE
HOURS.
FOR BILL ONE RECENT PROGRESS TO
IMPROVE THE COUNSELOR TO STUDENT
RATIO.
FIVE.
ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR STUDENT
SERVICES TO ADDRESS FOOD
INSECURITY IN THE STUDENT
POPULATION NOT JUST PATCHWORK
BUT SOMETHING MORE SUBSTANTIAL.
SIX PROVIDE INCENTIVES WERE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT TO
PARTNER WITH PUBLIC AGENCIES
IN IDENTIFYING PRACTICAL
SOLUTIONS FOR STUDENTS HOUSING
INSECURITY.
SEVEN AND FINALLY STOP THE
PRIVATIZATION OF THE PUBLIC
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE IMPACT OF
GRANT FUNDING IT'S UNDERMINING
SHARED GOVERNANCE AND
REDIRECTING THIS TECHNICIAN THE
COLLEGES WITH LITTLE SUBSTANTIVE
AND I EMPHASIZE SUBSTANTIVE.
IMPORT FROM ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
FACULTY CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONAL
STAFF AND STUDENTS IN YES EVEN
HONEST ADMINISTRATORS. IF I CAN
SPEAK OFF THE RECORD.
ARE REFORM INITIATIVE WHERE.
WE WANT TO GET AWAY FROM THE
DISRUPTIVE BUSINESS MODEL IN
GROUP GET BACK TO OUR CORE
MISSION.
CLOSING I THINK THE COMMITTEE
FOR HEARING MY TESTIMONY IN
CONSIDERING MY RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE U. DOUG MACLEOD.
DOCTOR LEE'S.
I'M SHARON A LEASE ASSOCIATE
VICE PRESIDENT SOUTH COUNSEL FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
THIS THE FAA REPRESENTS MORE
THAN TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
TENURE LINE PROFESSORS LECTURERS
LIBRARIANS COUNSELORS AND
COACHES ON THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
ALSO KNOWN AS THE PEOPLE'S
UNIVERSITY.
I AM ALSO PROFESSOR AND CHAIR OF
THE SOCIOLOGY DEPARTMENT.
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME.
YOU ASKED US OF A CERTAIN A SET
OF QUESTIONS AND I WANT TO
RESPOND IN THAT WAY SO FIRST AS
WE CONSIDER WHAT FACULTY NEED TO
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE ACCESS AND EQUITY.
IN THE CFA WE LIKE TO SAY THAT
FACULTY TEACHING CONDITIONS ARE
STUDENT LEARNING CONDITIONS THIS
IS WHY WE FOCUS ON WHAT IS
AVAILABLE TO THE STUDENTS.
IN TERMS OF ACCESS WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
HAVE ARISEN TO MEET CSU
QUALIFICATIONS
SO THEY DESERVE ACCESS.
AND YET AT THE END OF
SCHWARZENEGGER'S GOVERNORSHIP
AND THROUGHOUT GOVERNOR BROWN'S
RECENT TENURE BOTH THE CSU IN
THE UC TURNED AWAY TENS OF
THOUSANDS WHO WERE QUALIFIED.
EVERY YEAR.
THIS IS A CRISIS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S A LONG TERM
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL WELL BEING
THESE PROTECTIVE STUDENTS WILL
EITHER GO TO OTHER INSTITUTIONS
OR THEY WON'T GO.
THE STATE'S PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING
AMOUNTS TO AN UNDER FUNDING WITH
AN ALLOCATION OF JUST NINETY TWO
MILLION.
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
THIS YEAR'S YOU ADMINISTRATION
COUNTERS WITH THE REQUEST OF TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
STILL NOT ENOUGH.
CFA RECOMMENDS FUNDING THE CSU
AT FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION. ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
ONLY THIS FUNDING LEVEL WOULD
HELP TO INCREASE STUDENT
ADMISSIONS UP TO A POINT OF AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FTE
STUDENTS STILL NOT THE NUMBER.
THAT IS BEING TURNED AWAY ONLY
HALF.
ARE RECENT REPORT AVAILABLE ON
OUR WEBSITE CAL FACT DOT ORG
EQUITY INTERRUPTED SHOWED THAT
THE CSU SYSTEM EDUCATES MORE
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY TODAY THAN
IT DID THIRTY YEARS AGO.
BUT ASTHMA NUMBER OF STUDENTS OF
COLOR INCREASED THE FUNDING WENT
DOWN AS WE SEE IT WHEN THE
STUDENT BODY GOT DARKER THE
FUNDING GOT LIGHTER.
ONLY IT'S NOT FUNNY.
NINETY FOUR PERCENT OF THE
STUDENT BODY IN THE CSU IS FROM
CALIFORNIA THREE QUARTERS OF
THEM IDENTIFY AS STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
WE KNOW HIGHER EDUCATION IS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
STRUCTURE AND THAT IT'S HELPFUL
FOR THE ECONOMY AS WELL SO WE
URGE THAT THE CSU BE FUNDED AT A
LEVEL THAT INSURERS. ALL
QUALIFIED CSU GRADUATES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFERS ARE
ADMITTED TO A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY.
OUR REQUEST FOR THAT FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILLION WOULD
ONLY RETURN US TO HALF THE LEVEL
OF SUPPORT ENJOYED BY STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA OF THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES WHEN THE AVERAGE
STUDENT WAS A WHITE MALE.
IN TERMS OF EQUITY A RELATED
ASPECT IS THE STUDENTS NEED
FACULTY WHO CAN PROVIDE THEM
WITH EQUITY IN EDUCATION WHICH
IS NOT POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF
PROBLEMS OF IMPLICIT BIAS IN
FACULTY HIRING AND EVALUATION.
THAT OBSTRUCT THE
DIVERSIFICATION OF THE FACULTY.
A SHORT HURT TERM I'M FOR THAT
WOULD BE RACISM
RACISM IS A PROBLEM HAVEN'T
HEARD THAT WORD TODAY SO I FEEL
LIKE PUTTING THAT OUT ON THE
TABLE.
STUDENTS NEED AND DESERVE A
FACULTY THAT MIRRORS THE
COMPOSITION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE OVERALL CSU STUDENT
POPULATION WE KNOW FROM DECADES
OF RESEARCH THAT
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR. ALSO NEED A
CULTURALLY RELEVANT CURRICULA
AND PEDAGOGY TO THRIVE SO WE
MUST TRANSFORM TRADITIONAL
NOTIONS OF THE CORNERSTONES OF
HIGHER EDUCATION TO NOT JUST
INCLUDE BUT EVEN CENTER COURSES
IN ETHNIC STUDIES. AND WOMEN'S
STUDIES ALONG WITH PEDAGOGIES
BASED IN COLLABORATIVE LEARNING
SERVICE LEARNING AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT THAT ARTICULATE WHAT
THE COMMUNITY ETHOS FROM WHICH
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS DRAW THEIR
STRENGTH.
THE SECOND QUESTION YOU ASKED US
TO ADDRESS OUR THE CHALLENGES
AND BARRIERS FACULTY FACING
MEETING STUDENT NEEDS.
WE FILL CENTRAL TO THIS QUESTION
IS DEALING WITH THE QUESTION OF
TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
THAT QUALITY HIGHER EDUCATION
CAN ONLY BE ASSURED BY ENDING
THE RECENT TRENDS TOWARD
RELIANCE ON QUOTE UNQUOTE
TEMPORARY FACULTY AND THEY SAY
THAN QUOTES RECENTLY OF FACULTY
IN MY DEPARTMENT RETIRED. FROM
HER TEMPORARY JOB AFTER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS.
WE BELIEVE THAT.
LECTURER FACULTY POSITIONS.
A NEED TO BE UNDERSTOOD AS
SIMPLY POSITION SPACE AND
INSTRUCTION WHEREAS TENURE TRACK
FACULTY POSITIONS INCLUDE
SCHOLARLY AND CREATIVE ACTIVITY
AND SERVICE AS OTHER COLLEAGUES
HAVE MENTIONED HERE. ADVISING
MENTORING COLLABORATIVE WORK
WITH STUDENTS COMMITTEE SERVICE
ACADEMIC PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT AND
REVIEW FACULTY PEER EVALUATION
AND SO FORTH.
FIFTY YEARS OF RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT STUDENT AT VANCE MEN IN AND
BEYOND COLLEGE DEPENDS ON
RELATIONSHIPS THEY BUILD WITH
FACULTY THROUGH THE KINDS OF
SERVICE THAT TENURE TRACK
FACULTY PROVIDE.
FOR GROWING NUMBERS OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE OF COLOR WHO ARE
IMMIGRANT WHO ARE FIRST
GENERATION WHO ARE VETERAN THESE
MENTORING RELATIONSHIPS ARE
CRITICAL TO THEIR SUCCESS.
EXAMPLE I HAD A STUDENT WHO
WISHES WALK INTO THE CAFETERIA
WHEN I SAW HER SHE WAS ON THE
VERGE OF DROPPING OUT I HAD NO
IDEA. BUT WHEN WE SPOKE SHE
STAYED IN SCHOOL SHE GOT
STRATEGIES TO STAY AND SHE IS A
NATIVE WOMAN AN INDIGENOUS WOMAN
WHO IS NOW A FULL PROFESSOR. AT
A COLLEGE.
WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
SO THROUGH TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
WE CAN PROVIDE THESE KINDS OF
SERVICES IMPORTANT TO OUR
STUDENTS BUT THE GROWING
RELIANCE ON THE CONTINGENT
FACULTY WORKFORCE MEANS THAT WE
ARE UNDER SERVING THOSE STUDENTS.
AND IT ALSO MEANS A GREATER
BURDEN ON THOSE WHO OUR FACULTY
OF COLOR IN THE CFA WE CALL THIS
CULTURAL TAXATION THAT FACULTY
OF COLOR HAVE TO PAY AS THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO KNOW WHAT THEIR
STUDENTS NEED.
AND I SEE THIS THROUGH EFFORTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES SO FOR EXAMPLE
STUDENTS WILL SAY PROFESSOR X.
KEPT ME IN SCHOOL OR I DIDN'T
FEEL I BELONGED HERE BUT
PROFESSOR X. TOLD ME ABOUT HER
JOURNEY TO THE PHD. AND SHE HAD
THE SAME STRUGGLES IT GAVE ME
CONFIDENCE
SO PROFESSOR ACCESS CULTURALLY
TAX BUT SHE WILL PAY THAT TAX TO
HELP THOSE STUDENTS STAY IN
SCHOOL.
CFA THEREFORE PROPOSES A BUDGET
THAT SETS ASIDE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF EXISTING ONGOING
FUNDS JUST TO TARGET THE HIRING
OF TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
THE THIRD FRAMING QUESTION WAS
HOW THE MASTER PLAN OF MET THE
NEEDS OF FACULTY AND WHAT IS AN
ACTION THE STATE COULD TAKE THAT
WOULD REQUIRE FUNDING WHAT IS
ONE THAT WOULD.
SHARED GOVERNANCE COST NOTHING
TO THE CSU IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE CSU TO RESPECT THE WAYS THAT
FACULTY CONSULTATION CAN INFORM
THE DIRECTION AND SHAPE OF
EDUCATION IN OUR STATE. YET IN
RECENT DECADES AND PARTICULARLY
ALL THROUGH THIS YEAR WE SAW
CASE AFTER CASE OF POLICIES THAT
OUT WITHOUT CONSULTATION WITH
FACULTY.
THIS EXPERIENCE WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE FIATS FOR EXAMPLE
WITH CHANGES IN GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS IS A CASE IN POINT.
IN TERMS OF ONE THING THE
LEGISLATION COULD DO TO SUPPORT
NEEDS A FACULTY THAT DOES HAVE A
COST WE NEED A LONG TERM FUNDING
SOURCE TO SUPPORT. FREE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SUCH AS THE
LEGISLATION RECENTLY INTRODUCED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
MY FATHER'S PEOPLE ARE
IMMIGRANTS FROM THE CARIBBEAN
WHO ENJOYED FREE EDUCATION IN
THE UC SYSTEM. MY MOTHER WHO IS
HERE WITH ME AND HER FAMILY
ENJOYED FREE EDUCATION IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IN LA.
MY HUSBAND AND ONE OF MY
CHILDREN ARE CSU GRADUATES WHO
LIKE ME AND MANY OF THE PEOPLE
IN MY GENERATION INCLUDING MANY
OF OUR LEGISLATURES.
LATERS BENEFITED FROM AN ALMOST
FREE HIGHER EDUCATION SO WHY
AREN'T STUDENTS GETTING THE SAME
DEAL WE GOT BY THE TIME MY
DAUGHTER GRADUATED FROM THE C.
S. YOU A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
HER TUITION WAS FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT HIGHER THAN HER FATHER
PAID.
THERE IS A STRONG ECONOMIC CASE
FOR FREE PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA ESTIMATES CALIFORNIA
WILL BE OVER ONE MILLION COLLEGE
GRADUATE SHORT. DEBATE THAT MEET
THE DEMANDS OF THE ECONOMY BY
TWENTY THIRTY JUST AROUND THE
CORNER.
THIS TREND WILL WORSEN WITHOUT
ACTION.
EDUCATION IS ARE DRIVING FORCE
FOR OUR ECONOMY. AND IT'S ALSO
SUCH AN IMPORTANT GIFT THAT WE
CAN GIVE OURSELVES AND OUR
CITIZENS
LET'S DO THE RIGHT THING FOR
STUDENTS IN THE PEOPLE'S
UNIVERSITY. ASSURE THEIR ACCESS
TO AN EDUCATION BASED ON EQUITY
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF TENURE
TRACK FACULTY WHO CAN DEVOTE
TIME TO MENTORING THEM IN AN
INSTITUTION THAT THRIVES BECAUSE
IT IS REASONABLY FUNDED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS HONOR.
THANK YOU DOCTOR LEADS AND
DOCUMENT GOT MCIVER.
CHAIR BERMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA DOCTOR WEBER COLLEAGUES
IN THE AUDIENCE AND THOSE
WATCHING ONLINE TODAY THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU.
I RECEIVED MY PHD FROM UC IRVINE
MEANING THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
INVESTED IN ME AS A SCHOLAR AND
A TEACHER.
SO I AM PART OF THE PIPELINE
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TODAY.
IT'S AN HONOR TO REPAY THAT
TRUSTS AND HELP GUIDE
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION FORWARD INTO THE
FUTURE.
I'M CURRENTLY A CONTINGENT
FACULTY MEMBER AT UCLA AND
PRESIDENT OF UNIVERSITY COUNCIL
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
THE LABOR UNION REPRESENTING YOU
SEE LECTURES AND LIBRARIANS.
I SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF NON
TENURE TRACK FACULTY WHO ARE
INTEGRAL TO THE UC'S TRIPARTITE
MISSION. OF RESEARCH EDUCATION
AND SERVICE.
THE NINETEEN SIXTY MASTER PLAN
NEVER ENVISIONED THE WIDESPREAD
EXPLOITATION OF UNDERPAID
UNDEREMPLOYED FACULTY.
YET THAT IS THE SITUATION AT THE
UC TODAY AND AS WE'VE BEEN
HEARING AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE CS USE.
UC'S UP FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED
LECTURERS TEACH ONE THIRD OF
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT CREDIT
HOURS.
ALL OF THOSE ARE OFTEN GATE
CLASS THAT OFF ENTRY INTO THE.
I'M FOR ME WHEN MY TEACHER OF
FIRST YEAR STUDENTS.
I LOOK FORWARD EVERY FALL TO
THE FIRST DAY OF CLASS TO BEING
IN THE CLASSROOM WITH MY
STUDENTS AND SAYING TO THEM MANY
OF THEM FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS. WELCOME TO COLLEGE
THAT IS A MAGIC MOMENT.
ALTOGETHER PRECARIOUS
INSTRUCTORS INCLUDING ADJUNCTS
VISITING ASSISTANT PROFESSORS
ACADEMIC STUDENT EMPLOYEES AND
OTHERS TEACH NEARLY ONE HALF OF
UNDERGRADUATE CREDIT HOURS.
FACULTY GROWTH IS OCCURRING
MAINLY CONTINGENT TITLES.
THE UC USES TEMPORARY FACULTY TO
DO PERMANENT WORK A SHORT
SIGHTED POLICY SHORT INJURED
POWERFUL ASTUTE.
I MIGHT BOTH CAN WORK AS A BRIEF
I TO YOU UBER FOR EIGHT YEARS
NOW.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE FIFTY FOUR
PERCENT MORE STUDENTS AT THE UC
TODAY THAN IN TWO THOUSAND
CLEARLY INDICATING A LONG TERM
NEED FOR HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION.
EXCELLENT LECTURERS ARE TREATED
AS DISPOSABLE AND SUBJECT TO
FORCED TO TURN OVER. OFTEN
PREVENTED FROM TEACHING LONGER
THAN A YEAR OR TWO.
LIKE MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES I
WORK MULTIPLE JOBS AGAINST ME
AND STRUGGLE TO REMAIN IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
ARE. DOT. PERCENTAGES
NECESSARILY A LOOP SURE.
FROM BASIC HELP RETIRED BENEFIT.
AND WE PERFORMED COUNTLESS HOURS
OF UNCOMPENSATED RESEARCH AND
SERVICE NOT TO MENTION THE
EMOTIONAL SERVICE AND LABOR I
THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALSO
DESCRIBED.
OUR WORKING CONDITIONS IN HER
PROFOUND FEELINGS OF ISOLATION
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION.
BY NEGLECTING A CORE OF
INCREDIBLY QUALIFIED TALENTED
EXPERIENCED AND ACCOMPLISH
FACULTY THE UC DIMINISHES THE
SEDIKIT A PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO
ARE SO WELL PREPARED TO MENTOR
STUDENTS.
AND THIS IS WHAT REALLY KILLS ME
IT IS SUCH A WASTE.
YOU SEE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLICLY
DESCRIBED CONTINUED FACULTY AS
SUBSIDIZING TENURE TRACK FACULTY
BY TEACHING THEIR CLASSES FOR
THEM.
THIS TWO TIER MODEL IN WHICH
TEACHING IS EFFECTIVELY
OUTSOURCED
DRIVES A WEDGE BETWEEN FACULTY
AND CREATES CLEAR CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST WHERE WE SHOULD BE
UNITED.
THIS IS NOT ONLY A MATTER OF
EQUITY WITHIN A FACULTY
HIERARCHY BUT ALSO OF RACIAL AND
GENDER EQUITY. LECTURER MORE
LIKELY THAN TRACK PUTTING THE
WOMEN AND OF COLOR.
YOU SEE CAMPUSES INTENSIFY THE
STRATIFICATION. BY SEPARATING
RESEARCH AND TEACHING INTO
DISTINCT.
WHEREAS THE MASTER PLAN OF
ORIGINALLY EMPHASIZED THE
IMPORTANCE
CALLER TEACHER.
I SEE ADMINISTRATORS ARE
INCREASINGLY SAID TARGET
PENTAGON FROM.
A CLEAR DISSERVICE TO BOTH THE
STUDENTS
BENEFIT
STARTING WITH EXPERTS IN THEIR
CHOSEN FIELDS.
AND A FACULTY
HIS RESEARCH BENEFITS FROM
ENGAGING STUDENT PRESS.
AND CONSIDERING THE FUTURE OF
THE MASTER PLAN THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD.
STORE STATE FUNDING HISTORICALLY
HIGH LOW AND DEDICATE A STABLE
FUND SOURCE TO ALL THREE
SEGMENTS OF. HIGHER EDUCATION.
THREE HELLO WE HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION HAS PERHAPS ONE SUCH
PILE.
THE SIXTY SIX DOLLAR FIX.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS DESERVED TO
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE DEBT FREE.
STABLE AND DEDICATED FUNDING
WILL ALSO RELIEVE THE YOU SEE
FROM THE BUDGETARY UNCERTAINTY
THAT DRIVES FACULTY PER CHARITES
AND UNDERMINE STUDENT SUCCESS.
REFORM THE BOARD OF REGENTS TO
ENSURE ITS MEMBERS BETTER
REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS
AND YOU SEE STAKEHOLDERS.
PROMOTE EDUCATIONAL INSTEAD OF
CORPORATE GOVERNANCE
INCLUDE A SEAT FOR CONTINGENT
FACULTY MEMBER.
INCLUDE MEASURES OF CONTENTION
FACULTY WELFARE IN
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS FOR THE
UC AND SET AMBITIOUS TARGETS FOR
THE UC TO MEET.
THE MOST REVEALING STATISTICS TO
ANALYZE WOULD BE LECTURER
TURNOVER RATE AN AVERAGE
APPOINTMENT PERCENTAGE
AND I HAVE SOME OF THOSE NUMBERS
WITH ME TODAY IN CASE PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED DURING THE CUBAN.
AND FINALLY ADVOCATE FOR
CONTINGENT FACULTY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND INCLUSION IN
ACADEMIC INITIATIVES.
WELL TAKING CARE NOT TO INFRINGE
ON. THE FAMOUS ECONOMY THE USE
DE. THROUGHOUT THE CHURCH
THERE'S THE SENSE TO.
STOP TURNOVER BY INSTITUTING
READ BRING RIGHTS FOR EARLY
CAREER CONTINGENT FACULTY.
I PICKING ONE OF MY CLASSES MY
STUDENTS OFTEN ASK WHETHER THEY
CAN TAKE ANOTHER WITH ME.
I HAVE TO RESPOND I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER I'LL BE TEACHING NEXT
YEAR.
WE CAN ONLY INVEST IN OUR
STUDENTS TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
UNIVERSITY INVESTS IN OFFICE.
IMPROVE QUALITY OF INSTRUCTION
BY REPLACING STUDENT EVALUATIONS
OF TEACHING WITH A VOICE IN THEIR OWN EDUCATE.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
BUT RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
USING STUDENT EVALUATIONS AND
PERSONNEL DECISIONS PERPETUATES
RACISM AND SEXISM COMPROMISES
ACADEMIC FREEDOM AND GENERATES A
CUSTOMER SERVICE DYNAMIC THAT
UNDERMINE SOUND PEDAGOGY.
ESTABLISH PAY PARITY AMONG
TENURE TRACK AND NON TENURE
TRACK FACULTY.
ENOUGH SAID.
IN FRANCHISE LECTURES AN ADJUNCT
THROUGH MEMBERSHIP IN THE UC
ACADEMIC SENATE. WE TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR EDUCATING
STUDENTS BUT LITTLE TOO NO VOICE
IN DECISION MAKING ABOUT
CURRICULA AND OTHER MATTERS.
THERE'S NO JUSTIFIABLE REASON TO
EXCLUDE SUCH AN ENORMOUS NUMBER
OF FACULTY FROM SHARED
GOVERNANCE.
MY STUDENTS MAKE ME FIERCELY
PROUD WHEN THEY GRADUATE WITH
THE ABILITY TO INQUIRE TO
CHALLENGE AND TO CREATE.
THE YOU SEE MAKES ME FIERCELY
PROUD WHEN IT EMPOWERS MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY WITHIN AND
BEYOND THE UNIVERSITY.
BY INVITING CONTENDER FACULTY TO
THIS HEARING YOU'VE ALREADY
SIGNAL THAT YOU SHARE THIS PRIDE.
AS WELL AS A HOLISTIC VISION FOR
RESEARCH TEACHING AND SERVICE AT
THE UC.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SPEAK TODAY FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND REFRAMING THE
MASTER PLAN FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
YOU'RE MUCH LIKE MCIVER.
THAT ALTMAN.
CALLING THREE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT MIGHT HAVE.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AYE I AM.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT.
.
CLEARLY GET TO THE HEART I THINK
OF OF FACULTY AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF FACULTY IN ITS RELATIONSHIP
TO. ACCOMPLISHING THE GOALS OF
WE WANT.
YEAH I'M SURE YOU PROBABLY
FOLLOW THE.
SOME KIND OF THE OF THE NUMBER
OF BILLS THAT WE PUT FORWARD TO
TRY TO ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS
AND AND.
.
YOU KNOW BEING THE BILL THE ONE
MEMBER I THINK IN THE HOUSE OF
THE ONE OF TWO THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY SERVED IN.
AS A TENURED FACULTY ON ONE OF
THESE CAMPUSES AND CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND. ALSO KINDA KNOW
THE DRAMA AND THE TRAUMA
INVOLVED IN PART TIME HIRING AND
THE RATIO. THAT EXISTS BETWEEN
FACULTY FULL TIME TENURE TRACK
FACULTY AND A PART TIME FACULTY.
IT IS CRITICAL FOR AN
INSTITUTION TO HAVE A LOT OF
TENURED FACULTY.
BECAUSE THAT REALLY GETS TO US
OF THE MISSION WE WANT WHICH IS.
THAT ONLY GIVING STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE. A MENTOR
AND A SUPPORTER. BUT DODD TO
STABILIZE THE INSTITUTION AND
OFFERINGS OF THE YEAR AND TO
ACTUALLY RUN THE INSTITUTIONS
YOU KNOW IF FACULTY ARE SUPPOSED
TO RUN THE UNIVERSITIES WHICH
THEY TELL US. WHEN YOU HAVE TO
HAVE ENOUGH OF US.
AS IT ALSO STILL HAVE THIS BAND
A DIVINITY BUT ANYWAY WE NEED TO
HAVE ENOUGH OF THEM I PUT TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE ON ALL THESE
COMMITTEES OTHERWISE YOU BURN
OUT.
AND.
AND SO YOU DON'T GET THE
QUALITY THAT YOU WANT THAT'S THE
AS WELL AS FACULTY. A PART TIME
FACULTY THAT RUNS AROUND I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
ALSO LOOK AT IS THAT I FOUND
DISTURBING. I WHEN I WAS IN AND
MOST IF IT'S STILL THERE I'M
SURE HE IS AYE MANOMETER LONG.
IS THAT WHEN WE GET READY TO
HIRE PERMIT FACULTY WE GENTLY
DON'T LOOK TO OUR PART TIMES TO
HIRE.
AT THE C. ISSUE. OF THAT AND AND
AND IT'S IT WAS ALWAYS ALARMING
TO ME THAT.
I'D HAVE I'D MEET INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN AT THE UNIVERSITY
FOR TEN TWENTY YEARS WORKING AND
SOMETIMES TEACHING FIVE AND SIX
CLASSES WITH THE AVERAGE FACULTY
TEACHES ABOUT TWO TO THREE.
AND WHAT IT CAME DOWN TO HIRE A
PERMANENT PERSON PERMIT FACULTY
THEY DID NOT CONSIDER. THIS PART
TIME WHO HAD A STRONG RECORD OF
TEACHING. WHO MAY NOT HAVE A
STRONG RECORD OF A PUBLICATIONS
BECAUSE THEY WERE TEACHING SO
MANY CLASSES RUNNING ALL OF THE
WORLD? IT WAS RARE I MEAN
ABSOLUTELY IT'S RARE WHEN A PART
TIME FACULTY GOT A FULL TIME
POSITION AT THE UNIVERSITY
AFTER TEACHING FOR FIVE TEN
FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND I FOUND THAT TO BE ALARMING
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S CHANGED ANY.
BUT.
YOU KNOW HERE'S SOMETHING
THAT'S TRIED AND TRUE THAT YOU
KNOW CAN DO THE JOB AND YET THEY
DON'T GET DOING DON'T GET THE
NOT THEY DON'T GET THE. PERMIT
FACULTY POSITION
SO BEING IDENTIFIED AS AN
ADJUNCT WITHOUT FACULTY IS
REALLY A LIFE SENTENCE.
YOU WANT TO BE THAT ADJUNCT
FACULTY IF YOU IF YOU REMAIN IN
THE SYSTEM. WHATEVER.
AND I'VE SEEN I HAVE FRIENDS
WHO'VE BEEN ADJUNCTS FOR.
A YEARS I'VE ONLY HAD ONE WHO
ACTUALLY BECAME AND MESA OF OF
LOSE CHAIR OF A BLACK STUDIES
NOW OF WHO'S A FORMER STUDENT MY.
MOVE ACTION BECAME A PERMANENT
FACULTY.
EVERYBODY ELSE ESTADO. NOT
STARLETS THE CHEMO MY JASA.
Ó WHO STARTED CAME IN I THINK
IT'S A FULL TIME FACULTY I
BELIEVE YEAH BUT WITH. THE CHEMO
CAME IN AS A PART TIME FACULTY
AND SHE'S THE ONLY ONE I'VE
KNOWN TO ACTUALLY BE HIRED AS A
FULL TIME PERSON UP FACULTY
AFTERWARD. ISN'T THAT THAT'S
GOOD TO KNOW WHAT I NOT SEE IS
YOU. THAT IS RARE I DON'T KNOW
OF ANY IT SEE ISSUE MAYBE ONE.
THAT ACTUALLY AFTER MY FORTY
YEARS WHO ACTUALLY GOT A FULL
TIME POSITION AND HAVE BEEN A
PART HAD BEEN A AN ADJUNCT
FACULTY MEMBER.
AND A AND THAT WAS ALWAYS
ALARMING TO ME BECAUSE WHEN WE
OPEN THE POOL WE WOULD NEVER
THEY'VE IF THEY APPLIED THERE
WOULD NEVER CONSIDER. THERE WILL
ALWAYS THE NEW LISTS
FLAVOR THAT SEEM MORE EXCITING
YOU KNOW THAT WAS THERE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AS WE TRIED
AND. COULD BILLS FOR I HAVE THE
TO GET TO THE SEVENTY FIVE
INCLUDES THE SEVENTY FIVE IN
SOME ANOTHER. IT'S HARD TO GET
OUR MINISTRY DOES.
AT THE END WHO IS IN CHARGE OF
ALL THE SYSTEMS TO BELIEVE THAT
THAT THAT'S IT HAPPENED BECAUSE
THEY WANT. HOLD THE FLEXIBILITY
TO. DO OTHER THINGS WITH THE
RESOURCES AND OF SORTS IT BUT IT
IS SOMETHING I THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO CONTINUE
THE CHAMPION.
IT MAY BE SOMETHING YOU SHOULD
BRING UP WITH THE NEW FOLKS
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR.
BECAUSE BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT PIECE
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I.
AS DOCTOR WEBER BRINGS UP THE
FACT OF THE OF BRINGING IT UP
WITH THE NEW PERSON RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR. THURSDAY EDITORIAL IN
TODAY'S SACRAMENTO BEE.
THAT SAYS JUST THAT ARE THAT THE
NEXT GOVERNOR SHOULD BE SOMEONE
WHO FULLY FUNDS.
HIGHER EDUCATION THAT FULLY
FUNDS I USUALLY.
AND CSU.
I SHARED THE ARTICLE OF THIS
MORNING I SHARED THAT EDITORIAL
THIS MORNING ON MY FACEBOOK PAGE
AND I ASK THE QUESTION. WHY
SHOULD WE WAIT ANOTHER YEAR?
AND I SAY THAT IN ALL
SERIOUSNESS.
I SAY THAT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS.
WEEKLY SHOULD NOT HAPPEN.
ANOTHER YEAR.
YOU NO EVERYONE ON THIS PANEL.
HERE SO FAR AND I THINK WE'LL
CONTINUE TO HEAR THE SAME THING
I WRITE IN MY NOTES.
.
THE IMPORTANCE OF FUNDING.
I I DON'T THINK THE STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA CAN WAIT ANOTHER YEAR
AND WE'RE HEARING THAT.
I THINK VERY DRAMATICALLY A
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS STUDENTS
CAN'T WAIT ANOTHER YEAR SO.
.
YOU NO LET'S NOT LET'S NOT WAIT
ANOTHER YEAR WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT THIS YEAR WE
NEED TO DO IT THIS YEAR.
ONLINE I COLLEGE.
WELL HOPEFULLY IS NOT GONNA GO
IN THERE.
.
YEAH I ALSO SERVED I ALSO SERVE
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. AND.
YESTERDAY I MET WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY A IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S A MUCH
BY EN.
AMONG THE BUDGET COMMITTEE ON
THE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
ONLINE AND I AND I WILL MAKE AND
THAT'S ANOTHER POINT THAT I
HEARD.
FROM PROFESSOR MCCLOUD THAT
THERE HASN'T BEEN CONSULTATION
THERE HASN'T BEEN CONSULTATION.
EVEN.
EVEN WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S WE
HEARD.
FROM BUT CHANCE THROUGH UP
CAMINO.
COLLEGE THAT IT WOULD BE THE
WORST WELL THAT THAT WAS IN
FUNDING AND IN REFERENCE TO THE
FUNDING.
REFORM AND BASS YEAH WELCOME
YEAH BOTH PROPOSALS I DON'T
THINK THERE'S BEEN CONSULTATION
OF WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S. I
DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN
OBVIOUSLY CONSULTATION WITH A
WITH THE FACULTY.
SO I I I I MIGHT AGREE THAT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE
BETTER SPENT.
A IF IF WE WENT TO OF FULLY
FUNDING.
CHANGING THE RATIO I WAS A PART
TIME.
INSTRUCTOR.
YEAH RCC AND.
COLLEGE OF THE DESERT AND
VALLEY COLLEGE AND I KNOW
PERSONALLY AND SO THEREFORE I'M
HAPPY TO TO PUT THE BILL'S
FORWARD WITH DUH.
WITH THE DOCTOR WEBER YOU KNOW
TO GIVE OFFICE HOURS TO MAKE
SURE THAT SENIORITY HIRING THAT
SENIORITY IS USE. AND HIRING A
PART TIME FACULTY.
RIGHT NOW MY.
STAFF PERSON LEFT TO GO TO RCC
TO TALK WITH PART TIME FACULTY
THAT'S WHERE SHE LEFT.
IT'S WHERE SHE IS RIGHT NOW.
.
WE WOULD NOT HAVE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IF IT WERE NOT
FOR PART TIME FACULTY.
AND AND AT THE SAME TIME FOR ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT REASONS YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T FEEL.
LIKE FACULTY.
THEY DON'T HAVE OFFICE HOURS
THEY MAY NOT HAVE HEALTH
BENEFITS.
THEY CAN'T SERVE ON COMMITTEES.
EVEN THINGS LIKE NOT BEING
INCLUDED IN GRADUATION EXERCISES.
AND.
SO IF WE ARE.
NEED TO DO MORE AND WE ARE
HEARING THE NEEDS FOR DOING MORE.
THERE'S LOTS.
A LOTS OF STUFF HERE AND AND I
WILL ALSO POINT OUT THAT WE ARE
HEARING SOME THINGS HERE THAT WE
DON'T HEAR IN SACRAMENTO.
AND THAT IS THAT THEIR FOR THE
IMPORTANCE OF BEING HERE UP ON
THE GROUND. ON CAMPUS HEARING
FROM YOU DIRECT.
AGREED EL I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE PANELISTS FOR ALL YOUR
SUGGESTIONS MANY OF WHICH THIS
IS THEY MORE FUNDING WHICH WHICH
I THINK WERE ALL LINED ON THE
NEED FOR SOME OF WHICH I DON'T.
WHICH IS ALSO VERY HELPFUL.
TO TO HAVE.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
SOME THEM ALL DO JUST QUICKLY
ALIGN MY THOUGHTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS.
AND WANT TO THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH FOR FOR PARTICIPATING TODAY
WE PLEASE.
GO ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
AND.
OUR NEXT PANEL IS GOING TO BE
OF THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
SERVICES STAFF.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME DOCTOR CHECK
DOCTOR JAMES TODD VICE PRESIDENT
OF STUDENT SERVICES MODESTO
JUNIOR COLLEGE JUST AND JOSE.
AG WE LARGE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCIAL AID THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE
UNFORTUNATELY DOCTOR BRIDGET
DRISKELL.
FROM CSU DOMINGUEZ HILLS WASN'T
ABLE TO MAKE IT TODAY.
BUT I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE A GREAT
PANEL.
A WITHOUT TO MET ERRED ARCHDUCHY
PANELISTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
YOUR.
GOOD.
OKAY.
OKAY WE'RE GOOD GOOD THAT.
BUT THAT'S.
SO WHEN WE KICK IT OFF.
WITH DOCTOR GOD WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
IF WE GIVE FOLKS IF THEY HAVE
ANY CONVERSATIONS TO MAYBE TAKE
THOSE UP SINGERS THAT WOULD BE
GREAT BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE WITH THE HEARING. THIS
SONG ONLY HALF AN HOUR LATE.
WELL THINK THINK YOU FOR FOR
HAVING ME.
.
I HAVE WONDERFUL DISCUSSION SO
FAR I THINK WHAT'S WHAT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGIES OUR.
COMMITMENT THAT'S BEEN APPEAR ON
EVERY PANEL SO FAR TO EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY ACROSS OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND I THINK YOU
MORE. COMPREHENSIVELY ABOUT
STUDENT SUCCESS.
MY COMMENTS TODAY ARE ALSO.
CUTTING DRIVEN OUT OF THE.
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE LOCALLY
AS ESPECIALLY CHIEF STUDENT
SERVICES OFFICERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIVE SYSTEM.
ON WHAT ARE OUR FRUSTRATIONS
I'M FROM STAFF IN HELPING
STUDENTS SUCCEED. I WOULD THE
HIGHEST IT YOU KNOW WOULD THE
LARGEST.
IN THE WORLD IN TERMS OF A HIGH
AS A AS SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND WE SERVE THE TOP
HUNDRED PERCENT OF PEOPLE IN IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT US JUST EXPRESSED TO
THINK ABOUT THAT MEANS WE ARE
SERVING STUDENTS THAT ARE INSIDE.
KATIE TWELVE SYSTEM THROUGH OUR
CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT.
WE ARE WORKING ON FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AND SYSTEM AFFECTED
INDIVIDUALS WE ARE WORK WITH.
FOLKS THAT ARE HOMELESS THERE
OFTEN.
IN VERY DIRE.
CIRCUMSTANCES IN TERMS OF THEIR
SOCIAL LIFE SO. THE QUESTION
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US IS
HOW DO WE BEST MOVE FROM A
SYSTEM BROADLY BASED ON ACCESS
AND ENROLLMENT. TOWARDS A
SUCCESS DRIVEN MODEL.
AND ONE THAT'S FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING EQUITY.
AND I THINK AS WELL BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE THE SYSTEMS HERE ARE
HOW DO WE HAVE A MORE GLOBAL
INTERSECT MENTAL APPROACH ACROSS
STUDENT SUPPORT SYSTEMS.
BECAUSE IT'S NEEDED IN TERMS OF
BUILDING A MORE STRUCTURED AND
INTENTIONAL PIPELINES FOR
STUDENTS THERE IS FRUSTRATION ON
HOW DO WE MOVE OUR STUDENTS FROM
OUR SYSTEM AS A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. INTO THE
UC'S END TO THE CS USE AND
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF CAPACITY.
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT BUILDING
CAPACITY ON PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
ON LOCAL CAMPUSES NOT NOT JUST
TO KNOW WHY WE NEED TO CHANGE
BUT HOW TO EXTRACT CHANGE AT
SCALE ESPECIALLY IN AREAS OF
INTEGRATED STUDENT SUPPORT SO I
HAVE FOUR MAIN POINTS I'M GOING
TO FOCUS ON TODAY. ON THE FIRST
ONE IS ABOUT OUR OWN
TRANSFORMATIONAL DEMANDS AHEAD
OF US AS THE CALIFORNIA RECALL
SYSTEM. I'M WHICH MEANS THAT WE
NEED INFRASTRUCTURE TOOLS
SUPPORT AND TRAINING FOR
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE.
I'M IN THIS ERA OF GUIDED
PATHWAYS WHICH I THINK IS.
MOVING US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN TERMS OF ALIGNMENT.
AND TRANSFORMATIONAL WORK ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
AS WE RETHINK ABOUT HOW
STUDENTS MOVE THROUGH OUR
COLLEGES THERE'S GREAT NEED FOR
RETRAINING STRUCTURE
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND IN PARTICULAR THE CHALLENGES
INVOLVED RETRAINING AND
RECLASSIFYING MANY CLASSIFY
PROFESSIONALS AND STUDENTS
SUPPORT STAFF IN ORDER TO ALIGN
AND RESTRUCTURING INSTITUTIONS
AND MODELS THAT BEST SUPPORT.
DEGREE AND CERTIFICATE
ATTAINMENT AS WELL AS
TRANSFERRING CAREER AND THREE.
SO WE NEED SYSTEMIC APPROACHES
TO HELPING COLLEGES RETRAIN
STAFF INCLUDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS I'M IN THE
PURSUIT OF STUDENT SUCCESS IN
EQUITY.
RICK SAMPLE.
WERE ALREADY A HISPANIC OR LET
LOT NEXT.
OF A SUPPORTING SYSTEM I'M I'M
ABOUT FORTY PERCENT I THINK IT'S
FORTY TWO PERCENT OF THE
PARTICULAR MOMENT.
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY HAVE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENTS?
TO HELP COLLEGES LEARNED NOT TO
BE HISPANIC EMERALDS.
INSTITUTIONS BUT HAS SPANDEX
SERVING INSTITUTIONS
THAT KIND OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IS REALLY NEEDED
ACROSS OUR STOCK AND STUDENT
SUPPORT.
AND HOW CAN THE BEST RECOGNIZE
UP BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS.
AND AND AND.
MODIFIER PRACTICES IT LOCALLY.
SECOND OF ALL WE NEED STATEWIDE
TECHNOLOGY CREWS INCLUDING CROSS
SYSTEM TECHNOLOGY AND TOOLS ARE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT INTEGRATED
PLANNING. PROGRAM NAVIGATION FOR
STUDENTS DATA SHARING AND
TRACKING.
EXAMPLES CAN INCLUDE ELECTRONIC
CATALOGS THAT INTEGRATE WITH
CURRICULUM DATA DASHBOARDS THAT
CONTRACTS STUDENTS IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PLAN PROGRESS FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES.
REFINE WEBSITES FOR EFFICIENT
EDUCATIONAL PLANNING AND QUIRK
CAREER GOAL SETTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR PRIOR
LEARNING ASSESSMENT.
PROGRAMS FOR ONLINE COUNSELING
AN ACADEMIC ADVISING AND
TECHNOLOGY FOR JUST IN TIME
SUPPORT THAT IS INTEGRATED WITH
INSTRUCTIONAL EFFORTS.
SO LEADING TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHAINS ARE REQUIRE SPECIFIC
SKILLS AND COMMUNICATION IN THE
EFFECTIVE USE OF DATA AND
IMPLEMENTATION BEYOND THE
DISCUSSIONS OF WHY THE FRAMEWORK
MATTERS.
AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THEIR STUDENT
SUPPORT STAFF BROADLY NEED
SHARED MODELS THAT CAN BE
ADAPTED TO THEIR INDIVIDUAL
ATKINS TO TO SINCE.
THE SECOND BROAD POINT I'D LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT HER HAVING CLEAR
STRUCTURAL PATHWAYS FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES AND THE
UNIVERSITY. OF CALIFORNIA WITH
AN EMPHASIS ON BUILDING CAPACITY
FOR LOCAL GUARANTEED ADMISSION
AND A PIPELINE AB DEGREE
ATTAINMENT.
AND THIS IS A FRUSTRATION FOR
MANY OF US WE HAVE.
.
THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVE SEEN THE
DATA FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT MOVE INTO.
THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM MANY OF
OUR GRADUATES ARE DOING MUCH
BETTER THAN THOSE THAT START AT
THE C. S. USE OR THE UC'S ONCE
THEY TRANSFER.
AND SO GIVEN THAT THE LARGE
POPULATION OF THE STUDENTS IN
THE SOCIAL NET THAT WE PROVIDE
HOW CAN WE HAVE MORE CAPACITIES
OF VERY IMPORTANT POINT.
FOR FOR OUR STAFF THAT ARE
TRYING TO NEW STUDENTS THROUGH
AND HAVE REAL FACTS IN THEIR
LIVES.
SO WHILE THE ASSOCIATE DEGREES
FOR TRANSFER OF PROVIDED A
PATHWAY AND GUIDED PATHWAYS IS
REALLY HELPING US IN THIS EFFORT
MANY PROBLEMS REMAIN IN TERM
TERMS OF ALIGNMENT ARTICULATION
AND PROVIDING A TRUE EFFICIENT
PIPELINE. FOR STUDENTS WHO COULD
BENEFIT FROM ATTENDING
COMMUNICORP COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WITH A GUARANTEED AND SRI INTO A
LOCAL CSU OR YOU SEE I WILL SAY
THIS. THAT I HAVE A TWENTY
PERCENTAGE POINT GAP OF MY
INSTANT.
IN TERMS OF.
UNDER REPRESENTED.
STUDENTS THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY NOT BEEN ABLE TO
TRANSFER DUE TO NOT HAVING A
LOCAL GUARANTEE AT THE
INSTITUTION DOWN THE STREET. AND
I WILL SAY THAT IF WE ARE ABLE
TO MARKET TO STUDENTS THAT ARE
INDICATED TWELFTH WHEN WE ARE
DOING OUTREACH AND STUDENT
SERVICES AND SAY YOU HAVE IF YOU
GET THESE DEGREES AT YOUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE YOU ARE
GUARANTEED ENTRY. INTO A CSU OR
YOU SEE THAT IS LOCAL THAT WILL
CHANGE FOR FAMILIES.
IT WILL CHANGE FOR STUDENTS.
ARMED SO INTENSIVE PARAMOUNT'S
OF LABOR PROVIDED BY STUDENTS
SUPPORT STAFF AND COUNSELORS IN
TERMS OF CURRICULUM MAPPING
ACROSS SYSTEMS AND EDUCATIONAL
PLANNING YET MANY STUDENTS STILL
END UP WITH A LESS THAN SEAMLESS
EXPERIENCE. WHEN TRANSFERRING
INSTITUTIONS DUE TO A LACK OF
INTERSECT MENTAL AGREEMENT.
SO RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE
INTENSIVE BRAND IN OF A
STATEWIDE PIPELINE OF SUCCESS
FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO THE
CSU AND YOU SEE. A RE
CONCEPTUALIZATION OF THE
ARTICULATION PRODUCT PROCESS
INCLUDING BROCK INERT BROUGHT
INTERSECT MENTAL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
ENGENDERING OR INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT PROMOTES MORE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LOWER DIVISION IN
ROMANCE AND MORE CAPACITY AND
THE CSU AND UC'S FOR UPPER
DIVISION COURSES.
TECHNOLOGICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
STATEWIDE CROSS SYSTEM AND
EDUCATIONAL PLANNING AND
GUARANTEED ENTRY INTO LOCAL
UNIVERSITIES.
THIRD POINT I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
IS ABOUT REDESIGNING THE SUPPORT
FOR AFFECTED BY SEEN AT SCALE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT STE
INSTITUTIONS I'M A MEDIUM SIZE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE SERVE
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS IN TERMS OF OUR
HEAD COUNT. THERE ARE MANY THAT
ARE MUCH HOW MUCH HIGHER. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF CAPACITY THAT'S
NEEDED IN TERMS OF ADVISING
STUDENTS.
THE GREAT NEED PROVIDE
EFFECTIVELY ADVISING THAT SCALE
CURRENTLY COUNSELORS PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL PLANNING A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COLLEGES INCLUDING ACADEMIC
PERSONAL AND CAREER COUNSELLING.
AND.
NOW COUNSELORS ARE BEING ASKED
TO COMPLETE MORE TRANSFERS IN
CAREER SERVICES ARE GIVEN THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS THAT WE HAVE
FROM OUR OUR CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
WHICH I THINK IS A GREAT
INITIATIVE.
BUT MANY COLLEGES HAVE
COUNSELORS TO STUDENT RATIOS OF
ONE TO OVER A THOUSAND.
AND THE SYSTEM IS NOT CURRENTLY
DESIGNED PERFORMED COUNSELING
SERVICES AT SCALE. FUNDING AND
HIRING COUNSELORS IT'S EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT ON CAMPUSES WITH THE
STRUCTURE OF THE FIFTY PERCENT
LAW.
I'M SO EITHER MORE MORE.
FUNDING FOR CANCERS THIS NEEDED
OR STRUCTURAL CHANGES MAY NEED
TO OCCUR THAT COULD ENABLE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
COLLABORATIVELY WE THINK FORMS
OF ACADEMIC ADVISING. IN ORDER
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL
STUDENTS.
THEIR ACADEMIC ADVISING MODELS I
USED SYSTEMS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA IN STATE SYSTEMS LIKE
YOU SEE OR CS YOU.
ADDITIONALLY STUDENTS CIRQUE
SENATE EDUCATIONAL PLANNING FOR
STUDENTS MOVING THROUGH SYSTEMS
AS WELL AS APPROPRIATE INTER
SEGMENTAL TECHNOLOGY.
MAY WARRANT INVESTIGATION AND
INVESTMENT.
THE LAST POINT IS THIS WE NEED
MORE INCREASED FUNDING THE
HOLISTICALLY MEETS STUDENT NEEDS.
I'M GIVEN THE STUDENTS THAT WE
SERVE ACROSS ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT A MAP OF WHERE THEY ARE
SERVING STUDENTS. YOU CAN TELL
THAT WE HAVE INCREDIBLE
DIVERSITY AND NEED FOR FOR LOCAL
POPULATIONS.
THE OPEN ACCESS MISSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
PLAQUES.
REQUIRES THE CONNECTEDNESS OF
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AND AN
AGENDA OF SERVING OUR MOST IN
NEED SERVICES AS DID INDEED
STUDENTS HOLISTICALLY.
IN ORDER TO OUT TO ACHIEVE
SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF
STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL GOALS THE
SYSTEM NEEDS CLEAR FINANCIAL AND
STRUCTURAL SUPPORT FOR ALL
STUDENTS INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH.
HEALTH SERVICES BASIC NEEDS
INCLUDING ADDRESSING FOOD
INSECURITIES TRANSPORTED
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AND
HOUSING AND SECURITIES
DISABILITY SERVICES AND
INCREASED SERVICES FOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
STEEP POP UP POPULATIONS.
JEFF ACTIVELY SERVE HIGH NEED
STUDENTS AND INCREASED
COMPLETION RATES PERHAPS THE
STUDENT NEEDS A FUNNY MODEL THAT
SUPPORTS ADDITIONAL CLASSIFIED
PERSONNEL. AND ALSO FACULTY
ADVISING DUTIES IN ADDITION TO
TEACHING LOADS.
WE WOULDN'T WEEK WE NEED
FUNDING FOR IT INSTRUCTIONAL
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH AS
TUTORING AND SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION WHICH IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO GET INSIDE
OF THE CURRENT BUDGET STRUCTURES
THAT WE HAVE.
THE DIFFICULTY REMAINS TO
EFFECTIVELY ASSESS ADDRESS
INTENTIONALLY INTERVENE AND
FOLLOW UP WITH STUDENTS AS THEY
ENTER AND MOVED THROUGH THE
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND HOLISTIC WAYS.
I FIND IT FUNNY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN PER PER STUDENT IN
WAYS THAT ADDRESS PARITY ACROSS
THE SYSTEMS.
AND MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS IN TERMS OF INSTRUCTION
AND SUPPORT ISN'T HARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADOPTED TODD
MISTER I WILL ARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BERMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND GUESS MY NAME IS JOSE
AGUILAR AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE LATE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE MASTER
PLAN FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY OUR STATE
DEVELOP A VISIONARY PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE OF HIGHER EDUCATION KNOWN
AS THE MASTER PLAN.
MUCH HAS CHANGED IN CALIFORNIA
DURING THE INCIDENT DECADES.
POPULATION GROWTH INCREASED
DIVERSE CITY. CHANGING LEAD IN
INDUSTRIES AND THEIR NEED FOR
TALENT.
AS WELL AS INNOVATIONS IN
TECHNOLOGY AND THE FEEL OF
EDUCATION EXCEPT.
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE MASTER
PLAN IS THAT IT CAN BE COMPARED
TO A THREE LEGGED STOOL. ONE LEG
REPRESENTS THE.
.
YOU NEED A COLLEGE SYSTEM ONE
LEG RISK REPRESENTS THE.
CSU SYSTEM.
AND THE.
ONE LABOR HAS THE UC SYSTEM ALL
THREE LEGS SUPPORT AND HOLD THE
SEAT PORTION OF THE STOOL.
STUDENTS. SEEKING A DEGREE ARE
AND AND. NEED OF THAT SEAT
IN MY OPINION.
THAT SEED.
OF THE STOOL REPRESENTS A
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT STUDENTS
DO SERVE AND REQUIRED TO SUCCEED
IN OBTAINING A DEGREE.
EXAMPLE OF THESE SERVICES ARE
ACADEMIC SUPPORT SERVICES.
ADMISSIONS FINANCIAL AID.
CAREER AND INVESTMENT SERVICES
HOUSING FOOD IS AND SOCIAL
SAFETY NETS PROGRAMS. HELP IN
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY AND MANY
MORE SERVICES THAT EXTEND BEYOND
THE DIRECT TEACHING AND RESEARCH
MISSION OFFERED BY THE
UNIVERSITY.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
THE LARGEST RESOURCE IN
UNIVERSITIES STATE IN THE WORLD
WITH MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND MATRICULATED
STUDENTS.
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND FOR.
FACULTY AND STAFF IN ABOUT ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION LIVING
ALUMNI.
IT INCLUDES TEN CAMPUSES FIVE
MEDICAL CENTERS.
AND THREE AFFILIATED NATIONAL
LABORATORIES
YOU SEE REMAINS COMMITTED TO
CARRYING OUT THIS RESEARCH
EDUCATION.
HEALTHCARE AND PUBLIC SERVICE
MISSIONS.
STRENGTHENING THE PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORT FOR THE MASTER PLAN FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION WILL ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY.
TO CONTINUE TO THRIVE AND
SURVIVE AN ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION.
STAY FUNDING THIS KEY AND
CRITICAL TO ENSURE ADEQUATE.
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED TO OUR
GROWING STUDENT POPULATION.
AT YOU SEE OUR LOAN WE RECEIVE
MORE THAN SIXTY THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATE OF FRESHMEN AND
TRANSFER APPLICATIONS.
FOR EVERY YEAR TO FILL
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
SEATS.
THE SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED HE'S
JOINED YOU SEE US CONTINUE
STUDENT POPULATION TO COMPRISE A
TOTAL. POPULATION OF APPROXIMATE
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THIS TOTAL AND ROLL POPULATION
ASSEMBLY INCREASES YEAR AFTER
YEAR.
DEPENDING ON INSTITUTIONAL
TIGERS AND STUDENT ACCEPTANCE
THIS.
FOR EXAMPLE TEN YEARS AGO THE
TOTEM ROLL POPULATION THAT YOU
SEE ARE.
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
THAT EQUATES TO ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT INCREASE AND ENROLL
STUDENTS IN THE LAST DECADE.
INCREASES THE STAFFING HAVE NOT
KEPT UP
TO THE STUDENT GROWTH LEVELS.
FOR EXAMPLE IT JUST ALONG IN MY
FINANCIAL AID OFFICE WE HAD A
STAFF OF TWENTY EIGHT.
FULL TIME EMPLOYEES.
SURF.
.
STUDENTS.
OF THE TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
WHEN COMPARED TO THE STAFF TEN
YEARS AGO THAT TRANSLATES TO A
SIXTY PERCENT INCREASE IN STAFF.
OVER THE TEN YEARS.
OTHER TWENTY EIGHT STAFF MEMBERS.
NINE I DECIMATED THE FINANCIALLY
COUNSELORS WHO ARE ABLE TO SERVE
OUR TOTAL STUDENT POPULATION
WHICH HAS. A COMPLEX AND UNIQUE
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
THIS TRANSLATES TO A TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED TO ONE
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID THE
STUDENT TO FINANCIALLY COUNSELOR
RATIO.
TEN YEARS AGO.
I'D EIGHT FINANCIALLY COUNSELORS
AVAILABLE TO SERVE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT REYES WHO
WAS TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SIX
STILL HIGH.
BUT IT.
IT WHEN LOOKING AT THAT AND
DOING A COMPARISON. THERE'S.
THE STUDENT TO FINANCE LABOR
ACCOUNTS SERRATIA INCREASED BY
THREE HUNDRED FORTY STUDENTS.
WE ARE.
.
REGULARLY ASKED TO DO MORE WITH
LESS AN APPETIZER SO THE STAFF
WORKING OVERTIME. TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF OUR STUDENTS EXCESS
OVER TIME I THINK KOSTAS
STEPPED BURNOUT THAT THEN LEADS
TO STAFF TURNOVER.
THE CHALLENGE IS NOT UNIQUE YOU
SEE ARE I REGULARLY ME WITH
OTHER YOU SEE FINANCIALLY
DIRECTORS TO COLLABORATE ON
VARIOUS TOPICS AND ISSUES
RELATED TO FINANCIALLY.
AT THIS MEETING AS WE HAVE
DISCUSSED THAT HE NEEDS ON
VARIOUS OCCASIONS AND WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT WERE SEVERELY
UNDERSTAFFED. TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR RESPECT THE STUDENT
BODIES.
FOR THE MORE I LIKE TO AND
KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS ALSO A
CHALLENGE IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY.
NOT A IT IS NOT YOU H. HOUSE YOU
NEED TO THE FINANCIAL AID OFFICE.
IN ADDITION TO ADEQUATE STAFF
AND WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THE STAFF.
ARE.
THE STAFF ARE ETHICALLY CUP
COMPENSATED STAFF SALARIES MUST
BE COMPETITIVE WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
I OFTENTIMES I LOSE WELL TRAINED
AND COUNT TO STAFF TO OTHER
INSTITUTIONS DUE TO LOW SALARIES.
ADEQUATE FACILITIES SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND HEALTHY WORK
ENVIRONMENTS ALSO COUNTRY TWIST
THAT MEMBERS OVERALL JOB
SATISFACTION WHICH TRANSLATES TO
IMPROVE CUSTOMER SERVICE.
TO LIKE.
CAMPUS COMMUNITY.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IS ALSO
KEY A KEY FACTOR IN ASSISTANCE
STAFF IN THE CONTINUOUS PROCESS
OF ACQUIRING A NEW IT. A
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS THAT RELATE
TO THEIR PROFESSION DRIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES OR WORK
ENVIRONMENT.
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
NEED TECHNOLOGICAL TOOLS TO
REMAIN COMPETITIVE AND PROVIDE
MORE SELF SERVICE MEN USED TO
STUDENTS.
STOOLS THESE TOOLS SHOULD BE
MITIGATES MEDICAID HIGH VOLUME
PHONE CALLS AND OFFICE VISITS.
FOR EXAMPLE ENHANCE PHONE
SYSTEMS AND WEB TOOLS WERE
REGULAR BENEFITS STUDENTS AND
PREVENT THEM FROM WAITING ON
HOLD FOR THIRTY TO SIXTY MINUTES
IT REPRESENTED TO BE AVAILABLE
DURING HIGH PEAK TIMES.
UNDERSTANDING THE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT STAFF BASIS
ALSO IMPORTANT. YOU SEE RISK WE
CONDUCT THE STAFF ENGAGEMENT
SURVEY WHICH HAS HELPED YOU SEE
ARE IDENTIFY ERISA STRENGTH.
POSITIVE WORK POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS AND COMMUNICATIONS
WITH SUPERVISORS AND ASKED OF
ATTENTION. FOR EXAMPLE WORKLOAD
AND CHANGE AND CHANGE MANAGEMENT.
AS AN INSTITUTION IT IS VITAL
FOR US.
TO COLLABORATE WITH STAFF TO
DEVELOP SOLUTIONS AND OTHER
THEIR RESPECTIVE.
PERSPECTIVE AND IN AN IMPROVING
EFFICIENCIES OF OUR CSUS.
MY RECOMMENDATION TO THE
COMMITTEE IS THAT THE MASTER
PLAN IS SURE THE STATE.
PROVIDE ADEQUATE FUNDING AND
RESOURCES FOR STAFF TO SUPPORT
STUDENT GROWTH. INCREASED
CAPACITY AND ADDRESS
DETERIORATED INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH
AS TECHNOLOGY UNDER EXISTING
CAMPUSES.
DO THEY STUDENTS THEY SERVE THE
SAME QUALITY EDUCATION ASSN PAST
GENERATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
AS WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND
ENROLLMENT WE MUST PROVIDE
STUDENTS AND STAFF. WITH THE
CLASSROOMS THE LAVATORIES THE
LIBRARIES.
AND THE LIVING AND LEARNING
SPACES THEY NEED TO THRIVE AND
SUCCEED.
AND WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT EVERY
FACULTY AND STAFF MEMBER PLACE
AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN ADVANCE IS
YOU SEE MISSION OF EDUCATION.
RESEARCH AND PUBLIC SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE MY PERSPECTIVE AN
ASSOCIATE OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE YOU VERY MUCH YOUR.
.
I'LL I'LL START I YOU KNOW.
THIS OUR FOURTH HEARING AT THE
MENTION OF THE START IN THE LAST
HEARING THAT WE HAD WAS ON ON
STUDENT NEEDS AND STUDENT
SERVICES REALLY. AND.
IT MADE ME APPRECIATE SO MUCH
MORE.
THE ROLE THAT OUR.
STUDENT SERVICES STAFF IN THE
WHOLE COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY
ECOSYSTEM.
THE THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT
ECOSYSTEM TESTING SIX.
AND AND INVESTMENT.
IN.
STUDENTS STAFF SERVICES IS SO
CRITICAL FOR TODAY'S STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY AS SO MANY MORE ARE
FACING CHALLENGES OF FOOD
INSECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS. AND
LACK OF ACCESS TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
AND IT'S REALLY FROM JUST BEEN
EYE OPENING FOR ME YEAH HEARING
THE STORIES FROM STUDENTS.
THAT WE HAVE OVER THE PAST.
I'M ONLY BEEN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR YEAR AND A HALF BUT JIMMY
DEAN IS BEEN THERE FOR LONGER.
YOU KNOW AT IT MAKES ME
APPRECIATE. THE NEED FOR IT FOR
MORE INVESTMENT.
YOU BOTH ANSWERED A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD BUT I GUESS
ONE THAT I ASK. IS.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S ONE THING THAT.
YOU WISH OUR CALLINGS
UNDERSTOOD ABOUT STUDENT
SERVICES STAFF WHEN WE'RE
CRAFTING POLICY. OF FOR A HIGHER
EDUCATION.
FOR THE NEXT.
COUPLE GENERATION.
WELL.
NO MYSELF I THINK.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH AN IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF CHANGE AT OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND SOME OF THE THE
THE QUESTION THAT'S THAT'S OUT
HIS FOR SO LONG.
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS FILL OUR
CLASSES WITH ENROLLMENT WE'VE
ALSO WAITED FOR STUDENTS MANY
TIMES TO SHOW UP TO FIND PLACES
ON CAMPUS TO? TO GET SUPPORT.
AND THERE'S BEEN A BEEN A REAL
SHIFT I THINK THE LAST THREE TO
FIVE YEARS ABOUT THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE INTENTIONALLY. GO AFTER
AND WORK WITH STUDENTS IN NEW
WAYS AND THAT AND THAT HAS HAS
HAS BEEN LARGELY AN EFFORT
THAT'S AROUND EQUITY.
THINKING ABOUT HOW DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS OF STUDENTS ARE
DOING ON ON OUR CAMPUSES.
AND SO THIS THIS CHANGE FROM
MOVING FROM ENROLLMENT TO
SUCCESS AS THE FOCUS A OF OUR
COLLEGES IT MIGHT SOUND LIKE
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE. IT NOT THAT
WE WERE DOING THAT ALL ALONG BUT
THE WAY IN WHICH WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PERHAPS BEING FUNDED.
AYE HAS HAS STARTED NEW
CONVERSATIONS ON OUR CAMPUSES SO.
WHAT THAT LEAVES US WITH THIS
BEAR DECADES OF THE WAYS IN
WHICH WE HAVE RUN PERSONNEL AND
HAVE HAD STOCK IN PER PARTICULAR
LOCATIONS ON OUR CAMPUS? AND
THIS MEANS MAJOR TRANSFORM
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE FOR OUR
LOCAL INSTITUTIONS AND HOW DO WE
BEST PROVIDE.
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW TO SERVE
STUDENTS BETTER.
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW TO BEST BUT
WORK ON EQUITY BEING.
IN IN INCOME INCLUSIVITY ON OUR
CAMPUSES HOW DO WE BEST WORK
WITH.
PARENTS AND FAMILIES HOW DO WE
BEST SERVE NOW ON IN A MUCH MORE
A MERCHANT A WORK FORCE AN ADULT
LEARNERS THAT ARE TRYING TO
ACCESS OUR CAMPUSES. IT MEANS
REALLY RESTRUCTURING OUR STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES SO THE KINDS OF
FUNDING AND THE KIND OF
ATTENTION AND I THINK THAT
ADMINISTRATION AND SUPPORT STAFF
NEED. ARE ARE DEVELOPING MODELS
THAT CAN BE EFFECTIVELY USE THAT
CAMPUSES AND HOW BROAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO TRANSFORM
ON THE CAMERA'S RIGHT AND HOW
ARE WE GOING TO DO THAT BETTER?
AND WE CAN IT'S INTERESTING WE
HAVE THREE SILOS.
I'M ON THESE PANELS AND WE'RE
NOT WE NEED TO THINK TOO ABOUT
HOW WE WORK ACROSS OUR SYSTEMS
RIGHT NOW JUST HOW WE CAN
INTENTIONALLY DOING ON OUR
CAMPUS HOW WE CAN TO PROVIDE
STUDENTS. WITH SYSTEMS OF
TECHNOLOGY AND TECHNOLOGY FOR
INSTITUTIONS THAT STUDENTS CAN
THINK ABOUT POINT A TO POINT Z.
AT ENDING AT A YOU SEE OR ANY
POLICY S. YOU SO THEY CAN SEE
THEIR ENTIRE EDUCATIONAL PLAN
AND NEEDS TO BE SEAMLESS. AND
MANY DEVELOP PROCESSES AND WAITS
FOR STUDENTS TO MEET THERE ARE
INSTITUTIONS EASILY AS A LOT OF
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE AND
MONEY NEEDS TO BE.
FUNDED REPORTS THAT OVER THE
NEXT AT LEAST THREE TO FIVE
YEARS AS WE TRANSITION.
YEAH I COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH
WITH THAT. THE COMMENTS AND NOW
ALSO.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO RECOGNIZE AS AS WELL IS THAT
AS WE.
I IN TERMS OF SERVICES AS WE
GROW MORE AS A STUDENT ROMAN
GIRLS ARE THERE MORE SERVICES
REQUIRE OTHER THAN THE CORE
SERVICES THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED
IN THE PAST FOR EXAMPLE MENTAL
HEALTH.
AT SOME OF THE INITIATIVES THAT
YOU YOU HAD MENTIONED AS WELL AS.
THAT YOU KNOW.
THE NIECE OF BASIC NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE ALL THOSE RESOURCES.
WE NEED TIME AND INCLUDE THAT
WHEN WE'RE HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSES A SPARSE POLICY AND
ALSO LOOK AT POLICY. THAT IS
PREVENTING FROM US MOVING
FORWARD TO TO SERVICE THE
STUDENTS TO ADEQUATELY SOMETIMES
WERE MORE WRAPPED UP.
AND MEETING THAT COMPLIANCE IN
THE POLICY REQUIREMENTS FROM THE
STATE AS WELL AS FROM THE GOD OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THAT YOU
KNOW WE. TEND TO LOSE THE BABY
OFFERING THAT'S THAT'S CUSTOMER
SERVICE TO THE STUDENT THEY
REALLY NEED AND WHEN A STUDENT
COMES TO MY OFFICE FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU KNOW IF THEY DON'T WHEN THEY
COME AT A HIGH SCHOOL THAT WILL
COME OUT WITH THE HIGH SCHOOL.
WITH FINANCIAL AID EDUCATION
THEN THERE IS SOMETHING NEW TO
THE UNIVERSITY OR TO THE STUDENT
AND THE FAMILY. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT EACH COMPLEX OFF
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCE THAT THE
STUDENTS FINDS HIMSELF.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE THAT'S LEVEL
OF SERVICE THAT WHERE THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE. AND THEY FEEL.
EMPOWERED TO MAKE THE DECISION
TO COME TO THE UNIVERSITY AND
LOOKING AT. YOU KNOW THE FUTURE
EXPENSIVE THEY HAVE IN FRONT OF
THEM.
NOW REALLY APPRECIATE BOTH YOUR
COMMENTS AND AND NOW DOCTOR JUST
CALL FROM CSU DURING HIS HOUSE
CAN BE YEAR.
SOUGHT TO SAY THAT I THINK
GERMANY THE AMOUNT OF BEEN WITH
ME.
WE TOOK A TOUR OF CSU DOMINGUEZ
HILLS AND THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT IN THIS PROACTIVE. NOW YOU
KNOW OUR REACH IN THAT THAT THEY
DO AND USING TECHNOLOGY
IDENTIFY WHEN THEY'RE RED FLAGS
IN FIRST JUNE.
AND FIND IT YOU KNOW SEEING
THAT WHEN IT HAPPENS IN THE
PROVIDING THAT STUDENT WITH A
LITTLE SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICE IT
WILL SUBMIT A HELP. THAT AT THAT
POINT RATHER THAN WAITING UNTIL
IT GETS WORSE AND THERE ARE RISK
OF DROPPING OUT SO YOU KNOW
USING TECHNOLOGY TO IDENTIFY.
YOU KNOW WHEN THE STUDENT IS
STRUGGLING AND AND WHAT
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT BE PROVIDED
FOR THEM CAN SAVE A LOT OF OF
MONEY AND TIME AND HEART ACHE.
DOWN THE ROAD.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
REALLY NEED A.
TRY TO GET BETTER AT DOING SO.
AND IN THE TECHNOLOGICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO GAIN MORE EFFICIENCIES
THERE AND BE MORE TRANSPARENT
WITH STUDENTS AND I THINK. THE
GLOBAL INTERSECT MENTAL APPROACH
AGAIN ISN'T IT TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE STOCK PIPELINE LOOK
LIKE AND HOW ARE WE GOING TO.
GET BACK TO AN IDEA THAT.
THAT WE HAVE YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
HUNDRED OF FOURTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ALL OVER CALIFORNIA AT
THAT ARE SERVING STUDENTS THAT
ALSO NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO MOVE THROUGH
YOUR FINISHED A BACHELOR'S
DEGREES ABSOLUTELY.
NOPE DOT ORG WITH THAT.
PLEASE.
THANK THE PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I AND OUR LAST PANEL.
OF OF THE HEARING IS GOING TO
BE THE NEEDS OF STAFF.
FOR UNION PERSPECTIVE I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME BILL RAWLINGS
COMPUTER FACILITIES COORDINATOR
AND CHAIR OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COMMITTEE. OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
VICKI MACLEOD IT BUDGET
SPECIALIST AND VICE CHAIR OF
WHAT IS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE AT THE CSU M. AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES UNION.
AND CHRISTINE STOCKY SENIOR
CUSTODIAN ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY
TWO NINETY NINE REPRESENTATIVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
TODAY. AND IT BILL IF YOU WANNA
KICK US OFF THEIR THING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS BILL RAWLINGS I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. AND I'VE BEEN A
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE AT MOUNT SAN
ANTONIO COLLEGE FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION CSEA.
CCA REPRESENTS OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES. I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE CSEA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR THOUGHTS AND
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW TO MAKE OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM BETTER.
SPECIFICALLY I WAS ESTA FOCUS ON
THE NEEDS OF CLASSIFIED STAFF IN
THREE AREAS
SO FIRST.
WHAT WE NEED TO BETTER SUPPORT
STUDENTS?
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ARE THE
EXTRAORDINARY WORKERS WHO DO THE
ESSENTIAL WORK TO KEEP A
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES CLEAN
SAFE AND FUNCTIONAL.
WE MAKE SURE THAT EVERY STUDENT
FACULTY ADMINISTRATOR INVESTOR
HAVE AN ENJOYABLE AND EFFECTIVE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT TO PURSUE
THEIR ACADEMIC CAREER AND LIFE
GOALS.
LIKE ANY PROFESSION BETTER PAY
HELPS TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
BETTER PROFESSIONALS
AND MORE STAFFING WILL ENSURE
THAT ADDITIONAL VITAL SERVICES
CAN BE PROVIDED ADEQUATELY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
FROM THE MOMENT THAT A STUDENT
FIRST VENTURES ON CAMPUS TO THE
DAY THAT THE GRADUATE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ARE INVOLVED IN ALL
ASPECTS OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
JOURNEY.
IN COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
STUDENTS TING MANY SERVICES TO
SUCCEED.
HAVING MORE SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ON
CAMPUS MEANS BEING ABLE TO
DELIVER MORE SERVICES TO
STUDENTS INCLUDING MORE
FINANCIAL AID SERVICES MORE
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES. COUNSELING
TUTORING HEALTHCARE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT CAMPUS SAFETY
JOB PLACEMENT SERVICES JUST TO
NAME A FEW.
BUT THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT
OUR MEMBERS REPEATEDLY ASKED FOR
IS TO GET MORE TRAINING AND
ONGOING PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
I THINK THIS IS A THEME WE'VE
HEARD A BIT TODAY.
IN THIS EVER CHANGING WORLD WE
WANT AND NEED TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
CONTINUOUSLY UPGRADE OUR SKILLS
AND LEARN BEST PRACTICES TO MEET
THE CHANGING NEEDS OF STUDENTS
AND FACULTY.
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS
INCREASES IN SOCIAL MEDIA AND
COMMUNICATION CURRICULA FORMS AS
WELL AS OTHER RISKS AND DANGER
REQUIRES TO A PETER SKILLS AND
KEEP UP WITH CHANGING TIMES.
FOR EXAMPLE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF MULTIPLE MEASURES FOR
ASSESSMENT.
WHO REQUIRE MANY OF ARE ECONOMIC
TO SUPPORT STAFF? TO ADAPT TO
THE INCREASED IN A TRANSFER
LEVEL STUDENTS.
SO WITHOUT ONGOING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WE MAY NOT HAVE THE
LATEST INFORMATION AND SKILLS TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS AND SUPPORT THEIR
SUCCESS.
SECOND. WHERE THE CHOSEN
BARRIERS CLASSIFIED STAFF IN
MEETING THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
AND HOW ARE THESE ADDRESSED?
WE NEED TO FIND A WAY TO STOP OR
MINIMIZE THE REPEATED USE OF
SHORT TERM INTEMPERATE PLOYS
WERE OFTEN MINIMALLY TRAINED AND
SKILLED. AS A WAY TO AVOID
PROVIDING HEALTH AND RETIREMENT
BENEFITS TO EMPLOYEES.
MANY COLLEGES HIGHER NON
PERMANENT CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
SUCH AS STUDENT WORKER SHORT
TERM WORKERS EXTENDED
SUBSTITUTES AND PROFESSIONAL
EXPERTS IN LIEU OF HIRING MORE
PERMANENT CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
CERTAIN CONDITIONS EXIST TO
WARRANT THE USE OF HIS TEMPORARY
SHORT TERM EMPLOYEES TO FILL A
LIMITED TEMPORARY ME. HOWEVER
THE NEED TRULY SHOULD BE LIMITED
AND THEY SHOULD NOT OUTNUMBER
THE NUMBER OF PERMANENT
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
WE'VE SEEN AN ENFORCER PATTERN
WERE SOME DISTRICTS HAVE
DEVELOPED THE PRACTICE OF HIRING
SHORT TERM EMPLOYEES FOR ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR DAYS.
LAYING THEM OFF AND THEN RE
HIRING THEM FOR THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR.
THIS PRACTICE IS REPEATED YEAR
AFTER YEAR CIRCUMVENTING THE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE DAYS ROLE
THEREBY DENYING THESE EMPLOYEES
HEALTH BENEFITS LEAVES HOLIDAYS
AND ALL OF THE RIGHTS OF
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
ALSO SOME COLLEGES HIGHER
MULTIPLE PART TIME CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES INSTEAD OF FEWER FULL
TIME CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IN
ORDER TO AVOID PAYING HEALTH
INSURANCE BENEFITS AND SHIPPING
TO CALPERS OUR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
SOME POSITIONS MAY BE SUED WAS
PART TIME POSITIONS BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THE WORK. HOWEVER
WHEN THE WORK CAN BE DONE BY ONE
PERSON AND A FULL TIME POSITION
WE'D PREFER THAT HAPPENED VERSUS
PUTTING THE WORK BETWEEN TWO
PART TIME POSITIONS. TO AVOID
PAYING THE HEALTH AND.
WE BELIEVE FULL TIME POSITIONS
ENCOURAGE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
BE MORE COMMITTED TO THEIR JOB.
MORE INVESTED IN THE OUTCOMES
THEY HELPED PRODUCE WITH OUR
STUDENTS AND MORE ENGAGE IN THE
CAMPUS CULTURE THEREBY PROMOTING
A CONSISTENT WORKFORCE INSTEAD
OF CONSTANT TURNING.
HIGH TURNOVER AND MULTIPLE
VACANCIES CAN ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO
INCREASED WORKLOAD ON THE
REMAINING STAFF
WHICH SOMETIMES RESULTS IN
DECREASED ACCESS AND SERVICES TO
STUDENTS. AND DECREASED EMPLOYEE
MORALE.
PROTECTING EMPLOYEE RIGHTS AND
BENEFITS CONTINUE TO BE A
POTENTIAL KEY BARRIER AND
CHALLENGE FOR SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS.
THIRD HOW SHOULD THE MASTER PLAN
MEET THE NEEDS OF STAFF WHAT IS
ONE ACTIONS TAKEN TAKE THAT
WOULD NOT REQUIRE FUNDING. AND
ONE ACTION THAT THE STATE CAN
TAKE A THAT WOULD REQUIRE FRONT.
THEIR STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT
COLLABORATION BETWEEN LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT ADVOCATES WHO TWELVE
CAMPUS LEADS TO BETTER STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
OUR CURRENT STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM
TORRANCE AND HAS DONE A LOT OF
WORK IN THIS AREA THROUGH HIS
LABOR MANAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
IT BRINGS TOGETHER THE SCHOOL
BOARD THE FACT THE CLASSIFIED
UNION SEE AND THE ADMINISTRATION
TO ADDRESS BUDGET ISSUES AND
CAMPUS ISSUES.
THE DISCUSSIONS ARE NOT ALWAYS
AMICABLE BUT THROUGH RESPECT AND
COMMUNICATION. THE RESULTANT
IMPACT ON STUDENTS ARE CLEAR THE
GRADES IMPROVE.
IN SOME WAYS IT'S ALMOST COMMON
SENSE THAT WHEN ALL EDUCATORS
RECORDED IN THEIR MISSION
STUDENTS BENEFIT.
IT IS THIS NOTION OF SHARED
GOVERNANCE I BELIEVE WILL MAKE
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
BETTER FOR STUDENTS.
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
IDEA PARTICIPATORY GOVERNANCE
PERMEATES FROM THE STATE LEVEL
FROM THE CONSULTATION COUNCIL OR
DOWN TO THE LOCAL LEVEL IN AND
BUT COMMITTEE.
I WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER BUILDING THE FUTURE
MASTER PLAN A CALL FOR SHARED
GOVERNANCE BETWEEN BOARD MEMBERS
ADMINISTRATORS FACTLY AND
CLASSIFIED STAFF.
IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO
PACIFIC WE HAVE THE EXCLUSIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE WORKERS
AS A MEMBER AND PARTICIPANT IN
THE SHARED GOVERNANCE PROCESS.
WE MAY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
VIEWPOINTS BUT OUR COMMON GOAL
IS THE SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS.
ALSO INCLUDING US IN THE SHARED
GOVERNANCE PROCESS HAS MINIMAL
TO NO FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS.
BUT WHAT CAN WE DO IF WE HAD
MORE FUNDING.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE GO BACK
TO LOOK AT MORE FULL TIME
STAFFING.
AS WELL AS IMPROVE PAIN BENEFITS
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
RETAIN OUR HARD WORKING
EMPLOYEES.
HAVING DEDICATED AND ENGAGED
EMPLOYEES IS A NECESSARY
INVESTMENT IN OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES FOR THE DIRECT
IMPACT ON STUDENTS TO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND.
THANK YOU BILL OF VICKI MACLEOD
YES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN.
FOR INVITING CSU YOU HERE TODAY
TO REPRESENT OUR EMPLOYEES THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AND ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR
WEBER.
I'M I'D LIKE TO START OFF MY
NAME'S VICKI I AM HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING SEE ISSUE EMPLOYEES
UNION THAT WE REPRESENT SIXTEEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES. AND I'M ALSO
AN EMPLOYEE AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON. BEEN THERE SEVEN
YEARS AND ALSO WORKED AT CAL
POLY POMONA FOR TWENTY FOUR SIDE
BEEN IN THE SYSTEM FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
THE SUPPORT STAFF OF THE CS YOU
ARE THE BACKBONE EN BANC BRAIN
TRUST OF THE UNIVERSITY BUT WERE
OFTEN OVERLOOKED.
THE FIRST INNER ACTION AS
STUDENT EXPERIENCES WHEN CALLING
ARE WALKING INTO A CSU OFFICE IS
WHAT THE STAFF MEMBER.
THE SERVICE PROVIDED TO STUDENTS
PARENTS AND OFTEN ON CAMPUS
COMMUNITY IS THOROUGH AND BODIES
A CARING CHARACTERISTIC TO
PROMOTE THE CSU MISSION
STATEMENT. OF INVESTING IN OUR
STUDENTS
TO PREPARE PREPARE THEM TO ENTER
THE COMMUNITY AND TO CONTRIBUTE
TO CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE.
MANY EMPLOYEES HAVE WORKED AT A
CSU CAMPUS FOR FOR YEARS.
IN ORDER TO ASSIST STUDENTS
SUPPORT STAFF POSITIONS SHOULD
BE FULLY FUNDED AND EMPLOYEES
NEED TO MOVE THROUGH THE SALARY
RANGE TO RETAIN CAMPUS WORKFORCE.
SEE IF YOU YOU IS ACTUALLY
SPONSORING A BILL WITH DR I
WEBER IT'S ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
THIRTY ONE. AND I'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT IN A LITTLE WHILE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
EMPLOYEES RECEIVED FURLOUGHS AND
LAYOFFS FOLLOWED NUMEROUS
POSITIONS HAVE NOT BEEN FILLED
SON FAN BUT THE REMAINING
EMPLOYEES CONTINUE TO ASSUME THE
DUTIES OF THE VACANT POSITIONS.
STAFF ARE COMMONLY TOLD TO DO
MORE WITH LESS AND THE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THIS VACANT POSITIONS DO NOT
INCLUDE AND SALARY INCREASE.
STAFF AREN'T IMPORTANT COMMUNITY
PLAYER AND DEDICATED TO SERVING
STUDENTS WHERE THE TRUST THAT
MANAGEMENT THAT MANAGES
IMPORTANT TASK.
I ENROLLING STUDENTS IN CLASSES.
HIRING STUDENT WORKERS KEEPING
OUR CAMPUSES CLEAN. RUNNING THE
FRONT OFFICE HANDLING BUDGETARY
FINANCIAL AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSISTANCE SUPPORTING FACULTY
ADMINISTRATORS AND CARING FOR
STUDENTS.
WE SHARED GOALS TO BILL
SOLUTIONS TO BETTER OUR STUDENTS.
THE FINANCIAL STATUS FOR MANY OF
OUR EMPLOYEES IS GRAHAM AND
DURING THE FIFTH FURLOUGHS THE
TASK OF TAKING TWO JOBS WAS
NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
MANY STAFF LOST THEIR HOMES.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT STUDENTS
FACULTY ADMINISTRATORS AND THE
PUBLIC KNOW THE CHALLENGES THAT
STAFF FACE.
OUR DEDICATED EMPLOYEES TREAT
THIS ISSUE CAMPUS AS THEIR HOME
AWAY FROM HOME.
THE COMMITMENT AND DEVOTION OUR
STAFF REPRESENT DALY IS
COMPATIBLE TO BEING A PROUD
MOTHER.
PARENT I AM THE PROUD MOTHER
BECAUSE MY STUDENT GRADUATED
FROM CSU FULLERTON TWO YEARS AGO.
DEATH WANT STUDENTS TO SUCCEED
AND ACCOMPLISH THEIR DRAIN WITH
A DEGREE IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE FACE MANY CHALLENGES WE WEAR
MANY HATS.
EMPLOYEES AS I MENTIONED HAVE
RETIRED THE POSITIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN REPLACED.
ACCEPTING ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
AND COMMITTING TO HIRING DIVERSE
FACULTY IS SUPPORTED BY STAFF.
BUT OUR EMPLOYEES TEND TO NOT BE
MENTIONED.
THERE IS A VOID IN ADDRESSING
THE NEED TO INCREASE STAFF
POSITIONS.
SUPPORT STAFF SHOULD BE INCLUDED
WHEN DIALOGUE TAKES PLACE THAT
AFFECTS THE CAMPUS SO THAT
EMPLOYEES CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE
STUDENTS PRODUCTIVELY.
MANY DEPARTMENTS ON CAMPUS HOUSE
ONE STAFF MEMBER TO ASSIST A
LARGE STUDENT AND FACULTY
POPULATION.
SUPPORT STAFF ARE THE FRONTLINE
IN THE FIRST CONTACT
STUDENT INNER ACTS WITH ONE
BEING ADMITTED. WE GIVE THEM
GUIDANCE AS MENTIONED EARLIER WE
ENROLLED IN CLASSES LEARNING THE
DEPARTMENT AND FACULTY AND
UNDERSTANDING THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES OF EACH CAMPUS.
STAFF CREATE ORGANIZE
COLLABORATE PRIORITIZE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT DIED AND
MONITOR STUDENTS TOWARDS THEIR
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS.
THE MASTER PLAN. AND THE
CALIFORNIA SITE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM SHOULD TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE KNOWLEDGE
EXPERTISE LONGEVITY AND
DEDICATION THAT STAFF SUPPLY TO
THE CSU CAMPUSES.
THERE ARE EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
DEDICATED THEIR CAREER WE
ENCOURAGE FAMILY TO ATTEND TO
SEE ISSUE AND RETREAT THIS ISSUE
OUR EMPLOYMENT AS FAMILY.
THE ISSUE YOU HAS REQUESTED TO
HAVE A SUPPORT STAFF SEAT ON THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES WE'VE DONE
THIS THREE TIMES TO THREE
DIFFERENT BILLS AND IT'S BEEN
VETOED.
THERE IS A STUDENT AND ALUMNI
AND THE FACULTY REPRESENTATIVE
ON THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES BUT NO
STAFF DELEGATE.
ALLOWING INPUT FROM SUPPORT
STAFF.
WOULD GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY AN
INSIGHT FROM THE PERSON WHO
WORKS DALY AND INNER ACTS WITH
STUDENTS TO GIVE CONCERNS AND
ISSUES.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER CSU A
SPONSORING A BILL BY DOCTOR
WEBER IS THE AUTHOR IT'S AB
TWELVE THIRTY ONE AND THAT IS TO
RESOURCE RESTORE SALARY STEPS
FOR SUPPORT STAFF.
THIS WOULD BRING BACK A FIVE
PERCENT INCREASE BASED ON AN
ANNUAL PERFORMANCE EVALUATION.
THIS WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM SUPPORT
STAFF OF THIS ISSUE NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS AGO.
THE BILL WILL RE ESTABLISH
PARITY WITH ALL OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND PARITY WITH THE
HALF MILLION STATE EMPLOYEES WHO
ALREADY HAVE SALARY STEPS.
THIS WAS HEARD IN THE ASSEMBLY
FOREIGN AND IT WAS PASSED AND I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
MEDINA AND BERMAN FOR VOTING YES
ON OUR BILL. AND IT WILL BE
HEARD ON MAY NINTH IN THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
THERE HAS BEEN A RECENT TREND OF
NEWLY HIRED SUPPORT STAFF
LEADING THE C. S. YOU DUE TO NO
MOVEMENT THROUGH THE SALARY
RANGE.
BY NOT RETAIN THE EMPLOYEES THE
DUTIES ONCE AGAIN FALL ON THE
REMAINING EMPLOYEES AS
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE IN
MEMORY. RETENTION IS AN ISSUE
FOR OUR EMPLOYEES AND THERE IS A
DISSERVICE TO OUR STUDENTS.
THERE'S ALSO.
AN INVERSION SO MANY EMPLOYEES
WHO HAVE BEEN THERE SUCH AS
MYSELF FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS WE
HAVE NEWLY EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
BEING HIRED BUT HIRED AT A
HIGHER SALARY. AND THAT CAUSES A
MORALE ISSUE AMONG STAFF.
IN AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER ED
COMMITTEE AND THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION HELD A
SPECIAL HEARING. TO REVIEW THE
STATE AUDIT OF THE CSU PERSONNEL
AND BUDGET PRACTICES. THE AUDIT
WAS RELEASED IN APRIL OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
THE ARCTIC DEMONSTRATED THE
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN MANAGEMENT
PERSONNEL AND STAFF POSITIONS.
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER ED COMMITTEE
HEARD AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE IN
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND IT
WAS SUGGESTED BY SENATOR ROCK
THAT THE CS CONDUCT AND
EMPLOYMENT SURVEY TO DETERMINE
IF THE UNIVERSITY OF HOUSING THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS.
AGAINST FACULTY AND STAFF
THIS SURVEY WOULD DETERMINE IF
THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES ARE HIRED TO
EFFECTIVELY SERVE OUR STUDENT
POPULATION.
THE SURVEY IS AN ACTION THE
STATE CAN TAKE THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT REQUIRE FUNDING.
THE UNIVERSITIES CONTINUE TO
FUNCTION TO SUPPORT STUDENTS AND
STAFF ARE EMPLOYED TWELVE MONTHS
OUT OF THE YEAR.
WE REMAIN ON CAMPUS ONCE THE
SEMESTER CONCLUDES DURING
DECEMBER BREAK SPRING BREAK AND
SUMMER SESSION. WE SUPPORT
STUDENTS MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY
EIGHT TO FIVE MANY OF THEM OR
EMPLOYEES.
WORK OVERTIME TO JUST SERVE OUR
STUDENTS.
EMPLOYEES KNOW THAT OUR NUMBER
ONE GOAL IS TO SUPPORT STUDENTS
SO THEY HAVE ACCESS TO AN
EXCELLENT EDUCATION.
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE I JUST HAD AN
ADVANTECH CAL STATE FULLERTON
YESTERDAY IN REGARDING OUR
CAMPUS MASTER PLAN AND IT WAS.
KIND OF STRUCTURING THE SAME
TALKS THAT ARE HERE TODAY AS NOT
ONLY ON HOW TO SERVE STEVE
STUDENTS BUT ALSO OUR FACILITIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE ON OUR CAMPUS.
THOUGH AGAIN I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR INVITING SEIZE YOU EMPLOYEES
UNION TODAY TO GIVE OUR FOCUS
AND INPUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HUMAN
CLOUD AND NEXT WE HAVE CHRISTIAN.
YES.
CHRISTINE DUCKIE I AM A UNION
REP. FROM ASPIRIN THIRTY TO
NINETY NINE I'M HERE TO SPEAK
ABOUT. WHAT WE ARE DOING? ON S..
BEEN A CUSTODIAN.
I'M A RESIDENT OF RIVERSIDE BEEN
LIVING HERE ALL MY LIFE.
HOME ONE DAY I WAS IN THE
PROGRAM AT UC I AND I SAID WHO I
WOULD LOVE TO WORK HERE. MY
DREAM CAME TRUE.
I'M HERE. AND.
I'D BEEN HERE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
YOU SEE IT'S A BEAUTIFUL PLACE
TO WORK.
AND WE KEEP IT BEAUTIFUL THE
CUSTODIAN THE YARD PEOPLE IN THE
COOKS THE TO EAT THEIR FOOD. AND.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOOD.
HOGAN I GUESS YEAH NEARING.
AND I'M HERE TO SAY THAT YOU
KNOW BEING A CUSTODIAN WERE
UNDERSTAFFED.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH EQUIPMENT
TO WORK.
WE ARE.
WORKING WITH LESS.
BUT WORKING WITH MAKING THEM
MAKE US WORK WITH MORE WE HAVE
MORE BUILDINGS TO DO THE LAST
PEOPLE TO DO WITH.
AND.
THE YA I PEOPLE HAVE MORE WORK
TO DO ANALYST'S YOU KNOW TO DO
WITH.
AND WE'RE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH
OUR.
WORKING TOGETHER.
ARE.
LIFTING US UP MAKING SURE THAT
YOU KNOW WE DO A GOOD JOB FOR
THE STUDENT.
BECAUSE TO COME INTO A CLEAN
BATHROOM.
THE PLACE TO BE.
YEAH AND I'M NOT.
WE JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT.
BEEN MIS TREATED.
NOT BEING APPRECIATED.
NOT BEING WORTHY OF WHY WE HAVE
TO WORK SO HARD.
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS.
I'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS.
AND I SEEM LIKE IT'S NOT GETTING
ANY BETTER IS GETTING WORSE.
ARM THE PEOPLE.
.
DON'T WANT TO HIRE US TO BE
SUPERVISOR.
THE BLACKS AND THE WHITES ARE
GETTING LESS.
PULLED UP INSTEAD OF BEING MORE
EQUALLY WE'RE GETTING LESS.
THE UPS OF ILL.
IT'S GETTING WORSE.
WE WANT TO BE TREATED AS EQUALS
WE ONE OF WE ENJOY DOING OUR JOB.
AND. INSTEAD OF TAKING STUFF
AWAY FROM MONTH LIKE I BENEFITS
I HEALTHCARE. I WOULD LOVE TO
RETIRE HERE BUT THEY'RE MAKING
IT HARDER AND HARDER EVERY YEAR.
WHY DO WE HAVE TO FIGHT EVERY
YEAR?
WE DO SUCH A GOOD JOB CLEANING BUT PLAYING FIELD TO TO IT FAIR.
WE ENJOYED WORKING HERE YOU SEE
THE CAP IS LOOKING GOOD RIGHT
NOW.
IT TAKES ALL OF US TO DO THAT.
AND TO KEEP THAT SPIRIT GOING.
WE NEED TO BE TREATED.
INSTEAD OF TAKING ALL AYE
BENEFITS ALL OUR HILL.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING
WITH ME.
THEY'RE NO LONGER FEELING LIKE
THEY'RE WORTHY.
THERE WHO MISTREATED.
THEY ARE UNHAPPY.
AND. THEY WANT TO BE TREATED.
THE WAY THE CAMPUS LOOKS.
IT TAKES ALL OF US.
AND ALL WE HAVE TO SAY IS.
PLEASE.
SUPPORT US
BE THERE BEHIND US IN WHEN YOU
SEE US WORK AND GIVE US A SMILE.
YOU KNOW.
WE WORK HARD YEAH.
WE WANT TO BE TREATED.
IN.
WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO STOP
OUTSOURCING ARE JOB.
WE ARE ON THE I USED TO WORK IN
THE KITCHEN AT THE CATERING TO
COOK I DON'T KNOW NONE OF THEM
PEOPLE KNOW MORE.
ARMY IS JUST.
EVERY DAY COMING TO WORK IN NO
AND IF I HAVE A JOB IF I DON'T.
YOU KNOW.
PLEASE.
TO NOT OUT SOURCE OUR JOB KEEP
US WORKING.
KEEP WAS BEING.
THE CAMPUS THE CHAFEE. IN THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU WORK WITH.
ALL WE ASK IS GIVE US A PLAYING
FIELD FAIR.
SO WEAKENED WORK.
THANK YOU WHAT IT THANK YOU MS
STUCKY I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
ONLY THING.
MR MEDINA JR MEDINA IS
CONSTANTLY BRAGGING ABOUT HOW
BEAUTIFUL YOU SEE OUR IS AND AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT
YOU DO.
SO REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU ABSOLUTE.
SO CLOSE TO FORTY FIVE YEARS AGO.
I DROVE FROM INDIANA.
CROSS THE U. S..
RIGHT.
TO YOU SEE ARE.
I I TRANSFERRED FROM A PRODUCER
UNIVERSITY TO. UC RIVERSIDE.
ABOUT FORTY FIVE YEARS AGO.
I I PULLED UP INTO THE A AND AYE
DOOR NOT TOO FAR FROM HERE.
PARK MY VOLKSWAGEN AND WENT TO
THE FRONT DESK IN THE FIRST
PERSON THAT I SAW WAS A CLERICAL
PERSON.
WITH THAT WOMAN WHO I STILL
REMEMBER HER NAME IS KATHY.
DIRECTED ME TO A DORM.
AND TO A FLOOR THAT MAYBE YOU
KNOW IT CHANGED MY LIFE.
BECAUSE SHE SAW YOU KNOW THAT.
I MIGHT HAVE INTEREST IN BEING
AND.
CASSIE'S PANIC AT.
AND SO SHE DIRECTED ME TO THAT
DORMITORY WHEN I WENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HISTORY OR LATIN
AMERICAN STUDIES. AND I SPOKE
WITH THE SECRETARY WHO IS A
SECRETARY WHO MADE SURE THAT I
GOT THE CLASSES THAT I NEEDED.
AND HAD THE UNITS THAT I NEEDED
TO GRADUATE ON TIME.
.
I LIVED IN A NIGHT DORM SO THE
PEOPLE WHO PREPARED THE FOOD.
EVERYDAY.
THE THREE MEALS A DAY YOU KNOW
WERE IMPORTANT TO ME.
THAT MY ROOM WAS CLEAN.
THE MY ROOM WAS CLEAN WHEN I
WATCH FROM A AND I. TO THE
LIBRARY.
I SAW THE MAINTENANCE I SAW THE
GROUNDS
YOU KNOW KIND OF.
PERFECTLY I CARED FOR.
SOMETIMES I THINK IS STUDENTS WE
MAY NOT.
SEE YOU KNOW WHO ARE THE FOLKS
WHO MAINTAINED A LIKE YOU SAID
THE BATHROOMS AND THE AND THE
GRASS AND THE CLASSROOMS THAT WE
SIT ON. BUT.
.
WE RECOGNIZE IN THE LEGISLATURE
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT YOU DO
OF WE ARE FIGHTING TO MAKE SURE.
THAT YOU SEE DOES NOT OUTSOURCE
I THINK WE HAD A BILL LAST YEAR.
THAT THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T SIGN
FOR THE SIMILAR BILL IS COMING
THROUGH AGAIN. WE HOPE THIS YEAR
GETS THE GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE.
SO ONLY SOMEONE LIKE NAM.
WITH WITH
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING UNVEILED THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO
EVERY DAY YES SOMETIMES.
YOU MIGHT DO YOUR JOB TOO WELL.
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T NOTICE HOW
CLEAN IT IS AN AND HOW NICE IT
IS BELOW NOTICE WHEN IT'S NOT
YEAH.
IT'S SO.
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU
DO AND THANK YOU FOR COMING AND
PARTICIPATING IN THE PANEL AND
YOUR ADVOCACY IN SACRAMENTO AS
WELL.
THEY HERE AND I DO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF OUT AND
LIVES FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER
AND COMMUNICATING WITH US SO I
KNOW STAFF ARE A VERY IMPORTANT
PART IN. EVERYBODY'S MORNING
QUIRK I I APPRECIATE THAT I'LL
I'LL I'LL JUMP THAT IN MY IN MY
PLAN COMMENTS AND AND THINK ALAN
GREEN MY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR.
THE MOVEMENTS COMMUNITY MEANS MY
ASSEMBLY FELLOW AND SOMEWHERE
THERE'S.
AND AND ALSO ONE THING THIS
MEDINA STAFF. IN THE
OFFICE WHO HELPED US WITH.
HAVING THE.
AND THE STAFF AT UC RIVERSIDE.
IN OUR AND I'LL JUST UGLY GIVE
A SHOUT OUT OF ANY TRANSFER MY
OFFICE.
MONNING CLEVERNESS
CLINTON LISTA.
WE WE JUST SHOW UP THEY'D.
BUT THAT ALL THE WORK SO THAT
THIS ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
SO REALLY APPRECIATE THAT OF
WITH THAT TO GET ONE MORE ROUND
OF APPLAUSE.
AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE A TWO
MINUTE BREAK AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA GO TO PUBLIC.
SO WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WE GOTTA
GET THE PUBLIC COMMENT LISTED.
TRANSITION TO WILL BE RIGHT BACK
THINKS.
YEAH.
RISK. VERY NICE TO ME.
RATHER IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
YEAH MASTERS IN EIGHTY FOUR.
I DIDN'T QUITE MAKE THE LEADING
ACQUAINTED MAKE THE PHP.
THEY.
SO BASED ON.
MAKES YOU.
YOU HEAR FROM.
BUT I STARTED WITH.
RIGHT WITH. ONE HUNDRED
REPRESENTATIVE HERE
I WILL BE A DAVIS.
QUESTION.
WHICH.
WELL.
YEAH.
RIGHT.
LET ME.
YOU.
AND I WANT TO HELP ROBERT AND
TRIPS AND THOSE AT THE END OF
THE LEASE.
LAST NIGHT ALL YEAH.
YEAH.
THIS.
THIS PROGRAM.
WE WE PUT IN ABOUT.
THIS ONE OKAY.
YES. THIS YEAR SEVEN ONE.
OKAY.
NDER.
THE.
SUNLINE.
PLEASE VISIT OUR
.
ABSOLUTELY.
I AND I LIVE.
THE.
RIGHT.
I WAS.
WOULD YOU
.
I THINK THAT'S WHY.
THERE'S.
THE WAY YOU TAKE OUT.
WELL.
THOUSANDS OF.
AND I AND I.
SPENDING.
GIVEN THE.
THE STATE.
THAT'S LIMON IN SCIENCE YEAH
PROBABLY.
NO.
FOR THIS.
HERE IN THE MIDDLE.
MAINTAIN YOUR GRANDMOTHER'S
HOUSE.
WELL I.
IN THE WRONG PLACE NO YOU'RE THE
REQUESTED.
YEAH.
THEY GOT TO.
YEAH NKANDLA.
SHOULD WE SHOULD.
BUT OF WHAT IT WOULD BE SO.
CERTAIN.
THERE YOU GO.
PANELISTS.
THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE BACK.
AND I'VE LEARNED THAT I'M GONNA
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE FOR
BUTCHERING ANYBODY'S NAME.
YOU THAT ARE GONNA BLAME IT ON
YOUR HAND WRITING.
SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH I HAVE
TERRIBLE IN WRITING WE'RE GONNA
START WITH BRIAN HA FROM CFT.
AND WE HAVE I THINK ABOUT
TWENTY FOLKS FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
HAVE YOU CAN KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO.
MINUTES OR LESS THAT WOULD BE
VERY APPRECIATED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I TRY TO KEEP IT LESS THAN THAT
I'M THANK YOU MY NAME IS BRIAN
HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS STAFF.
YOU GUYS PUT TOGETHER OTHER
FANTASTIC HEARING REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
.
THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE DOWN
YOU GUYS
HAVING ARE TO START PANELISTS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
TEACHER UNION DEMOCRAT EVER AND
OUT OF THEM CLOUT.
I'M AND MR MEDINA YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT ABOUT THE
ONLINE COLLEGE AND FUNDING
FORMULA PROPOSAL WITHOUT ANY
FACULTY INPUT.
I WILL TRY TO ADDRESS STUDENT.
ON WE KNOW A THING OR TWO ABOUT
USE EXCESS BECAUSE WE TEACH OUR
STUDENTS.
BUT YET PROPOSALS AFTER PROPOSE
THOSE ON.
POLICIES AFTER POLICIES ON.
DURING THE FORMULATION PROCESS
WE ARE NOT INVITED TO THE TABLE.
I WE DON'T GET ANY INPUT FROM US
ON THIS DAY IN YEAH THIS IS WHY
THESE POLICIES DON'T ASK.
AND THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
PROBLEMS.
AS YOU SAID YOU CAN IMAGINE. ARM
AND I AND I CAN GO ON FOR TWO
HOURS TALKING ABOUT THOSE TWO
PROPOSES WHEN I WOKE. UP.
AND LASTLY CSU YOU FOLK IS IT
HERE AB ONE TWO THREE ONE. AM
CST WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THAT BELL.
.
YOU KNOW IS A VERY GOOD DEL. AND
I LASTLY ONE INTRODUCED MY A
NEPHEW DOT DOT JONATHAN ONE TIME
DON'T.
HE'S A FORMER AIRFORCE COMMANDO.
SERVED ON WHAT TO PUT TOWARDS
OVERSEAS.
AND IT GOT A FULL RIDE TO LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY AFTER SERVICE
SO HE'S ONE OF THE STUDENTS THAT
MASTER PLAN AND DON'T REALLY
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF. YOU KNOW
BECAUSE HE BECAUSE IT TO KAREN'S
ITSELF DECLARE US EXACTLY
CONSULTANTS OUT. AND IF YOU'RE
WONDERING WHERE YOU GET THE GOOD
LUCK TO TAXES YEAH.
IF.
YEAH I LOVE THOSE GUYS YOU KNOW
YOU SERVE THE COUNTRY IS THE
EPITOME OF THE PERFECT ON YEAH
PERFECT STUDENT. ARM AND OUT
PLEASE HELP ME WHICH WOULD ALLOW
FOR AS A FUTURE ENDEAVORS YEAH
THERE'S ALWAYS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE NEXT UP
WE HAVE ADAM WHAT'S MEN FROM
FAA'S YOU SEE. FOLLOWED BY
AUDREY BAKA.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ADAM WHAT'S
MEAN I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE ELEVEN THOUSAND MEMBER
PROFESSIONAL. MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION ADVOCATES FOR ALL
FACULTY.
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOTH
FULL TIME AND PART TIME.
I WANT TO ENDORSE.
WHAT?
MY COLLEAGUE THAT YOU MEAN
BRUNO SAID.
IF WE DO WANT TO MOVE THE
METRICS WHEN IT COMES TO STUDENT
SUCCESS ARE WE NEED TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF FULL TIME FACULTY.
IF WE WANNA MOVE THOSE METRICS
WE NEED TO INCREASE THE
PROFESSIONALIZATION OF PART TIME
FACULTY WHICH INCLUDES OFFICE
HOURS I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA FOR AGAIN
SPONSORING A BILL RELATING TO.
OFFICE HOURS WE WE THINK THAT'S
GOING TO PASS BUT WE'LL SEE IF
IT GETS SIGNED. ARM IF WE WANT
TO INCREASE THOSE METRICS WE
ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT PART
TIME FACULTY HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND GOOD WAGES AND
REHIRE RIGHTS WE NEED TO DO ALL
OF THOSE THINGS. AYE IF WE DO
WANT TO MOVE OF THOSE METRICS
THEN WE NEED TO. ENGAGE FACULTY
AND STAFF AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE CONVERSATION INSTEAD OF AT
THE END OF THE CONVERSATION
WE HAVE BEEN INITIATIVES TO
DEATH.
I WITH ONE AFTER THE OTHER OUR
HEADS ARE CONSTANTLY SPINNING
AROUND IN BEFORE WE CAN EVEN
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT ONE
INITIATIVE HAS ACHIEVED ITS GOAL
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE AND
SOMETIMES THE OLD ONES GET
THROWN OUT. SO WE NEED TO ENGAGE
FACULTY AND STAFF AT THE
CONVERSATIONS ALL THE TIME TO
SEE IF THEY ARE GOING TO ACHIEVE.
THE GOALS THAT WE WANT THEM TO
ACHIEVE ARM WE ENDORSE THE IDEA
OF CHANGING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING SO THAT IT'S
EITHER A CATEGORICAL PROGRAM. OR
SOMETHING THAT IS REQUIRED A BY
THE COLLEGES TO SPEND A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE I'M AS ARTICULATED BY
AYE JULIE BRUNO.
ALSO.
SACK AND ALL THE FACULTY
ORGANIZATIONS I'M SURE THE STAFF
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL ARE READY
TO SUPPORT THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON CRAFTING POLICY FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADAM IN THIS IS THIS
IS LIKE A PUMPED UP CROWD WE GOT
MORE APPLAUSE IN THIS HEARING
YOU.
AND HERE WE THAT YET.
AUDREY BACA FROM C. S. U. S. B.
FOLLOWED BY THOMAS BROUGH FROM A
AYE.
YOU SEE YOU.
SO THANK YOU FOR FOR.
FOR DOING THIS THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS AND THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO THE VOICES.
AND I'M JUST GONNA QUOTE.
CHRISTINE STUCKY AS SHE
MENTIONED IT TAKES ALL OF US.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
LISTENING TO THE VOICES AS YOU
MENTIONED A AND SACRAMENTO. THAT
MAYBE NOT AS MUCH DIVERSITY OR
AS MANY OF THESE CONVERSATIONS
HAVE HAPPENED UP THERE SO PLEASE
KEEP THESE VOICES CENTRAL TO
YOUR CONSIDERATIONS.
WHEN YOU'RE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS AND TO ALSO JUST.
NOT BE THINKING OF. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
BUT AS WE ALL KNOW IN NINETEEN
SIXTY WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
FIFTEEN YEAR MASTER PLAN.
THINKING OF THE FIFTEEN TO
THIRTY YEARS OF THE WORLD THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
I WOULD ALSO JUST ASK THAT.
.
YOU CONSIDER THAT PART TIME.
ADJUNCT FACULTY.
AS MEMBERS OF OF.
SEES ME.
JUST AS AS THE PREVIOUS OWNER
HAD MENTIONED CONSIDER PART TIME
WE NEED MORE FULL TIME IT IS A
FULL TIME JOB EDUCATING THE
STUDENTS AND WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE. DIVERSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT TEACH OUR STUDENTS BECAUSE
OUR STUDENT POPULATIONS ARE
DIVERSE.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
TWENTY ONE THREE.
NEXT WE HAVE THOMAS BROUGH
FOLLOWED BY MICHELLE CANOE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BERMAN AND
THEM MR MEDINA.
MY NAME SOME ASSEMBLY LINE WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE ARE THE
ORGANIZATIONAL VOICE FOR I NOW
EIGHTY A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
LOCALLY HERE ARE CAL BAPTIST
UNIVERSITY AND LAST YEAR
UNIVERSITY.
THE PRIVATE NONPROFIT A SECTOR.
HAS LONG BEEN A PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN.
SINCE IT'S DRAFTING IN NINETEEN
IN NINETEEN SIXTY AND ALSO WE
WERE INTEGRAL IN THE CREATION OF
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM BACK IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE.
A WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A LARGE
ROLE IN CREATING STUDENT ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
IN REGARDS TO A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND FACULTY
DIVERSITY.
MANY PRIVATE NONPROFITS HAVE
SUBSTANTIVE FACULTY DIVERSITY
PROGRAMS.
AND THIS IS A POINT TO POINT OUT
BECAUSE THE PRIVATE NONPROFIT
SECTOR EDUCATES FIFTY SIX
PERCENT OF GRADUATE STUDENTS IN
THE STATE.
THAT'S MORE THAN THIS YES YOU
AND YOU SEE COMBINED.
AND THESE INCLUDE MASTER'S
PROGRAMS PHD PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONAL DEGREES AS WELL.
THAT'S SUCH A DON'T KNOW WE HAVE
A LARGE ROLE IN EDUCATING THE
NEXT GENERATION. OF.
PROFESSORS THAT. END UP
TEACHING AT A COMMUNICABLE EACH
OTHER YOU SEE YOUR S. YES YOU.
OR YEAH ALSO WORK IN LOW SOCIO
SOCIO ECONOMIC COMMUNITIES.
THAT NEED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS AND OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS.
AND THIS IS A RESPONSIBILITY
THAT WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY. AND
WE BELIEVE THAT TO STRENGTHEN
THESE EFFORTS AND TO STRENGTHEN
THAT PIPELINE THAT HAS BEEN
REFERRED TO.
IN PREVIOUS PANELS.
FROM HIGH SCHOOL TO
UNDERGRADUATE TO GRADUATE SCHOOL.
FOR STUDENTS FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND THE STATE NEEDS
TO FULLY FUND THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
FOR STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
THAT.
NEED THE CHANCE TO ATTEND.
THAT HAVE THE CHOICE TO ATTEND
A PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY OR A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION.
AND.
.
NO WELL WE APPRECIATE DEFINITELY.
HALTING THE CUTS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
WE HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
GROW THE AWARD IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
SECOND WE ALSO NEED TO
STRENGTHENED AND DEMYSTIFY THE
TRANSFER PROCESS AS AS HAS BEEN
NO AND I MENTIONED BEFORE.
ES RC SEE YOU IS FINALIZING
SOME BUDGET LANGUAGE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND.
FINALIZING IT AND WILL YOU WITH
THAT THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
IT TO ARTICULATE.
DE SOCI DEGREE FOR TRANSFER A
TO A PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY AND YOUR SUPPORT
OF.
THOSE EFFORTS WOULD BE
APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU TOM ISLAMIST
QUICKLY SAY US SOMEONE EARLIER
USE A HELPFUL METAPHOR A THREE
LEGGED STOOL A AYE WELL ONCE
IT'S REALLY MORE LIKE A FOUR
LEGGED CHAIR.
BECAUSE OUR INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ARE
CRITICAL PARTNER.
FOR ALL OF US.
IN MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS GET HIGHER
EDUCATION.
HIGH QUALITY AND EDUCATION
MICHELLE CANOE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE CANOE AND
I'M WITH BLUE EDUCATIONAL
FOUNDATION WERE BASED AND SALMON
MEDINA COUNTY WORKING A LOT
EXAMINES YOU KNOW SCHOOLS. I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE UP TO YOU
BECAUSE OUR ORGANIZATION WORKS
VERY CLOSELY WITH STUDENTS OF
COLOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS YOU OFTEN DON'T HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY JUST TO STEP
FOOT ON THE CAL STATE CAMPUSES.
AND THE UC CAMPUSES UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY TAKE THEM AND I WANTED
TO REITERATE THE VALUE THAT
THOSE SUPPORT STAFF OFFER ON THE
COMMUNITY CAN'T COLLEGES. AS
WELL AS ON THE CS USE IN THE UC
CAMPUSES AND PARTICULARLY WHEN
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR HOW MUCH IT DOES.
TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO WANT TO
CONTINUE TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IN THE ONCE THEY'RE THERE HOW
MUCH IT REALLY ENCOURAGES THEM
TO STAY IN TO EVENTUALLY
GRADUATE SO I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE THE REAL VALUE OF THAT.
FROM THE K. THROUGH TWELVE ENDS
FOR THE ORGANIZATIONS THOSE OF
US WORKING WITH THOSE STUDENTS
WHO ARE REALLY.
TRYING TO GET ON TO THESE
CAMPUSES AND IN THE LONG LONG
BRIAN THAT REALLY BENEFITS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS THE GOAL
IS TO EVENTUALLY GRADUATE MORE
THE STUDENTS AND CONTRIBUTES YOU
A DIVERSE. AND WELL TRAINED
WORKFORCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT THAT WE HAVE CARLA OR
BONDS YOU CAN THE LIBRARIANS
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FOLLOWED BY JONATHAN
HUGHES.
I THINK YOU I'M CARL RPG AND I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE LABOR
AND ASSOCIATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS THE PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION
FOR ALL YOU SEE LIBRARIAN.
I'M ALSO A LIBRARIAN HERE AT UC
RIVERSIDE AND AN ALUMNI OF YOU
SEE ARE AND SOME OF THE STATE
UNIVERSITY.
I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF LIBRARIES AND
LIBRARIANS IN SUPPORTING OUR
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF.
LIBRARIES IN HIGHER EDUCATION
ARE NOT JUST ABOUT WRITING
ACCESS TO WORK THE WORLD'S
KNOWLEDGE BUT ABOUT KNOWLEDGE
CREATION. LIBRARIES AND
LIBRARIANS ARE NOT JUST ABOUT
WHAT WE OFFER TO OUR PATRONS BUT
WHAT WE DO FOR THEM TO REALIZE
THEIR GOALS WHETHER IT BE
COMPLETING A PROGRAMMER DEGREE.
DISCOVERING NEW INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATIONS DESIGNING CUTTING
EDGE RESEARCH OR EVEN BECOMING A
NOBEL LAUREATE.
WE OFFER THE TRANSFORMATIVE
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND EXPERTISE
TO MAKE THESE THINGS HAPPEN.
LIBRARIANS NOW MORE THAN EVER
ARE LOOKING BEYOND THEIR
TRADITIONAL ROLES AND PROVIDING
GREATER OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EDUCATION EXPLORATION
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. EMPOWERMENT
AND ENGAGEMENT.
THEREFORE I HOPE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE CRUCIAL ROLE. THAT LIBRARIES
AND LIBRARIANS PLAY IN ADVANCING
IDEALS OF PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE HEARTS OF OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES.
I HOPE THAT IN YOUR REVIEW OF
THE MASTER PLAN YOU ENSURE THAT
LIBRARIES REMAIN AN ESSENTIAL
AND WELL SUPPORTED COMPONENT OF
CALIFORNIANS INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
NICK SIMEONE JONATHAN HUGHES
FOLLOWED BY CATHERINE CALLED.
THEY DO SO MUCH I CHAIR BERMAN
AND SELENA MEDINA AYE JONATHAN
HUGHES REPRESENTING AZUSA
PACIFIC UNIVERSITY ONE OF THE
MANY INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES. WERE
PROUD.
THAT WE'VE BEEN PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN SINCE IT'S.
FORMATION IN NINETEEN SIXTY ARE
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL CHOICE
FOR STUDENTS FOR WHOM AN
INDEPENDENT SCHOOL MAY BE THE
BEST CHOICE FOR THEIR PARTICULAR
NEEDS. AND IF YOU HAS EIGHT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LOCATIONS IN
OVER TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AND
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL I CAN SAY
HONESTLY AFTER THE RELATIONSHIPS
WE HAVE WITH MANY OF OUR PUBLIC
PARTNERS IN HIGHER EDUCATION. A
PARTICULARLY THE CCC ARE WE HAVE
TO JUST COLLEGE PREPARATORY WORK
CLOSELY WITH PASADENA CITY
COLLEGE MOUNTS AND ANTONIO
COLLEGE VICTOR VALLEY COLLEGE UP
IN THE HIGH DESERT. AND MANY
OTHER SO THAT'S JUST TO NAME A
FEW I THINK A THEME DEFINITELY
TODAY DURING OUR CONVERSATION
HAS BEEN THE CHANGING
DEMOGRAPHICS OF CALPERS HIGHER
ED LANDSCAPE.
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT.
AT IF YOU THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER TO LOCAL GUARANTEED
ADMISSION PARTNERSHIPS AND AP
YOU JUST IN THE LAST YEAR TO
WE'VE SIGNED FIFTEEN
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR LOCAL QUE
TWELVE DISTRICTS. AND WERE MORE
REFLECTIVE THAN EVER OF THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND THE BROADER CITY
CALIFORNIA.
AND JUST TO MENTION A FEW OF
THE MANY PROGRAMS WE HAVE FOR
FACULTY STAFF.
WHEN IT COMES TO ENGAGING THE
STUDENTS FROM ALL THESE DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS AND WE HAVE JUST IN
THE LAST FEW MONTHS HAD TRAINING
FOR STAFF AND FACULTY AROUND.
ENGAGING WITH UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS ARE FIRST GENERATION
PROGRAMMING PRADA SAY THAT OUR
FRESHMAN CLASS THIS YEAR AT
FORTY FOUR PERCENT OF THEM ARE
THE FIRST IN HER FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
WHERE DIVERSITY AMBASSADOR
PROGRAM THE TRAINING THAT'S HELD
ALL YEAR ROUND FOR FACULTY AND
STAFF ON ENGAGING THE STUDENTS?
AND FACULTY FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS OVER FIFTY PERCENT
OF OUR STUDENTS COME FROM AT
THAT MINORITY BACKGROUNDS AS
WELL AS LGBTQ TRAININGS AND
VETERAN AND MILITARY CONNECTED
FAMILIES HAVE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS THAT IDENTIFY THAT WAY.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
RESTAURANTS BASED CAMPUS AND SO
WE ARE EMPLOYER STREETS WHICH
APPROACH NOT ONLY WITH OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT BUT THAT BEEN
EMPOWERS THEM TO INTERACT WITH
STUDENTS AND A LEAN TO THEIR
STRENGTHS.
RIGHT HISPANIC SERVING
INSTITUTION.
ONE OF ONLY THREE A PRIVATE
CHRISTIAN UNIVERSITY THAT HAVE
THAT DESIGNATION YOU'RE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ANYWAY I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION THOSE FEW PROGRAMS WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR AND
ADVOCACY FOR THE HIGHER ED.
MASTER PLAN FOR SHOULD BE
DRAWING.
NEXT WE HAVE CATHERINE COBB AND
HE STIRS TWENTY TEN FOLLOWED BY
JOSEPHINE THAT CAN CHOLA. FROM
THE POINT OF PROJECT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CATHERINE COBB PRESIDENT OF
TEAMSTERS LOCAL TWENTY TEN OR WE
HAVE FOURTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS.
WHO DO WITH HIGHER EDUCATION AS
WELL AS SKILLED TRADE?
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT CS YOU
WHEN YOU SEE SHOULD BE A SOURCE
OF GOOD JOBS.
AND GOOD EDUCATION FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THIS SHOULD BE
CENTRAL PA Y. MASTER PLAN. OF
KEY IMPORTANCE TO WORKERS HEALTH
AND SAFETY IS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
CSU AND YOU SEE CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO BILLION AS WELL AS EIGHT
BILLION RESPECTIVELY AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
FOLLOWING YEARS OF UNDERFUNDING
ARE SKILLED TRADE MEMBERS AT CS
YOU AND YOU SEE. OUR TASK WOULD
MAINTAINING FACILITIES SO THEY
KNOW BETTER. THAN ANYONE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY RISK THAT
THESE GOING BACK OAK LOGS POSE
TO THEMSELVES STUDENTS AND
FACULTY.
YOU KNOW GOVERNOR BROWN PROPOSE
I READ.
HE PROPOSED AND ALSO REJECTED
FIFTY MILLION FOR CS YOU AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR YOU SEE
AN A ONE TIME FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THEIR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOGS. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
GOVERNOR BROWN DID PROPOSE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
TO ADDRESS THE FAR MAINTENANCE I
CALIFORNIA. COMMUNITY COLLEGES
I KNOW ADDRESSING CRITICAL
FACILITIES MAINTENANCE NEEDS
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY FOR ALL.
FOR ALL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
HIGHER EDUCATION AND NOT JUST
HUMIDITY COLLEGES.
BUT GOVERNMENTS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL CONTINUES A
PATTERN OF UNDERFUNDING THAT
NEEDS TO LARGER DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOGS AND TOO FEW
STAFF TO ADDRESS THE MAINTENANCE
NEEDS. TOGETHER THESE ISSUES CAN
CONTINUE. TO OUT SOURCE WHICH IS
THE PROBLEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN PROJECTS BECOME TOO
EXPENSIVE OR DANGEROUS. TO PUT
ALL.
WE HAVE SAID HAVE SEEN THAT
OUTSOURCING UNDERMINES GOOD JOBS
BY BRINGING IN CONTRACTORS WHO
PAY THEIR WORKERS LITTLE WAGES
AND PROVIDE FEWER BENEFITS AND
IN SUMMARY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS MUST EIGHT
INITIATIVE. TO ENSURE THAT THE
C. S. YOU AND YOU SEE ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED TO MEET THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE
MASTER PLAN WHILE INCREASING
ACCOUNTABILITY. OF THIS UC'S TO
BE A SOURCE OF GOOD JOBS.
AND EDUCATION AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CLASSROOM.
BOTH WILL CONTROL OF ALL OF BY
INTO ALONZO.
YEAH YES GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE MEMBERS MY NAME ACOSTA
FINA CONTROLLER ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF PARTNERSHIPS WHERE
THE WHEN THE PROJECT WITH UC
BERKELEY AND THEY PRIDE YOU SEE
OUR ALUMNA.
WHEN THERE'S A PROGRAM THAT HAS
A THIRTY FIVE YEAR HISTORY OF
SUCCESS SERVING CALIFORNIA FIRST
GENERATION UNDERSERVED STUDENTS
AND ACADEMICALLY PREPARING THEM
TO NOT JUST REACH. BUT ALSO
ACHIEVE HIGHER EDUCATION.
WHEN THAT HAS PROVEN TO CREATE
STRONG PREPARED ACADEMICALLY
SUSPECT SUCCESSFUL STUDENTS ARE
DATA PROVES OUR PROGRAM'S
SUCCESS.
WHAT WE NEED A SIMPLE?
WE NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOME
WOULD SAY SHOW ME THE MONEY.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE LESS THAN
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN PROGRAM
FUNDING AND WITH THESE LIMITED
FUNDS WE START OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND MIDDLE SCHOOL HIGH
SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. FROM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WHEN THAT DOES WHAT SOME
WOULD CALL TRUE MIRACLES WITH
OUR LIMITED RESOURCES.
WE KNOW WE CAN AND ARE PREPARED
TO DO MORE WITH ADEQUATE FUNDING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAY IS JUST A
MINUTE I REQUEST FOR SIX MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION TO OUR
BUDGET. WE HOPE YOU CAN SUPPORT
THIS REQUEST THERE IS NO NEED TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL SUPPORT WENT
THAT HAS A PROVEN THIRTY FIVE
YEAR HISTORY OF SORT OF STUDENT
SUCCESS.
OUR WORK SUPPORTS THE MASTER
PLAN BY CREATING EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY FOR UNDERSERVED STUDENTS
THAT MAIN AB NOT OTHERWISE
PURSUE OR A CHIEF HIGHER
EDUCATION. THERE FOR MAKING
HIGHER EDUCATION AVAILABLE FOR
ALL STUDENTS AND NOT JUST THOSE
THAT ARE BORN INTO SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC PRIVILEGE WE BRIDGE OUR
STUDENTS AND FROM. WOODBRIDGE
OUR STUDENTS INTO BECOMING
FUTURE SUCCESSFUL COLLEGE
GRADUATES AND PROFESSIONALS FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ALSO ENOUGH.
NEXT THAT WE'RE INTO ALONZO
FOLLOWED BY TRAVIS TRADE WERE.
NOPE.
IS ANDREW.
BEIJING WANTS BEIJING TWICE SOLD.
TRAVIS EUROPE.
I THINK YOU MANY THIS TRAVIS
TRADE BETTER.
I'M HERE WITH YOUR SAY COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS WELL AS THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY YOUNG DEMOCRATS.
BOTH OF WHICH SUPPORTED THE
FORTY DOLLAR FIX NOW NOTICED
SIXTY SIX DOLLAR FIX WHICH WOULD
RETURN OF HISTORIC FUNDING TO
THE YOU SEE SEE SEE YOU AND YOU
SEE SEE SISTER A CCC SYSTEM. UP
AS WELL AS DECREASE
PRIVATIZATION WHICH WOULD. ALLOW
STUDENTS AND FACULTY TO GET THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL I'M A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MYSELF I'M ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT AT NOTS INNOCENT SO
COMMITTEE CALLED TRADE DOWN THE
LENGTH.
AND I'M.
I HAVE TO SAY THE. YOU KNOW
LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME AYE AYE AYE
AYE THEN TELL FOR MY ENTIRE LIFE
ONCE YOU CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
AND HIGH SCHOOL I. SH I SHOULD
HAVE GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL IT
WAS IT WAS WATER TO HOW HOMEWORK
ASSIGNMENTS AWAY FROM.
NOT GRADUATING I'M IN TELFORD
COMMITTEE COLLEGES HAVE GIVEN ME
A SECOND CHANCE FOR MAGIC.
SO I'VE GONE THERE AND.
SUCCEEDED BUT IT WASN'T JUST
BECAUSE OF MY QUOTE UNQUOTE HARD
WORK.
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE AN
ECOSYSTEM WHEN WE REALLY THINK
ABOUT IT IT'S THE CUSTODIAN TO
THE FACULTY TO STUDENT TO YOU
KNOW THE LIBRARY.
OF AND REALLY THE FACULTY AND
THE STUDENTS NEED THESE RESOURCE
THIS IS WHAT WE REALLY NEED
BECAUSE I I CAN'T SAY THAT RIGHT
NOW I I'M. I'M ACTUALLY
GRADUATING THIS SEMESTER AND
IT'S BEEN A LONG TWO YEARS.
WHAT WHAT HE MEANS THE SYSTEM NO
I I WAS PLACE IN REMEDIAL MATH
REMEDIAL ENGLISH?
I CAME IN THAT I HAD TO TAKE
MATH FIFTY FIVE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX ONE FLORIDA UNITED ALL
THROUGH ALL THAT AND IT WASN'T
BECAUSE THE NEAREST DEATH IN
TIMES OF NEED THINKING OF
DROPPING OUT JUST SAYING YOU
KNOW IT LOOKS. A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS TO DO THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHER PATHWAYS AND LIKE TO TAKE.
I'M BUT IT WAS THE PROFESSORS
THAT CAN BE AND IT IT WAS
BECAUSE OF THINGS LIKE OFFICE
HOURS THAT I WAS ABLE TO. NOT
ONLY TALK TO THEM ABOUT MY
EDUCATION BUT MY PERSONAL THINGS
THAT WERE GOING ON WITH IN MY
LIFE.
SO IT WAS REALLY PROFESSORS THAT
ENABLED ME TO DO THIS AND SO BY
DENYING FACULTY AND STUDENTS
RESOURCES WE'RE NOT ONLY DENYING
THAT YOU KNOW OURSELVES FROM.
GREATER HEIGHTS BUT WE'RE
DENYING OUR STATE AND OVERALL
OUR COUNTRY FROM REACHING A
BETTER. GENERATION WE WOULD BE
DOING A LOT OF TO WHERE WE COULD
IT POWER GENERATIONS
FOR MUCH MUCH LARGER THAN JUST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN
COULD GO ON FOR YEARS SO WE NEED
A VISION AND A PATHWAY TOWARDS
THE FUTURE TO EMPOWER THE REST
OF CALIFORNIANS. NOT JUST NOW
BUT FOR.
WANT YOUR TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU TRAVIS.
NICK SIMEONE CHRISTIAN HE'S DONE
FOLLOWED BY JAN MUCHO.
THANKS OF I'M A PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY HERE UC RIVERSIDE AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE RIVERSIDE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION I WAS
FINANCED BY THE. COUNCIL OF
UNIVERSITY OF FACULTY
ASSOCIATIONS OF THE UC SYSTEM TO
COME AND BASICALLY ENDORSED THE
AND TELL YOU ABOUT THIS.
SIXTY SIX PICKS.
DOT ORG PROPOSAL THAT TRAVIS
JUST MENTIONED AND SOME OF YOU
HAVE THAT IN YOUR AND YOUR
THINGS BUT OTHER WHAT OTHERS
WANT TO LOOK AT BASICALLY IT'S A
PROPOSAL FOR HOW THE STATE CAN
FIND. FREE PUBLIC EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND ROLL BACK.
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHEN
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN.
AND THEY THEY THEY'RE DIFFERENT
POSSIBLE WAYS TO FUND THIS.
INCOME TAX THE STATE TAX AND SO
ON THAT BASICALLY THE IDEA HERE
IS. THERE'S A THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US IN CALIFORNIA
TO.
HAVE A NEW NEW DEAL AND A NEW
MASTER PLAN AND TO.
GET PEOPLE IN THE THE THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA TO
SUPPORT THAT.
IT MAY TAKE A REFERENDUM BUT WE
THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THIS TO HAPPEN IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS AND SO WE SUPPORT ALL THE
EFFORTS THAT ARE SELLING HUNDRED
MAKING IN THAT. IN THE US IN THE
STATE GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW BUT
WE THINK THERE'S A BIG
OPPORTUNITY IN SAY CALIFORNIA TO
DO PUBLIC EDUCATION RIGHT TO
KEEP THIS PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM WHICH IS THE BEST ONE IN
THE WORLD.
AS GOOD AS IT HAS BEEN AND MAKE
IT WORK FOR THE FOR THE FUTURE
AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU PROFESSOR MOST
RELIGION AND.
MUTO AND I APOLOGIZE BY GOD
THAT NO YOU WERE PERFECT FOR
WRITTEN FOR OF ALL BY JONATHAN
ABBOUD.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN AND MR
MEDINA FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. MY
NAME IS JAN YOU TOM UP FOR AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AT NORCO
COLLEGE.
BUT I'M ALSO HERE REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATION. WHICH IS THE HIGHER
A BRANCH OF CTA ANY.
I SIT ON THE BOARD AS A DIRECTOR
OF DISTRICT QUE. WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY RIVERSIDE COMMITTEE
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
BUT I I REALLY WANT TO SPEAK IN
PRETTY BROAD TERMS ABOUT. MY OWN
PERSPECTIVE BEING A FORMER
ADMINISTRATOR AS WELL AS.
A COMMUTER COLLEGE PROFESSOR.
I THINK THE COMMENTS OF THE
PANELISTS WERE SO RELEVANT.
A BUT I WANT.
KIND OF PERSON INTO THREE. AREAS
ONE IS WHAT I WOULD CALL A
PIPELINE OF DISCRIMINATION.
AND THAT REALLY IS THAT NOTION
OF CHICKEN AND EGG. BUT IT IT IS
FUELLED BY IN MY OPINION AN
ACADEMIC ELITISM. WHERE WE DO IN
FACT IN THE PROFESSION OF HIGHER
ED?
SEEK PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKE
OURSELVES
AND AND THAT IS WHITE WHITE MEN
WHO HAVE DOMINATED HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND I'LL Ó POINT THIS OUT BY
AN EXAMPLE OF VERY REAL EXAMPLE
THE PERSON THAT I KNOW VERY WELL
THAT MR MEDINA KNOWS VERY WELL.
WHO'S TAUGHT ADDICT A COLLEGE
PART TIME FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
THIS WOMAN HAPPENS TO BE LATINA.
SHE ALSO HAPPENS TO BE A MEMBER
OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY. AND SHE
ALSO HAPPENS TO BE OVER THE AGE
OF FIFTY FIVE.
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF A CANDIDATE
IN A IN A POOL FOR A FULL TIME
JOB AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND WAS CHOSEN.
BUT THE CHOSEN CANDIDATE WAS A
WHITE MALE COULD ONLY BEEN
TEACHING FOR FIVE YEARS.
WHO HAD A PHD IN HAND?
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW THE PHD
DOES NOT NECESSARILY MAKE.
A GREAT COMMITTEE BECAUSE
TEACHER EVEN THOUGH I AM ONE.
YEAH IT EXCEPTIONS SUCH AN
ACCORD. ANOTHER ANOTHER THING I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO BEAR IN MIND
AS YOU WORK ON THE MASTER PLAN
IS A GROUP THAT I HAD NOT HEARD
MENTION TODAY. THAT OFTEN SOUNDS
IS SILENT AND THAT IS THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT DIVERSITY IN TERMS OF RACE
WE'VE HEARD SOME ABOUT DIVERSITY
AND SOCIO ECONOMIC CLASS. BUT I
HAVE NOT HEARD ONE PERSON TODAY.
TALK ABOUT THE LGBTQ POPULATION.
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY PERCENT OF
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES IDENTIFIED
AS A MEMBER OF THAT POPULATION
SO THAT IS CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT.
TO WHO WE ARE.
AND IT ERIC AT MY COLLEGE ONE OF
THE THINGS I DID WAS HELP
CONVINCE OUR ADMINISTRATION TO
ESTABLISH A SAFE ZONE.
BUT WE PARTNERED WITH THE DOCTOR
STUDENTS
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT BOTH
POPULATIONS FEAR FOR THEIR
SAFETY THEIR PHYSICAL SAFETY. SO
WE THE STUDENTS CAUGHT THE UNITY
SO.
IT WOULD BE WONDERFUL TO BE ABLE
TO FOR EVERY COLLEGE IN THE
STATE COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY. TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE SUCH A A SPACE
THERE ARE CURRENTLY ONLY SEVEN
LGBT PRIDE CENTERS IN THE STATE.
AT THE COMMUTER COLLEGES.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS WHAT
I WOULD CONSIDER THE CORPORATE
IS ASIAN OF EDUCATION.
AND THAT COMES NOT JUST IN THE
FORM OF THE CORPORATIONS THAT
SPONSOR GRANTS BUT IT REALLY
COMES FROM OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BEING UNDER FUNDED. AND
HAVING TO CHASE DOLLARS SO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS THEY'RE
PARTNERING. IN VERY KIND OF
HAPHAZARD WAYS SOMETIMES WITH
GRANT BODIES BUT ALSO WITH
PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
SEEK FUNDS
SO A FULL AND SHORT A FULLY
FUNDED.
THREE TIER SYSTEM.
OF HIGHER EDUCATION HELPS US AND
IT HELPS ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
INCLUDING UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
HOMELESS STUDENTS AND LGBTQ TO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU JAN.
NEXT TO JONATHAN THE BOOT FALL
BY FRED CINCHES.
HELLO MY NAME IS JONATHAN THE
MOOD I AM IN THE MASTER PLAN IS
MY FAVORITE PIECE OF PUBLIC
POLICY SINCE I WAS EIGHTEEN. I
AM THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
SANTA BARBARA CITY COLLEGE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES I AM THE A PARTNER
OF THE REKLAME CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION COALITION AND. FORMER
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT UC SANTA
BARBARA CURRENTLY I'M A GRAD
STUDENT ANTI ALIEN TECHNOLOGY
MANAGEMENT YOU SEE S. B. I PLAN
TO STRIKE. ON TUESDAY WITH ARE
ASKED ME.
SOMEONE ASKED THE AUDIENCE A FEW
QUESTIONS I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THE
FIRST ANSWER BUT I THINK YOU
GUYS GET THE SECOND TWO.
SO WHAT DO FACULTY NEED A FULLY
FUNDED UC'S YES YOU AND CC.
SO WHAT STAFF NEED.
HE FUNDED YOU SEE IF YES YOU AND
FIFTY AND WHY DO STUDENTS NEED.
A FULLY FUNDED UC'S USE YOU AND
SEE YOU SEE.
WHEN I WAS APPLYING TO YOU SEE
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE REGENTS.
BY FORCE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR. RAISED TUITION BY
THIRTY TWO PERCENT AS WELL
PETITIONS BEING TURNED AND AND
THAT SCARED ME IN MY FENCE WILL
FLY.
IN MY FIRST MONTH AT UCSB THOSE
APPROACHES FOR ANOTHER TUITION
INCREASE.
AND THAT END UP CAUSING ME TO
WRITE MY FIRST PEOPLE IN SCHOOL.
ON THE MASTER PLAN.
I FOUGHT TO PASS PROP THIRTY
BECAUSE IT MEANT MY FELLOW
STUDENTS WOULD HAVE DROPPED OUT
OF SCHOOL BECAUSE OF ANOTHER
TUITION INCREASE THAT WAS HELD A
GUN TO OUR HEAD IF WE CAN PASS
IT.
AND THEN AT THE END OF MY TIME
TO YOU SEE S. B. I WORKED ON A
STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN TO GET
STUDENT GOVERNMENT SUPPORT. A
NEW MASTER PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA.
REGARDLESS OF ALL THIS WHATEVER
WE DECIDE WHAT'S IN THIS NEW
MASTER PLAN THERE'S ONE CONSTANT
AND ONE CLEAR ACTION THE NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN.
AND THAT'S FULLY FUNDING THE
MASTER PLAN.
THE MASTER PLAN AS WE KNOW IT IS
THE BROKEN COVENANT TO THE
PEOPLE BECAUSE THE STATE
OBJECTED ON ITS RESPONSIBILITY
TO FUND IT.
STUDENTS OF COLOR LAUGHED THE UC
SYSTEM NOT BECAUSE THE UC SYSTEM
DIDN'T WANT THE BECAUSE THE
STATE DEFUNDED THE SCHOOL'S
TUITION AS A POLICY. IS AGAINST
USE OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
PEOPLE TO LISTEN CANNOT EXIST
ANYMORE AND THE STATE.
IF WE WANT A MASTER PLAN TO
SUCCEED WE NEED TO FULLY FUNDED.
AND PROJECTS AND IDEAS LIKE THE
SIX SIX DOLLAR FIX TO HAVE FIVE
COPIES OF RIGHT NOW OR REAL
TANGIBLE PATH FORWARD SUPPORTED
BY STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BY STATE
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IF WE WANT TO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM THIS
TUITION FREE OF THE HIGHEST
QUALITY AND FOR ALL IN WE NEED
TO PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTHS ARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. JOHN.
NEXT INFERENCE ENGINES FOLLOWED
BY AMELIA MARTINEZ.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU.
CHAIR BERMAN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY I'M FRED
SANCHEZ THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AT CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND AT THE CAMPAIGN WE WORK TO
ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND AND
SUCCEED IN COLLEGE.
THIS SPRING THE CAMPAIGN
PUBLISHED A REPORT TITLED LEFT
OUT THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT TODAY
AND WHICH FOUND THAT WHILE
SEVENTY PERCENT OF OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS COME FROM DIVERSE.
RACIAL AND ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS
THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE FOR THE
DIVERSITY OF ITS LEADERSHIP.
OVER SIXTY PERCENT OF COLLEGE
FACULTY IN SENIOR LEADERSHIP AT
THE UC CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE WHITE.
SEVENTY FOUR PERCENT OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE MEMBERS ARE
WHITE ACROSS THIS.
AND.
DESPITE FIFTY PERCENT OF.
COLLEGE STUDENTS BEEN FEMALE
WOMEN ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
AMONG TENURED FACULTY ACADEMIC
SENATE'S COLLEGE LEADERSHIP AND
STATEWIDE GOVERNANCE.
COLLEGE LEADERS SET THE TONE
VALUES AND DIRECTION OF THEIR
INSTITUTIONS.
AND WHEN THEY'RE LEADERSHIP IS
NOT REFLECTIVE OF THE DIVERSITY
OF THE STUDENT POPULATION.
STUDENT SUCCESS SUFFERS.
WHEN CAMPUSES ARE INCLUSIVE AND
REFLECTIVE OF THE STUDENT
POPULATION.
CULTURE PRACTICES AND POLICIES
ALIGNED WITH THE NEEDS OF THOSE
STUDENTS.
THEY EXPERIENCE A GREATER SENSE
OF BELONGING AND HAVE MORE ROLE
MODELS WHO UNDERSTAND AND
VALIDATE THEIR EXPERIENCES.
OUR STATE AND COLLEGE LEADERS
MUST GO BEYOND AN INTELLECTUAL
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY. THAT
FOR TOO LONG HAS TOLERATED.
TOLERATED ITS ABSENCE.
THAT'S WHY TODAY WE URGE THE
LEGISLATOR LOOKED LEGISLATURE TO
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR TO
APPOINT UC REGENTS.
CSU TRUSTEES
AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS MEMBERS THAT
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE.
THESE POSITIONS ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO SETTING THE TONE
AND DIRECTION OF THE
INSTITUTIONS THEY SERVE.
WE ALSO URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
REQUIRE THE UC CSU.
IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SUBMIT A BI ANNUAL ANALYSIS OF
LEADERSHIP FACULTY AND ACADEMIC
SENATE DIVERSITY.
THIS AGGREGATED BY RACE
ETHNICITY AND GENDER.
THIS INCLUDES DEFINED GOALS FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
AND IT IS ONLY BY LOOKING AT THE
DATA AND SETTING GOALS THAT OUR
VERBAL COMMITMENTS TO DIVERSITY
ARE MANIFEST.
THANK YOU AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO ENSURE OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES HAVE
THE LEADERSHIP NEEDED TO SERVE
OUR DIVERSE STUDENT BODY.
THANK YOU FRED.
NEXT UP WE HAVE A MILLION
MARTINEZ IN AMELIA'S ONE OF OF
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS.
THAT COME HAVE BEEN OF THE
CAPITAL COUPLE A TIMES NOW.
TO ADVOCATE SO GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN A MEAL.
FIFTY SEE YOU TO.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MANY AT AYE AND THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS DIRECTOR FOR STUDENTS
HERE UNDER A AS YOU SEE I. AM
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO EVERYONE WHO SENT IN THE
PANELS AND SPOKE BECAUSE I ALSO
LEARNED A LIFE LIKE. SOMETIMES A
STUDENTS WE DON'T ALWAYS FOCUS
ON FACULTY AND STAFF WHICH WE
SHOULD MORE IN OUT OF MY WAY TO
A PORT OF. PORT OF THAT'S WHAT
THIS WAS GRAY AT A I LEARNED A
LOT. OF MOVING FORWARD AND
DISPENSE AND MANY TIMES
PERSISTED AND I WANT TO. REMIND
EVERYONE THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FORM A DIVERSE
FACULTY AND STAFF FOR ALL THE
REASONS THEY HAVE HEARD HERE
TODAY. ON ANOTHER TOPIC.
THE UC SYSTEM NEEDS TO STOP
TRYING TO FIND SHORTCUTS WHEN IT
COMES TO EDUCATION. FOR EXAMPLE
DID YOU KNOW THAT AND IT'S A
CAMPUS THERE'S ENTRY LEVEL MATH
CLASSES THAT ARE TAUGHT BY
SECOND YEAR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS.
NATIONAL BE HAPPENING Y. WISE TO
SECOND YEAR TEACHING A FIRST
YEAR ENTRY LEVEL MATH CLASS.
ON OUR OUR LECTURES TAUGHT BY
PROFESSOR BAR LOT WHICH FOR
ENTRY LEVEL CLASSES ARE
SOMETIMES UP TO THREE TIMES A
WEEK. IS TAUGHT BY STE A SECOND
YEAR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS THE
SOMETIMES WE SPEAK TO THEM
THEY'VE ONLY TAKEN THREE MORE
CLASSES OR TWO MORE QUESTIONS IN
THE VERY STUDENTS ARE TEACHING.
ON.
I APPRECIATE EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT THAT DOES TEACH THESE
CLASSES BECAUSE THEY WORK ICED
TEA EIGHTIES AND YOU SHOULD BE
THE CENTRAL ENTRY LEVEL CLASSES
ARE BIG SO DARED TO YOU KNOW OUR
STUDENTS ARE GOING A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
ON MOST OF THEM ARE MATH MAJORS
IN A LOT OF THEM ARE YOU SEE
VERY HAPPY BECAUSE OF THE
WORKING FOR THAT BUT YOU SEE AND
GETTING PAID FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR. AND.
AS MUCH AS I APPRECIATE THEM
THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
OF THE TRAINING THAT THEY NEED
TO BE TEACHING OTHER STUDENTS.
ON A WIDE IS THE UC SYSTEM DO
THIS BECAUSE THEY CAN PAY A
STUDENT HAS. BEEN THEY SHOULD BE
TRAINING DAY THAN THEY SHOULD BE
PAYING TRAIN SOME OF THAT'S
TRAINING HAS A REQUIREMENTS FOR
THIS. M..
YOU KNOW THAT.
A LITTLE SAD M. AND I THINK.
STUDENTS WHO SERVE MORE THAN
THAT THERE'S SO MANY STUDENTS
HERE AND FAMILIES WHO DO
EVERYTHING THAT THEY POSSIBLY
CAN TO BE A YOU SEE ARE. AND THE
FACT THAT SOMETIMES THEY'RE NOT
GIVING US THE LEVEL OF EDUCATION
WE DO SERVE IS.
DISGRACEFUL AND I THINK WE NEED
TO DO BETTER THAN THAT.
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS A LAB
CAN REALLY IMPACT YOUR LEARNING
AS ANYONE KNOWS WHEN YOU'RE IN A
LAB WHERE NO DISCUSSION THAT'S
WHY YOU DO MOST OF THE ACTUAL
WORK WHEN. YOU'RE IN A SMALLER
GROUP AND YOU CAN ASK QUESTIONS
RATHER THAN YOU DO IN A LECTURE
SO. IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
EMPLOYMENT AND IT'S A SERIOUS
ISSUE.
HOME SO THAT'S JUST SOMETHING ON
IT UP TO BRING UP TO NORTH
ATTENTION.
BEFORE I LEAVE I ALSO WANT TO
SAY THAT THE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICE NEEDS NEEDS MORE FUNDING.
ON EVERY TIME I GO AND I SEE
ABOUT FIVE PEOPLE WORKING AND
AND THEY'RE GREAT THEY WILL TRY
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS TO THE
BEST OF THE BILLY I BEEN THERE
MULTIPLE TIMES HAVE BEEN THERE
WITH OTHER STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
THERE WITH MY PARENTS. DICK DO
TRY THEIR BEST.
Y. PERSON CANNOT HAVE HAD A BAD
EXPERIENCE I'M.
DOT ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT BE THE
CASE IF NOT JUST BE ABOUT FIVE
TO SIX PEOPLE WORKING ON WE NEED
MORE PEOPLE AT THE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICE BECAUSE TRUST ME STUDENT
TOUGH QUESTIONS.
I'M WE SHOULD ALSO HAVE A SYSTEM
EVERY SINGLE YOU SEE CAL STATE
INCOMMUNICADO LEGIT WHERE
STUDENTS CAN MAKE APPOINTMENTS
WHERE YOU GO TO A CLOSED OFFICE.
I'M I'M NOT I CANNOT SPEAK FOR
EVERY SINGLE YOU SEE BUT MOST
UC'S I'VE BEEN TO ON THE WAY
IT'S SET UP YOU STAND IN A LINE
THERE'S OVER ON THE FRONT AND.
USUALLY IT'S KIND OF QUIET EVERY
ONCE IN THE PHONE.
AND YOU CAN HEAR. WAS ON THE
FINANCIALLY DEVICES ARE TELLING
THOSE STUDENTS I HAVE HER
MULTIPLE TIMES WE NEED TO PICK
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS IN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS YOU WANNA BE WITH
HIM ALL. THIS IS VERY PERSONAL
STUFF THAT'S BEING TOLD IN A
ROOM FULL OF OTHER PEOPLE ON
BUSES ON THE SEA CHANGE EVERY
TIME I TALK TO STUDENT THAT.
DESERVES TO CONTINUE TO BE A
MOLD AND AND THIS YOU SEE IN
THIS YOU SEE. I HEAR THEM SAY.
WHY DON'T I GOT QUESTION BECAUSE
OTHER PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE
LISTENING? YOU KNOW THERE'S ALL
THIS JUST KIND OF STICK MUSLIM
TIMES AROUND HAVE BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD AN EDUCATION SO I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
DO BETTER AT CHANGING ITS LITTLE
THINGS LIKE THAT. LITTLE
CONSIDERATIONS LIKE THAT THAT WE.
CHANGE STUDENTS EXPERIENCE AT
HERE A YOU SEE I. ON LASTLY
STUDENTS WE WANT WHAT'S BEST FOR
FOR FACULTY FOR STUFF WE ARE
COMMUNITY WE SEE. EACH OTHER
EVERY SINGLE DAY I CAN TELL YOU
PAT T. H. WHO ARE MAY SEEM TO
MEAN HE'LL WALK ON SINGLE SOURCE
STOPPING FACULTY. SO WE WE
SHOULD BE ADVOCATING FOR EACH
OTHER ONE SHOULD BE THERE.
LISTENING TO TURN IN HEARING
EACH OTHER OUT SO WE SHOULD HAVE
MORE EVENTS LIKE THIS THINK YOU
THANK YOUR MILLION.
NEXT UP WE HAVE ALL HUNTER LOW
MILLIE WHO PARTICIPATED IN OUR
STUDENT HEARING AT FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE A COUPLE MONTHS AGO. SO
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN I WANDER
IF YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING. YEAH
ZILLOW EVERYONE.
THINK IT'S IS THAT WE MEMBER
BERMAN SILLIER MEDINA AND OTHER
MEMBERS THE SELECT COMMITTEE
MEETINGS ALL HUNTER LAMELLAE I
MISS YOU TO AND LONG YOU SEE
COLLEGE WITH PLANS TO TRANSFER
TO COUNTY LONG BEACH IN THE FALL.
SO I I'VE DONE SOME WORK ACROSS
THE STATE ON SOME ISSUES AND. I
KNOW WE ALL HAVE SOME
INITIATIVES THAT WE WANT TO PUSH
FORWARD THEY LIKE TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS THE FOCUS MORE ON
FACULTY AND STAFF.
IT MORE.
I'M ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT I'VE
SEEN HER SINGING I JUST CANNOT
GET MY MIND OVER. IS THIS ISSUE
THAT WE SEE A STUDENT ERA WE
TALK TO STUDENT THAT THERE THAT
THEY HAVE TO ATTEND THREE
COMMUTER COLLEGES ARE MORE COMEY
COLLEGES TO REACH YOUR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY. WE
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A PROBLEM WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN YOU DO A
BIT MORE WE NEED TO ALIGN OUR
COURSE SCHEDULING WE NEED TO
OFFER MORE CLASSES WE NEED TO
OFFER. MORE ADAPTABLE SECTIONS
FOR THE STUDENT TO BE SUCCESSFUL
WHEN WE HAVE THE SIMILAR
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH FACULTY
AND STAFF THAT THEY HAVE TO WORK
AT THREE DIFFERENT COMMUNICABLE
EDGES TO BE SUCCESSFUL OR TO
SURVIVE. IT'S JUST ANOTHER NOR.
YOU KNOW I HAVE A PROFESSOR
RIGHT NOW YOU SEE WHO HAS TO
TEACH AT THREE DIFFERENT CAN YOU
COLLEGES.
AND I ASKED HER YOU KNOW WHY ARE
YOU TEACHING AT THREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND SHE SAYS I BECAUSE
I WANT TO ITS BECAUSE I HAVE TO.
SO I NEVER REALLY UNDERSTOOD
THAT AND I I KEEP HEARING IN
THESE MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'RE ALL HERE FOR STUDENTS
AND.
YOU KNOW I KEEP HEARING OVER
OVER AGAIN I WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO BELIEVE IT.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU KNOW STUDENTS CANNOT BE
SUCCESSFUL IF THE SYSTEM IS NOT
THERE TO MEET THEM BOTH INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM.
PERSONALLY IT IS HEARTENING TO
ME TO SEE MY FAIR PROFESSORS
THAT INSPIRED ME TO DO MORE AND
BE BETTER. STRUGGLING WITH
THEMSELVES TO SUPPORT THEM THEIR
OWN SUCCESSES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
.
YOU KNOW I'M SORRY TODAY I DON'T
HAVE ANY ANSWERS FOR YOU ALL
ABOUT HOW TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THOSE SUGGESTIONS ARE SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE BUT I
HOPE THESE OPEN UP SOME
CONVERSATIONS AND OPEN UP A
DIALOGUE THAT WE CAN HAVE MOVING
FORWARD.
TO INCLUDE THOSE MEANINGFUL
DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE BECAUSE WE
WE CAN DO BETTER AND WE MUST DO
BETTER FOR OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF THAT WE.
SUPPORT AND DAILY BASIS
I DO WANNA ENDS UP WITH A COUPLE
PLUGS THE FIRST ONE.
IS THERE WAS A COMMENT MADE
EARLIER TODAY ABOUT THIS IDEA OF
YOU KNOW HAVING A STUDENT'S
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY MAPPED OUT
FROM INSTITUTION TO INSTITUTION.
AND AS A TRANSFER STUDENT RIGHT
NOW GOING TO THE TRANSFER
PROCESS I CAN EVEN APPLY TO
CLASSES UNTIL THE MONTH BEFORE
SCHOOL STARTS. I'M SO I GET ALL
THE LEFTOVER CLASSES I'M GONNA
REALLY BE FIGHTING FOR THE AND
THAT'S A KEY PIECE THAT WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON AS WELL AND FACULTY
WILL BE A HUGE PART IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. AND THERE WAS A
COMMENT MADE EARLIER ABOUT I'M
STRENGTHENING AND IMPROVING THE
CULTURE AROUND SHARED GOVERNANCE
AND AS MUCH AS I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENT THAT WAS MADE EARLY
ABOUT INCLUDING FACULTY STAFF
ADMINISTRATORS AND ALL THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. I DO WANT US TO
REMEMBER THAT STUDENTS ARE
VALUED PARTNER WE WANT
ENCOURAGED THAT PARTICIPATION AS
WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOUR HONOR.
NEXT WE HAVE NATALIE MORALES
FOLLOWED BY ALONDRA LUNA.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS NATALIE MORALES I AM A
STUDENT AT UC RIVERSIDE AND I AM
PART OF THE US IN GOVERNMENT AS
A CIVIC ENGAGEMENT COMMITTEE
DIRECTOR.
AND OF FOR SO WHY DOESN'T
APOLOGIZE FOR MY TERRY TO PEEN
THINKING BACK FROM A MID TERM
REALLY TIRED.
BUT ANYWAYS.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY. THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE PANELISTS THAT
EVERYONE THAT'S HERE BECAUSE OF
THAT I LEARNED A LOT LIKE.
EMELIA THAT.
FROM EVERYONE'S.
RESEARCH AND EXPERIENCES BUT I
DO WANNA POINT OUT A FEW. ON
TOPICS THAT WERE DISCUSSED.
ONE IS.
ABOUT MAKING A FACULTY OF MORE
DIVERSE IN THAT RACE ETHNICITY
AS OF EACH YEAR AND THE OF
RELIGION AND EVERYTHING LIKE
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE.
AS A STUDENT I NEED THAT RAMALLO.
TO TEACH ME OF CLASSES YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE CLASSES THAT
WE LEARN ABOUT THESE ISSUES WE
SHOULD HAVE SOMEONE FROM THAT
COMMUNITY TEACHING THIS.
SO.
THAT'S JUST AN EMPHASIS THAT I
WANT A PET. AND ALSO I WANNA PUT
AN EMPHASIS ON TEMPORARY.
FACULTY I THINK.
IT'S KIND OF RIDICULOUS FORA
FACULTY TO BE WORRYING ABOUT
WHERE THEY GONNA BE REHIRED WHEN
I THINK THEY'RE GREAT PROFESSORS
I WANNA.
HERE BUTTON OR TAKE MORE CLASSES
WITH THEM. AND ALSO THE
RESTRICTIONS OR THE WORRY THEY
HAVE.
A LOT OF PROFESSORS WORRY ABOUT.
ON.
IN GIVING TOO MANY AIDS.
THAT SHOULDN'T BE A PROBLEM I
SHOULDN'T BE WORRYING ABOUT ARM
AND I GONNA MAKE THAT CATEGORY
OF THE HAVING THE EIGHT IF I
DESERVE THE A AS YOU GET THAT
AID NOT JUST BECAUSE. FACULTY
BELIEVE THAT A THE THEY WON'T
GET REHIRED IF THEY GET THEY GET
TOO MANY AIDS. THAT'S SHOULD NOT
BE A PROBLEM.
AND ALSO IF THERE'S SUCH A LARGE
POOL THAT COULD BEAT ARM
PERMANENT WORKERS HERE. WHY? NOT
THAT IS THERE'S ANYTHING WRONG
WITH THIS BECAUSE.
THERE IS AND I BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S.
A STATE FOR OPPORTUNITY MOST OF
THE OTHER FACULTY MEMBERS HERE
ARE FROM OTHER STATES I'VE HAD
MOST OF MY FOR PRESSURES FROM
FROM OUR STATE. AND I BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD BE HIGHER AND OUR
OWN CALIFORNIA WORKERS THAT ARE
ALREADY ON TEMPORARY WORKERS
HERE SO I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE THAT.
AND ALSO MORE FACULTY IN TERMS
OF COUNSELORS.
AND DESPITE YOU SEE ARE THERE.
HOUSE FRIEDMAN FACULTY IS
FOURTEEN.
OUT OF THOSE FOURTEEN E. ARE
LICENSED PSYCHOLOGIST.
FOR THE TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
STUDENT BODY.
THAT'S.
NOT HOURS BUT.
IT'S VERY LIMITED TIME YOU CAN
HAVE. A RESTRAINED TIME WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SERIOUS
PSYCHOLOGICAL ISSUES I SHOULD BE
MAKING ON THE POINT MEANT LIKE
WEEKS AFTER LIKE I'M STRUGGLING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
TO JUST DISCUSS SOMETHING THAT
BALL EVEN MATTER INTO THE TWO
WEEKS.
YOU KNOW SO I THINK MORE FACULTY.
IS VERY IMPORTED SO FUNDING FOR
THESE ISSUES IS.
EXTREMELY IMPARTED TO STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF.
AND YEAH THOSE ARE JUST THE SOME
OF THE FEW POINTS I WANT TO
MENTION AND THANK YOU FOR.
TAKING THE TIME IN HEARING ME
AND MAKING THIS MORE ACCESSIBLE
TO SINCE LIKE MYSELF THINK YOU
THINK YOU KNOW.
NICK SIMEONE ALONDRA LUNA
FOLLOWED BY KILEY SANCHES.
HELLO EVERYBODY MY NAME IS A
LONDON LUNA AND AMY SEE OUR
STUDENTS ARE THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
BERMAN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AFTER LISTENING TO ALL OF
US. AND CONTINUE TO HOLD THIS
HEARING I ORIGINALLY WASN'T
GOING TO BE SO TO BE SPEAKING
I'M GOING TO BE HONEST WITH ALL
OF YOU. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AS A STUDENT OF MYSELF
TO EMPHASIZE A MESSAGE THAT
EVERYBODY'S NEEDS NEEDS NEEDS TO
BE MET.
THERE REGARDLESS OF DEMOGRAPHICS
REGARDLESS OF AGE REGARDLESS OF
GENDER REGARDLESS OF IDENTITY
THE ONLY TO BE MET.
PERSONALLY I KNOW MANY STUDENTS
I GO TO THE RESOURCES ON CAMPUS
AND ACTUALLY UTILIZE RESOURCES.
AND THEY DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
CONNECTING WITH STAFF BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO BE HERE NOT YOU GO TO
THESE COUNTERS AT THE CARE
OFFICE.
AND SEE THEM BECAUSE YOU HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES OR WHATEVER
YOU'RE STRUGGLING AT HOME. AND
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO CONNECT WITH
THEM BECAUSE THE NEXT TIME YOU
GO YOU GONNA BE SWITCHED OUT
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST A LOT OF.
UNDERSTAFFED.
AND ALSO.
ANOTHER FACT IS. YOU ENROLL IN
THESE CLASSES AND YOU'RE ALWAYS
NERVOUS WHETHER YOU ARE GOING TO
BE PUT IN THESE CLASSES AND ONCE
YOU ARE THERE THEIR STUDENTS
SITTING ON THE FLOOR. AND THEIR
STUDENTS IN THE BACK TO STANDING
UP AND THERE SHOULD BE MORE
SEATS AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE AND
THE WEIGHT OF THE SCHOOL OF
DESIGN HAS WORKED IN THE PAST
YEARS AND USE YOUR IS A
BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS. AND I KNOW
EVERYONE WORKS HARD TO MAKE IT A
BETTER CAMPUS EVERYDAY. BUT.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA STATED
IN THE LAST.
CONGRESO HAD LIKE WE COULD GO
TODAY'S A RAINY DAY AND IT'S
RAINING RIGHT NOW AND WE NEED TO
BE FUNDED.
AND WE NEED TO BE MET OUR
RESIDENTS METS THE STAFF THE
FACULTY EVERYONE ENDING IT IS
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
MESSAGE AND INFORM THE I HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE ENDORSED. A
PLAN YET BECAUSE I WANT TO BE
MORE WELL INFORMED AND EDUCATE
MYSELF SINCE I AM THE FIRST YEAR
I'M STILL LEARNING AND GAINING
ALL THESE.
JACKSON EVERYBODY BUT IT'S JUST
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
MESSAGE THAT IN SACRAMENTO OUR
VOICES SHOULD BE HEARD. IF WE
CAN EVEN MAKE IT OUT THERE SO
YOU THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR
EVERYONE FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
LONGER.
SO THAT'LL CONCLUDE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
.
PORTION OF THE HEARING OR
MENTIONED.
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO FOR FREE
TO REACH OUT TO TO MY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR ALAN GREEN
IS THE POINT PERSON FOR THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. IF YOU SEND
ALLEN AN EMAIL WITH YOUR EMAIL
ADDRESS YOU CAN ADD YOU TO THE
LIST SO YOU'RE KEPT IN THE LOOP
AS WE PROGRESS.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO HEAR FROM
YOU IN DISCUSS THE WORK OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ARE ALSO JUST
REALLY WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO ATTENDED AND PARTICIPATED
TODAY.
MY COLLEAGUES ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS UC RIVERSIDE FACULTY
STAFF IN THE PUBLIC IN THE
AUDIENCE ARE FIFTH AND FINAL
HEARING THIS YEAR WILL BE HELD
IN SACRAMENTO IN AUGUST. AND
WE'LL DISCUSS COSTS IN FUNDING
PLEASE STAY TUNED AND FEEL FREE
TO CHECK THE SELECT COMMITTEES
WEB PAGE ON MY ASSEMBLY WEBSITE.
FOR MORE DETAILS OR A RECHARGE
MY OFFICE.
AND.
MISTER MEDINA IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SEE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS IN IN
CLOSING JUST DIRT THAT THANK
EVERYBODY EVERYONE WHO A STATE
TO THE VERY AND AND.
A BIG THANK YOU TO OUR CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC WAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THINGS
ADJOURNED THINKS OF ONE.